OK.
Start.
I don't have to order last minute.
Give me half minutes right away.
Thank you.
Mm.
No, I was like, that's not OK. Yeah,
that's that's that's the visual. Oh,
give me the picture.
Oh, you got it? Yeah,
I think I don't think the sickness.
So.
It's they're doing really good like
unless you go out, I don't know. Yeah,
I mean,
where is before I was like 2 to three
days. We're in the,
I'll be ordered in Minnesota to be able
to go in to.
And it's Vivaldi's. Oh,
is that why I was there? Yeah. Holy ****.
OK, I'll be talking about it.
I was gonna be here, though. Yeah,
that's dope. So in January,
we're gonna do it with the bad budget
review, but.
Super cool. Candlelight.
This is their extra meeting.
We weren't allowed to record during the
summer in autumn and winter, but.
But these, these are worse, right?
But these are better. If they're worse,
when you're rolling, I'm just afraid.
Yes, thank you. Appreciate it.
It seems like meetings.
Reminders inside. God,
it's a big what I did.
I was just letting you guys know the AI
St. audit is what it's going to be.
I'm sure it's going to be our key people.
What's that?
We're glad we did that. Yeah,
Alan will say it. I'll just go over here.
Yeah,
see any books you find property though.
It was, yeah,
it was 22 degrees close and then and then
severe winter's strong one.
They have a lot of you. Good morning.
How are you? Good this morning.
Yeah.
Yes.
Partnership.
Unforgive me.
I'll see you later in a while.
He said they're not an update right now,
so he's still they're trying to duplicate
the entire database in a separate.
But they explain that's why everything's
super slow. It's a simple, easy process.
It's just the pretty quick. Yeah, yeah,
that's quick. So I don't know.
They started the process last Thursday,
so excuse I'll that's our excuse at this
point. I could show you right now.
I'll have because I will told would be
there, you know, about that.
Don't have minutes.
That's that's kind of what I thought.
That's right now. Dave. Yeah, so, right.
Yeah,
there's there's these kind of if you want
to swap through that. OK, can we get one?
No, this one's all right. This is bad.
We're going to test these out today.
It's not a steel officer.
This ain't intentionally what I sent them.
Yeah, it's getting down to it.
So and they've been following this to a
tee allegedly, so I.
I'm unsure where the hiccups are coming
in now, like the SQL Service manager.
Like I have had an issue with it like not
doing the naming,
but afterwards there's like the naming.
I think copies it and does everything
right. I have to mean it. But yeah, yeah,
that's exactly what it's going to be
right there.
And I've been waiting for them to give me
the new port number and I followed up
this morning and I was like, Oh yeah, no,
that's not done yet. I was like.
I've been working on this since Thursday.
Yeah,
give me access to SQL and I'll just take
a while. I have it. But yeah, we have,
we have. All right,
you have access to the server there.
I wish. Also, I sure they have a bill.
They don't trust me with that. Yeah. Well,
the guy that it does is sitting in my
office right now. Oh, yeah. Well,
I can show a lot of bill if you also
might be your need. Yeah,
something important for me to be.
He's over here, definitely.
Then at least you know the plugin is
admin.
So looks like the main goal for today for
the morning is inventory clean up taking
stocks.
My P OS review and answer questions.
Finish the taking stock clean up.
So a good portion of our taking stock
clean up is being cleaned up and they're
putting umbrella so loaded just because
there's some videos that are unfinalized.
So this was over 1,000,000 pounds before.
Yep,
now our on order weight still reflects
the same as because of that and and I
guess one thing that.
I'm pretty sure there isn't.
There isn't a way to batch funds and SP
OS. It's all right.
So I had one client who had not finalized
in five years and so they had some tool
that they used.
There's almost like a script they wrote.
Yeah, there wasn't a script.
There was some,
there was some programs that you can sit
in there and I'll see if I can find it.
But he he he basically.
Showed it or trained it how to finalize
and he turned it off when I came back to
the next door. In fact, he just,
he just left it so that every night when
they left and finalized all their ideas
from that,
they say they like to do it here.
So, ma'am, I can't think who that was.
Let me see if I can find that.
Yesterday's meeting.
Uh.
And I'll have to figure out who that was,
cause I actually not remember who that
was. Man, it was really sweet. Yeah,
it was quick, but otherwise, yeah,
it is PO dot PO. You gotta go with the D.
So.
Dang, I can picture the guy.
I can't think of where he is.
I'll have to find that and see if I can
and and and then you got to figure out
how to use it too 'cause it's.
It's it's a program that's comes on the
you like create short pass and stuff like
the dude was getting like control T or
something like that and it was it was
running stuff impact from what we just
trying to do certain things.
So that's pretty cool.
It's not Power BI. No, it wasn't Power BI.
Um.
Yeah,
I'll I'll have to figure out who that was
and find it. I I don't remember,
but if I can, I'll figure that out.
See.
I thought random.
I'll have to look. I don't.
I can't find it right off the top. So.
So why are these PO open POS?
These are videos from the whole projects
and I guess we never really got it as a
portal or.
Procedures to go back in and finalize and
approve them formally in the system.
So as you said,
I mean close the purchase orders as fully
received.
Can you show us something like what do
you mean by that?
Yeah. So,
so basically this is a purchase order
that has been fully received at this
point and everything that's been on has
been cut off with the exception of the
buy items because not associated, but.
Um,
anything that's great out been associated
with a couple of stuff can be used. Uh,
so on here.
We would just have to essentially for the
PO process follow this all the way
through,
finalize the items in here so they no
longer show on the order in our inventory
system and then approve the purchase
order which would then be.
This can't be edited out to this point
unless you go in and unlock it and roll
with approval.
So with us having the the main issue that
this wasn't added to our.
Process flow initially was this was a
duplicate of it.
We originally used to do all of our
purchase orders in and that was our
governing guide and then this was a
duplicate so that we could generally cut
this and handle all the data.
And then with us switching to Vista,
not necessarily the same thing as we
don't have to break out the line items
and Vista like we were previously
referred to and throw over.
Now it's just pulling the number and
we're tracking the actual details of the
purchase order in here.
So it's something that we just need to
add to our process of once we are now in
place in order,
once we know that it's received and I've
been adding this as a task to shipping
and receiving the received of the final
item, they could finalize the PO and the.
Either me and Tom can go on and approve
it or the shipping's right there.
The process is super easy.
They can go ahead and go ahead and
finalize it.
Do you have companies of P OS that are in
this state? Yes.
And that's where,
that's where if we go into inventory
right now and we see weight on order is 1,
063,145 lbs in here,
but what we actually have for stock.
That is either off the grams or order
materials that have not been processed.
That's why the stock and the order number
are not matching. Technically,
we want those to be matching if we're
following this process.
So,
so there's a half million pounds on the
site somewhere.
In theory, yes. So where the reality is,
reality is probably,
I guess I'd say it's pretty close.
Plus or minus 100,000 pounds.
So.
So what is that? That's like backlog.
That's what? Yeah, backlog and or I can.
I see.
It's actual inventory that you guys
brought against. Yeah, if I go into.
Is this the inventory that drives the
system or is this the inventory drives
the system? No, this is right here.
This is the so.
So whenever our SOP operators have a
usable RAM outside of our or within our
guidelines, so 137,
000 of confirmed stop in the yard of
usable RAMs.
The other stuff is either rejected
remnants from active projects in system
or is allocated to a cut list and is
upcoming.
I know that TSMCI have all those
materials entered in here and.
No TSMC Fab 3,
that's like 169 time in the project,
so that will show in our stock as
incoming, not necessarily see.
OK.
I I sent you an e-mail on it.
It's called Auto Hot Key and the guy sent
me a couple videos you can watch there.
It shows how to do it.
In fact.
ChatGPT show me all the scripts to do it.
But you probably need access.
Yeah,
especially if it's a new program
downloaded.
That's where I'm going to pull up,
but I have to report Keith,
so you don't say anything I need,
but it's going to help us.
I can get downloaded. Well,
he sent me the executive order to do it.
But evidently he took it down or it
expired. Yeah, it it expired already,
so I'll e-mail and see if he'll put it
back up for you.
And is it? Is it version specific?
I don't know really anything about what
he built that is that I'll document
things.
I really think that it probably would not
be version specific, yes or no.
So.
Because the process is I'm assigned in
this so it's the last million years,
so that we have no way of truly tracking.
It's gonna be all.
Yeah,
but and that would be the best way to
look at it is inventory stop.
It doesn't work.
It's just that it doesn't move it just
because you.
No. So once it's received and finalized,
then like you said, right,
you have to finalize. Yeah,
until once it's just received by like
because our current process,
we have to see which receives it.
It doesn't include it from time.
That order, yeah, number, right. Yeah.
Which for reason of like us wanting to
utilize,
it would probably be like a hopefully we
have on order both.
We don't have a true keeper to check that.
Yeah, pretty much.
And and I mean with all the stuff.
It'll become valuable if we're running
lots of jobs and we're trying to,
since we have limited yard space and then
we have a decent amount of space,
but once that starts building up,
being able to look forward as a we have a
project coming in.
This is what we show in stock.
This is what we show on order.
We're projecting another 300 tons of
steel coming in and this is already a new
purchase orders in the system,
but not received yet.
We know that we're going to have to try
and figure out looking for 300,
000 tons of steel. So in order 600,
that's.
It would help our guys for sure,
knowing where their material was at and
and obviously like not having to worry
about a place to put it, but yeah,
like for me it feels like a shipping.
Like the benefited mostly to any forecast
where they can make things out.
Where is it?
We're talking about inventory.
We're talking about necessarily about
locations,
but for us so can you show so because
what what I wanted to make bin location
down in the.
No, it was. It was. It's it's not now,
but we we also have readjusted it once
and now we have the five acres and what I
started to do is do overlays of whip bins
and bin like.
Inventory some locations for for this
very reason. Yeah.
And then other things to it too. Yeah.
So that's what we're going to move to.
Once this area is done,
I want to sit down with Mark and uh,
most likely to get about the battle
between.
Yeah, I can't have a, I can't, I can't,
I can't create these locations.
The player for space is really good,
but really good.
But what this would follow is to show
like how much material we already have in
stock and how much material we also are
projecting to.
Yep. But with us not finalizing,
so we're like currently, you know,
a piece of material comes in and
receiving takes the heat under applies it
to the system to show that it's receiving
attaches the document into our and that's
pretty much the extended process, but.
It doesn't remove it from the delete
order.
There.
So like right now we show that we have
one point. We don't have that,
but because that purchase order isn't
finalized,
that's actually the last piece that you
received, it still shows.
Does that trigger your controller like is
it your controller?
They don't have licenses. They're not.
They don't worry about how much inventory
you guys they're actually carry or don't
carry, no.
Inventory on steel is already more or
less true through the job.
So I don't know why it still should be in
the inventory,
but steel should be doing the balance and
everything else. If they want to do that,
I don't, I don't understand it. Yeah,
I don't think that number is reflective
of the file.
It's stuff that isn't finalized because
like the line that we're on,
you see the selected line says 08.
It was 22 gauge,
just doesn't have a weight yet in the
system.
I'm thinking that doesn't reflect the
number that of the stuff that isn't
finalized.
Yeah, it's 241927.
B2B does have volume. So yeah,
just don't like much.
1.25 lbs a square foot.
Sure.
Yes.
Yeah.
The white.
Uh, on order, I think is the same there.
Yeah.
So that is reflective of what the system
sees us on order.
So either there is a lot of, there is 1.
1 million lbs on water or else there's a
bunch on EA's that just that.
So one of the two.
Yes, I would really let me check on.
I will do jobs.
Yeah.
Is there stuff in here that on P OS that
is not steal?
Like sometimes people will order paint
and stuff and they should never receive
it. Yep.
Chance as well.
And one big one that I've seen in the
past is test jobs.
I'm like when we've had trainees or new
employees.
Like this, like that one.
This is.
But the steel that will never be received
in.
Yeah.
So at that point you can just delete that,
yeah.
What I don't understand is what we have
interiors in here,
whether it's not outstanding.
So why do you guys run test stuff on a
test environment?
I'm used to the database,
which the whole company runs off.
But we do training all the time.
We would just go into a test company and
do training in a test company and not
commingle.
Those two entities don't do any training
in the real company.
It's easy to delete them out.
We can get them in and delete all that
out. What is the standard? I mean,
but there's next 10 units probably.
Yeah.
It's not messing with your data.
Yeah, I definitely.
The uh the.
A huge portion of us not because we've
we've only ever ran with the with the one
company in here and with us creating the
new electrical database and so we've
never really had a testing environment
that we've ever implemented.
So uh,
that's that's probably an issue there.
These it's not.
I think there's only the PO itself.
I don't think it'll let me with these
items being it should. It should.
It's also not finalized or anything.
Yes, bro. Good to leave if you.
And I cut this or cut off from whatever
whatever was associated with it, so.
But in theory,
considering that mass appeal just cleared
out.
49 and the 7000 so even that doesn't make
sense because that one order was only
showing 87 right? I don't know man,
that was a hell of an RFQ or a hell of a
Pl. So but but I I don't agree but.
Which shown 8787,000 lbs. So how would we?
Both of them were selected and there was
80,
000 pounds of oh wait that I deleted out
and nobody freaks out about those numbers
being there. No,
nobody sees me and I right now to look at
it, honestly.
So ideally with us pushing towards this
integration,
we'll track and push some of our purchase
service back and forth between some of
our material purchases because I know
that they're.
Their ideal goal with our syncing Vista
is to sync labor codes.
I'm pretty sure that's not an option at
this point as of yet.
So we talked a little bit about that
yesterday and my understanding from what
you explained it is.
Technically pushing into this,
but just as a question, is that correct?
Well,
the only thing technically pushing into
this is PA use, PA receipts,
and then transactions.
So we still are going to do that same
thing we already currently have.
It's a push that doesn't have to.
It's a, you know, for, yeah, yeah,
it's just to create an import export in
the background. So,
but it takes human intervention to force
it or it just once it's entered,
it actually narrows it over.
You can set it up now and do it all.
So,
but the or you what are you guys doing?
Are you physically pushing for for like,
so let's say you're a PO.
Are you physically pushing POS in the
Vista? No. How?
How do you get it in the Vista?
You can manually get to it.
Yeah, we go in weeks creation of the PO.
Yeah,
that's what we talked about yesterday.
We have to create the PO and generate it
in Vista to get the PO number. Yeah,
take that PO number,
then create the PO in Tecla and take it
in. I got you.
I remember that conversation. Yeah,
it's true.
I guess my thing is,
is would there be the could could we take
it from Tecla and have Tecla just create
whatever PO number it is right?
Just start a PO1, just work our way down,
right?
But then when it pushes it into Vista,
have Vista create the PO that it needs to
port it.
It'll only pull whatever information type
tells it. Yeah,
it'll that's the PO number in Vista, yeah.
So that's where it's like, either way,
we're still gonna have to go into Vista,
create the PO just to get the stupid PO
number that they want, which that sucks.
But I don't have my company number.
It's what's the company number? It's well,
our POS are 41, so the 36, yeah,
because they closed out company 36 when
our company 41. That's a PO number.
I can't be because I we got orders for 42
liter, but it keeps going on.
I'll start with a 49 instead of a three.
So it's not just three.
I don't think we got to that point here.
Well, we will.
We eventually will and that's fine. Yeah.
No, that's all right. Yeah.
Outside of my view green on that one,
that's for sure.
Yeah, but I'm here as whether it would.
Yeah, once again,
don't don't break something if this is
working,
but if I'm wondering if it would kick it
over, kick the information over there.
If uh, it was already created in Vista.
But yeah, do you have to double receipt?
No, it's interested in that club.
They don't.
And what close is it out in Vista? I mean,
once they send their big problem,
they pay still asking this question.
We're bringing stuff on PO's in Vista and
then we're not receiving it,
bringing it in and then they and then how
do we backlash it?
We so with Pro 4 they used to verify,
right?
They used to make sure that it was
received, but now they're.
I don't know what their process is
foundation with our.
And stuff like that, right? Yeah,
this is what I that stuff is supposed to
happen.
Tech doesn't look like a piggyback to
that, you know,
the accounting side of things, not so.
That's a very. This isn't.
This isn't necessarily.
Approving it though,
showing that it's been received.
At least that's not the way it was
explained to me. This is exactly.
I go through these.
I have my purchase order.
If they invoice me for something that
I've already received or something that
we haven't received yet,
I will decline decline.
I will not allow them to dig the inside
so you can find those over the top.
You have two types of approval.
Yeah. So the other one's like, yeah, OK.
So like Gavin was just explaining,
this is our check, I guess,
of these would be orders that we place.
Yep, which I get. But here's my,
that's the thing,
but but sometimes they send over from.
Some for approval and sometimes they
don't. You get more than I do, yeah.
And I know for sure I'm placing more
still orders than you are now.
So it's like there's no reason.
Bank not only should, I mean,
you should not only get mine also,
you know,
like you you should be getting mine and I
should be getting mine.
And once you see that I've approved it,
you know that I've gone through my check.
To make sure that it's been received,
make sure that we aren't getting
overcharged. But like,
I get it once for paint, like for sure.
And that's about the extent of it. Like,
yeah, no, I get billing, I get paint,
I get any random order and once I approve
them, then they go to March.
But Mark usually just pushes them to make
sure everything shines with what we
originally went for. Good point.
So but that that is there if you ever be
appointed it it will do.
The PO of receiving annual.
So that's why things are absolute. Yeah,
that's definitely something we're going
to want to use going forward,
but if you still have to go and create
the PO.
It's just adding a lot of adding a lot of.
I think that's cover somebody just trying
to push it. Yeah, I mean,
what's what it should be pretty seamless,
but yeah,
it's there if you need things for me.
What we we used to have is something to
wear to tell the videos or whatever and
we push it like into the night,
but I don't feel like.
Yeah, we've used some new.
We had QuickBooks. We had foundation.
There's, yeah, foundation.
Each one's been different of I need to
put specific quantities, material sizes,
lengths when I.
From all the way down to to over here,
I can put it with you.
So now you wouldn't need to set up house
codes and or face codes in here that will
match.
So Pierre would have to have that on it.
So that's where it's a lot of times most
of our base coats for material are
relatively similar,
but like this elusiveness metal shop,
we're gonna have 60 different sequences
and each sub block is gonna have its own
material base coat.
I'll get it there and sequence form lot
one is going to have 083000 dot 01 and
then lot 6 will have the same base code .
09 and it's kind of all over the place.
Yeah, if if the.
You can set it up so that shapes have us
have like a false.
It's got your face in in in a Vista.
She set it up so a shape has a default
one and just pops it on there so that it
was always the same things.
Right. But if it changes all the time,
then now you got Monday in the year,
then yeah, it might be back and forth.
Yeah,
it'd be one thing if we had a dedicated.
Accounting personnel that was working the
data back and forth. Yeah,
but it's and even then I'm sure that they
would get to the one where they're like,
OK,
we're defining the standard on this
because this is just ridiculous. Yeah.
So which I don't,
I don't think it's out to the wrong
because they have a pretty good breakdown
of.
This is what should go here,
and This is why. Yeah, big Excel sheet.
It breaks down why these things go to
what? Yep.
So they would just have to expand on
material for surely. Yeah, instead of.
Field oriented difference point, yes.
Now the the estimate can you bring me
down the the the cost is in a year you
can send us an estimate just
automatically breaks it on the cost.
If the cost schedule changes by a lot of
items, that's something you want to do.
Yes,
I which I'm assuming somebody somewhere
is taking the estimate and breaking it
down by cost getting anybody to give to
them.
So but the estimate can do that for you.
So yeah,
251819 is probably a good example.
Yeah.
Oh.
Do you have any issues with three drives
this morning? No,
I just you didn't want to just read this,
but that's not actually working.
Are you Jada or?
It must have just happened a little bit
earlier.
Hello.
2025 I shouldn't have to wait this long.
But he sent me a new link.
Yeah,
I can set that up in the background so
that runs.
I don't think it's a bad idea to have it
as a part of our process.
This is the checks and balance.
But if I can get that automation set up,
yeah, then because it's not.
Our check process and receiving items in
it's essentially our final step.
We just want it to be clean.
I would rather have it be clean so.
And like these guys, when I got there,
when they tried to open up inventory,
it literally took like four or five
minutes to open the inventory because
they had so many line items in there
because then and they were kind of.
Fudging it because they had an automatic
filter set for everything greater than 0,
so they never saw it. But they're like,
why is it so? Yeah, yeah,
this is a typical, typical breakdown.
Facebook's relatively similar, but then.
Different call outs in the back end of it
and.
Base codes are generated by Hemington.
Base codes are generated by Ryan Collins.
He takes our estimate exports and then he
associated associates the base codes
based upon the long rows hierarchy that
they have for the type of labour area of
labour.
And associated um.
Trade. So a human does that.
If if you go into estimating,
I'll show you how that can be set up
since you're.
Cost codes or or phase codes are used
kind of depending on how the material is
used. It makes it more difficult,
but if you go to, yeah,
go to company standards.
No,
go back up there and go to fabricator
information.
Maintenance excavating, yeah,
and fabricating information about 5-6
there from the top and then cost periods
is at the bottom.
So you go through and set up the cost for
all these different areas.
And then you got labor rates where you
could go in and you could assign a cost
per labor rate.
You can do it on estimate extras,
you can do it on shapes.
So if if you set all that up then at the
end of the estimate.
You know this with summary that's in
there it can.
There's an option in there break this
down by the cost code and it uses this to
break it all down.
Now with your with it changing depending
on how you're using it,
you're going to have probably some manual
intervention in order to make that work.
Yeah so.
Watch out so I get it to you.
I think about 75% of them.
They are a bolt is a bolt is a bolt that
is the same cost.
A beam is always the same cost that that
makes it easy where it's just it's just.
But if it changes the wrong material,
that's going to be,
that's going to be some main alliteration.
So yeah, that's for sure.
And and the value of having it be one
line item per item that we can look at a
historical data on it would be easier to
on a Costco basis as well.
Whereas we don't,
I like you couldn't tell me how many,
how many beans you bought in the last
year right now. OK,
you don't have Costco's tied to it.
I can just just send my inventory
information.
Filtering for for what's been on order
and everything and I can go back to my
purchase history and everything and look
at previous pricing for who I've ordered
based upon vendors and shapes and the
grades and so like if an estimator
reaches out to me and they say hey.
I don't have time to get an estimate
pricing on this.
Can you tell me what the last date for
wide flange for 10 inch wide flanges?
Just give me a range of sizes and I'll go
in here and.
Maybe this all out and.
Selecting group sizes and that's not
self-serve for those guys.
They'd have to have you intervene.
They can't just self-serve them. Yeah,
they don't.
They don't know what they don't know what
to do. So I wish I hear you so.
Yeah,
essentially going here and I'll sort by
date.
And so this one's a hard example because
it's 2024 and I can tell you right now
I'm confidently pricing exchange from
them and even back then in 2024 we
weren't always put in the pricing.
Um, getting sparse in here, so uh.
It's fine.
It's like 20 minutes.
So these will be in my I can say 7166 to
$0.
74 if you go in and that looks normal and
then that will give you at least a
baseline of what we've paid in the last
few months and I'll take the average.
How is $0.25 underweight in here?
25 cents underweight?
This would have been before we were
putting full breakdowns of of materials
in there.
So if we look at an old purchase order.
Some of these 22 jobs, this one,
that's bad. It's bad.
We don't need new webcams for not going
away to the lead series. Yeah,
essentially a lot of these we wouldn't,
we wouldn't put a line in them every
single.
Um,
every single price in here and cause
essentially our pricing was tracked in
the PO system.
So as long as we knew if we were per
quote, we put the quote price in,
generate the PO,
attach our quote we got from the vendor
and then this was more of.
Tracking lengths and quantities.
Now however,
with our new projects and everything,
all of these are getting broken out for
their specific pricing and cut weight or.
Cut the price that we're doing with
Dave's promise and along with Davis
getting entered in there so that our
historical pricing has a lot more
accuracy, so.
Yeah, that was early stages.
No reason we couldn't have been broke out,
but we just didn't get that way.
I'm on and purchase for members finished
through side.
See if there's anything else.
Which you can stop.
Sure.
Um.
Cool.
The.
OK.
News.
As long as we've got you here,
we want to have you do something.
Yes.
Anything on this?
Just thinking quickly.
Yeah, so they should be all jobs,
anything from 2022 to 2024,
anything that's not in our inventory
allocated spot. So from here.
I can do this whole piece.
These are all projects,
so that'll clear up the last bit.
It's going to take a minute to think,
but I should clear up the bottom of this.
Yes, for items with the marks on hold,
continue with on hold items.
2.
Uh,
these are the for the trestle that we
don't need that we purchased.
Are we positive? We won't hear anything.
Yeah, I followed up with Gary last week.
He said. OK,
so the work is the worst thing I have
left to redo it.
I got all of this done in zero hours and
0 minutes.
Oh, that's nice. Man,
it took too much of A thinker this
morning. Right in the middle of that.
That's bad. That sucks. OK. Is your set,
by the way,
the retirement agreements the inventory
servers are from the government?
Yes, by me then,
I think whatever it returns to.
In responses.
Thank you.
Yes.
OK.
But.
OK.
Not sure anything.
Yeah.
Yes.
Command needs to start. This is all jobs.
Yeah.
It's been because I've been clicking too
fast.
It switched to 2025 I go from one screen
to the next and then the next and moving.
OK.
Is it think?
Totally forgetting to.
I'm just going to wake up seeing these
shorter days.
Well, you went from down to 318,000, yeah.
It's.
OK.
Isn't it the main authority?
What we're also looking at is the we have
some extra budget on one of our projects
that we are going to use for.
Interested.
Yeah, that's your last name.
That's what I was wondering too.
Yes.
Uh.
But I reached out to the progress Rep to
purchase the progress integration. Oh,
go with them so that we can get that
going because they know that we're we
have a huge amount of off that runs from
the play machine that can be better
tracked with the inventory system that's
available in progress. OK and then having.
We went link back and forth with that we
have. So yeah, so that's one thing.
And then also purchasing the additional
modules which isn't really relevant to
Tackler, but being able to comment like.
Yeah, edge cut and everything.
That's going to certainly come to you.
So if you have trouble,
let me know how Chris would help me.
My guy Chris would help me,
so I forgot it and work on that
integration.
We'll provide that.
That is what you got that long iteration
plan. That's what. Yeah, that's one.
Hopefully,
hopefully we'll get a response this week
so I can get a purchase and then we can
have all the information that you can at
least get the process started.
That's huge. So that that would be.
There's no reason why we shouldn't and.
Not necessarily that we haven't had the
value for it,
but if me and Alan are any of your
purchasing and working with your
programming anyways,
there's no reason why we shouldn't have
that.
You have way better tracking of your
plate and your inventory for it, so.
Oh,
so that's the one area we struggle the
most with when your links are really easy
to track and yeah, but.
Putting when it gives us the you not
using this much square footage of your of
your thing,
it's going in squares and rectangles and
coming out with pitches, slopes,
cutouts and so yeah.
But OK, we'll see back out.
Now we're back.
The stock's a lot better.
I order's a lot better.
See that was.
Let's really see here. Uh,
I think a lot of the rest of it's just
going through. So we finalizing.
There's a lot of this stuff from the
bottom. It's all finalizing.
So is there a room that's back in for
those jobs we that you just got for that
last smaller portion with the exception
of that one that I had to nullify because
it.
Wouldn't let me, yes.
Let's see.
Sure.
So very much.
Yeah,
it looks looks like there's anything
right.
So they're not very anything with remarks,
inventory, Alex, our archive,
we spend it on it or there are all the
time.
That's where he checks his confidence.
Basis. Since we had such a mess in here,
anything that he verified person of the
tape measure had the numbers,
everything per AISC,
he put his remarks against that.
So we kind of kept to them anytime
something comes off the side and it has a
heat number tracking TR something.
The location. Um,
the operator will assign that remark to
it. So it looks like everything else is.
I don't see if it would, yeah.
Let's give us a support team.
Interesting.
Hey.
Yeah, so.
OK.
This piece I'm able to see this screen.
I don't even know what this is.
That's really weird.
It was talking when I was.
Yes, actually.
Why don't you do it in the other material?
Or the truck without the long holds.
Apparently did some of the.
The potato. You know, that's so,
that's so, but longer.
It's delivering only a mutual freaking
baked potato.
It's happening while we're on,
so while we're on, so we're closest.
All right. That's great.
That's good for six. I just like so.
Oh, I got it. I'll take care of it. No,
no, no. You guys,
you stay focused on this.
Let me handle this. He's, he's,
he's being at home with COVID and he's
going crazy. So he feels.
Useless. I'll be able to. Can you?
I've been on the phone since 6.
So for these purchase orders,
I went in and finalized them again.
Are these hanging out today? So yes,
I have the show finalize purchase orders
checkbox off.
Is it because there's bio items on this
that it won't?
Think those 'cause technically,
these binaries aren't marked as received
at this point. Yeah, that would be.
I can believe it.
No, you don't have to block it by the way.
Oh, OK,
just just so one of those will be
finalizes all you have to do.
You can do the processes if you want,
but you don't have to or to to get out
any so that.
I'll follow up.
OK,
so do you want to see finalizing those
bad boys?
This one you can see how he's done.
There's other received divers,
so that's why I said OK.
So I guess I can just push those through
and see them.
'Cause these are all old P OS,
so that's what I'll do at least.
Actually.
OK.
These are not watching, I mean.
Yeah.
They're about five lives on this evening.
Take care of the workshop you've done it.
We don't know. I so.
Let me see the checkbox. Oh,
finalize and receive. Yep.
Yeah, that's really.
Plus it gives you the option, hey,
do you want this to go into the inventory
or do you want to go to the inventory
history?
That way you have to go to the inventory.
Where do you guys run? Job costing here,
average costing, standard costing here.
There's none. Um, we do really both,
I think, right?
We do job costing and standard costing,
yeah.
Yeah,
that's totally you run an accounting
system.
Well,
you said you'd use the wrong word right
there normally, but yeah, doesn't matter.
It just matters how you treat you.
Most of this job.
I'll be honest, I'm not really.
I'm sure to follow that.
Job costing.
You just take the cost to buy silence
with jobs, standard costing.
I would cost less inventory and silence.
No. So it my guess is the job then. Yeah,
jobs specifically for sure.
I like job costing better.
We do this more accurate that way or it's
easier that's for job costing,
but it's harder like if you have a lot of
standard products.
You know, get to share the cost,
like if the cost is in March and
difference in September.
This is the average costing,
then we don't need to do anything the
same for us. So what happened?
The only time people looking for the
swapping and then I'm saying that for us
in the shop that we don't do like art.
It's always different things that we're
working on. It's never like.
A standard.
The inventory in here is actual.
It doesn't do average LIFO,
LIFO doesn't do any of that.
So unless they're doing something on the
back end somehow that this is actual cost
in European.
Stops in.
What he just mentioned is what ends up
happening in.
But you guys don't product focus as much.
Yes.
And that's probably process you can
automate with that little tool as well.
But yeah, I've I've been using tools,
so yeah,
it's definitely something I want to dive
into.
So I can make that process going into
level. Definitely eliminate a lot of this.
Yeah,
this a lot of these projects through 1179,
this is the intel.
So a lot of this is about Unistra and
then.
All these fittings, we got 10,
100 fittings, like, yeah, 40,000 of these.
So it's, it's interesting, yeah.
Now, some of that stuff now,
people start using.
If there's stuff you're not overseas,
some people start using subcontractors
for that because every single door and
yeah, it's just.
That's Mark, yes.
I get a question like that. All Chair,
you know, I mean, it's wide open.
It's just use the same case both the last.
We don't have requests, we don't have.
You know, we have processed procedures,
but it's not there.
We've got the same request and say, hey,
she's his credit card number real quick.
We never really want.
I've been in charge for about a month and
1/2 and it's like a list of things that
need to be addressed.
It's it's a lot.
I'm just surprised your controller
doesn't just lose her mind.
She's too busy to get along with other
stuff.
But she's when I talked to her when I
first started,
she said we're a bunch of high school
students pretending.
Question one and I think that every, yeah,
you're right.
Early 2025 we're looking at.
Documenting all our partner orders
through this and um.
That process went for about a month. Uh,
I mean that should be a good.
When I was in,
I used to track everything down to not
Washer. We were getting it.
I'm going to screen an appeal for it,
screen the location for it.
We were tracking, yeah.
Here it's kind of got the money because
for a while there that was passed on.
The project engineers ordered anything
spec related to your project and we were
just ordering steel and then we kind of
got money again there.
We're now needing to order it because we
order things and.
Some PE do it, some PE don't.
And so then we started this process and
didn't see it through so.
I'm open to anything you can't see at
this point. I'd rather have about it.
I love them both. I mean,
that's what gets lost, right?
So I love it in the year and I love them
receiving it just like they do a B or
whatever that and you got tracking on it.
I agree with that wholeheartedly.
First thing you get bosses.
Where's my pulse? Yeah,
when I started doing that,
at least I had a five chance,
but I'm maybe you didn't want to put it
in the issue. We start trying to partner.
Well,
right now we receive stuff in two
locations. Yeah,
I'm trying to bring it all under one.
I'm going to get those two trailers
pulled out of that dock warehouse and
everything goes to the warehouse and gets
broad.
You can see puts everything on the
Smartsheet so we have at least some sort
of record and stuff.
He can move over and start steering that
button.
Sorry, that's all. Hold on.
Are your bolts all inventory and then the
one that's not due to return stock?
So you know what you have or you know we
returned some stuff to stock,
but we're trying not to carry it if we
got paid for the equipment.
For the items, but when there is,
I'd rather return it and pay a stocking
fee if possible, which is very right.
Don't want to carry the inventory because
everything is so unique. Yeah,
and then common stuff it'll it'll keep on
hand.
But everything comes in and gets grouped
together by job,
put on the tablet on the shelves and
noted the location.
So instead of having to do the choice,
but so that's where job cost take works
because everything is about job.
If you were running inventory exhausting,
they could. Let's say you stock one inch.
We think you're 25 hours. Oh yeah,
if you were to do inventory graph,
then you would be, yeah,
we wouldn't want to have inventory graphs.
It's a big problem in the pain.
This and that.
30 drums of waste black bean inventory on
paint and plums. Every time you do it,
let's say you did 4 fourth quarter with
100 tons.
Just have enough of inventory.
You don't buy it.
You buy every time 10 truckloads.
We stopped more stuff here to be to be
honest, and it's still at around planning.
We should go through it.
I think I can see it plans to have to do
things like that,
but it reminds about myself.
Oh, OK. Besides,
how many is the restaurant there?
The long windows are man.
At least you guys don't have to manage.
Well, that's what we're gonna do.
That's what I'm doing.
We'll take what he's doing now,
which is tracking it in Smartsheet. Yeah,
and and move him over to tech tech list.
So that way it's tracked.
We'll have to do both.
I think 'cause so I have to check with
someone on top. It's so stupid.
Probably you know,
it's like that was my question,
like why you do Smartsheet?
Aren't you receiving it in this type of?
This they should receive against the and
show it that it's received and they're
not. They don't do that.
There's none of that, no.
But somebody does. No, it's like,
I don't know how I I PO will stay open.
PO will stay open if they.
Pl. The Pl.
stays open until the invoice comes and
then the invoice is approved through the
approval system and then it's done.
That's fine.
All everything in between normal
operations or books you would consider
one of those come on.
There's none.
And that's what I would like because then
you can instead of, you know,
going to the system and see it, you can't.
I I'm used to knowing when things are
received from my system and knowing when
invoices are paid. Those are separate.
Things. So you know, hey,
I got it in the system and hey,
it was paid for in the system.
Those are separate statuses and that's
one of the reasons I think that we really
want to put everything in this shop on
tech because then we can send it through,
we can run it more traditional and
sensitive.
We have visibility on everything as it
moves. And right now, like I said,
physically they receive some stuff at the
shipping office and then some stuff to
the warehouse and physically we can't do
it because we have too much junk.
In the yard. So now we have this jar.
I don't want to get these trailers that
are in our warehouse stuff out,
start receiving and all the receipts go
through that by the warehouse and nothing
goes over to it.
It goes on a physical rack out.
And anyone can just walk up and take
whatever they want,
but we have a big problem with that too.
I think the one with the balls in Europe
has a decent production because that's
the other side of it is it even
membership bolts.
So a lot of people would just they are in
the production withdraw order from there
and they all kind of.
That's, yeah,
that's where they they build the um.
You know,
and they should be supposed to be worth
protective.
So we see what the the POL is as it's
still ordered and that's the next step to
it.
You have like each process that we're
looking at,
there's multiple broken pieces in it.
It's just broken all over.
So we start with.
Control. First of all,
it's not the ship and then next is
getting shipping on them.
They know where to go to get it.
What's it's it's a possible kind of
vaccine.
It.
OK.
This is a tedious promise.
I walk in the middle of the road, not.
I don't care. I gotta do what's right.
It's just this.
So when the field guys are missing
something.
What happens? Who? Who do they go to?
Omar first and then you.
But what they do is they the field guys
have POS like PM to the PES.
They let Omar know they they actually go.
They're supposed to go and put it on the
Smartsheet. So now we have.
That's like a record of it.
Then he receives against against sort of
the smart sheets,
tells them that it's there,
and then he builds pallets of all their
all of their parts and pieces and then
labels it and puts it on the rack and
then notates the location of.
And then on the Smartsheets.
And then when they need it,
they go to the warehouse and they ask
them to load it. If something's missing,
then it's all overview.
They're generating deals on listed, yes.
What we did is we walked in the list,
people like myself and we walked into
these messes and the first thing we do is
we we're trying to clean everything up to
make it manageable and then we start
focusing on how we're going to streamline
this moving forward.
So those,
that's kind of the phase where we're at
right now. If it was first the warehouse,
anyone could walk in there,
I saw it and then we gated it off and
secured it,
cleaned it up and labeled the the
locations.
So it's so.
It's a lot of work and it's costing the
last year.
Did you make any progress on those job
summaries that you guys were working on
yesterday?
Were you were doing the comparisons of
multiple jobs? No,
I just got those two that we did.
Um.
Now I didn't have the estimate for that,
but yeah, but it's partially still.
Yeah, I'll have.
We have to go do some more, so.
Which would be a good process if they get
a order with it. We find stuff.
We're several times, generally,
we're seven hours. Yeah,
if we want to look at the process,
if I want to look at how maybe this is
approximately, yeah.
Yeah, I can do this all day. When are we?
When's the cadence?
I don't know when somebody came in to
come in for building side of it.
Was there anybody that was going to be
available today for that?
Are we ready for that? Well,
this process is very.
Tedious.
It's tedious that it requires critiques,
but I should do this all day.
I don't be doing well,
but certainly done associated with just
finalizing the POS.
So we can go back into comparing jobs
estimates and pushing labor between the
two of those.
Just, you know,
correlate and where we need the new
adjustments or if we have a number of
coding personnel available.
The second part of our agenda is a major
rebuild of the coding system,
but it would be pretty key to have one of
them with us.
I know it gives Mo a heads up.
Why don't we go into the afternoon?
Aren't they in AISC?
That's how we can call to find out where
it is. It's a little chaotic.
I think tomorrow we get the environmental
people on top of that.
I see Mo in the meetings,
but the meeting isn't.
Nobody started the meeting,
so they're probably just.
I think they're doing it on site and all
the people that are off site are not
joining because there's no meeting going.
Yeah, there's.
Yeah,
we can go to doing estimating and pushing
labor against some of our estimated award
and if you can complete the I actually,
I don't know, I'm sure.
I mean what would that have a status on
for the candidates before they actually
come in here, but we need to try to deter.
I don't know the data.
We need to determine how.
We want it and then say here's what,
here's my vision with what this looks
like and then or we need them for that,
that type of stuff.
I don't think we really need that for the
defining of it.
Essentially we want to track the coding
side of things.
In the same granular level that we are
with production, yeah,
we have handling fit well cut all that
kind of stuff,
but as a I don't know if necessarily need
handling,
but prep and then prime intermediate code
and so on and so forth which is gonna
fail.
To associating,
associating that into our coatings or
into our fabrication routes that involve
coatings,
creating some routes that are just
coatings only. Mm-hmm.
So that we have that and then also going
into the inspections.
And creating the inspections and tying
those inspections to those rounding so
that they have their markers cause
they're not going to have to take and
stop and Cody's only job must be
associated with something cause most of
them they're just going to be important
seeing that we're going to see a regular
production job that they're not ever
going to use a production inspection.
But then you also want to do that
estimating as well, right?
You want them going later to do the
estimate. Yeah, yes.
So we'll want them in estimates.
So we'll have to break down the all the
different types of prep and hours and
calculations associated with the prep as
well as.
I don't know how many coding systems
we're going to want to associate,
whether it's just prepping proxy code.
That's where, you know,
I'm talking to coatings. Yeah,
that's the that's the that's really the
difficult part.
Breaking down with the press there are
still very excited.
I'll look at that,
but the different coding systems I feel
like we'll come up with maybe half a
dozen up front and then we might have to
add it.
We'll go as we set it up like 80% in the
middle.
And then you can set up,
you can set up unique coding systems per
estimate. So in other words,
don't try to set up everything you might
ever possibly do,
and it pulls into every job.
Just pull just put set up what what the
then the worry is if there's no one right.
You set it up to the 8% of what you need
and then the rest of them just set it up
on an estimate by estimate basis.
That's kind of what we're thinking along
the same lines.
We have like the steel spec parameter
which is standard the the carb.
Be able to sink, maybe even when we do,
there might be a maybe one or two epoxies.
We're starting out kind of small on that.
We'll let them decide. Yeah,
they have the history,
but they have legs for all the refractory
for all of that.
So if you're doing SB10 here, they know.
What is it? Hours per square foot?
They did not have that last time.
It's in the past. It's in there.
That's what you're going to.
I assume that's what I have for the
record. Yeah, it'll be by the 22,
so if it goes through the wheel and gravy.
We have it has to be 6, 65 and 10.
23.
23656 that's what we have.
Like there's there's pressure wash,
there's a brushed blast,
there's the pan blast.
You know when you start net,
you use steel shot,
a build greater and then.
But are these codes ready to go so we
could we could build them out.
SP2 and SP3 are the only ones to work out
in there at this moment.
There's a very vague.
It sounds like just in Excel we just need
a list of the codes that are.
That we need so we can get everything in.
You can fill it out, but the numbers.
So again that we have been tracking the
last few jobs,
he's been tracking the actual like time
studies more or less appears where it's
at because before it was when everybody
said oh, we use a standard,
we use a standard.
Well, where are we at?
We we use the standard on on a job and we
we have a 28% margin and we finished with
a big 5% margin.
We were a little lost in it, lost in.
There's the greatest yesterday we have.
House deal comes in, where do we,
where do we want to land on the estimates?
They go in the middle,
they don't go worst case. So yeah,
that has to all be kind of laid out,
I think. What's the goal?
Is the goal to set that up today during
the voting meeting or is it set it up
before then and say?
Yeah, we need the data,
get the structure set up and then you
know he enters, we set the parameters.
Who's gonna be the master of the
structures?
So would you do the structures in Excel
first to get by or are we just hiring
them in? Why not? Let's do it.
Make a little progress. Yeah,
we can get them in there and then if I
need to tweak the numbers after the fact,
I already know where to go to do.
So you want to do that.
We don't need him over here,
but I'd like to get him over here. Yeah,
we don't have to go right to second.
We can push through with the comparing
estimates,
the actuals in terms of us or doing
something for a department that's not
represented.
I'd want somebody here so that their buy
in is there.
In the end it's going to be, you know,
we're telling them that we're using this,
but it's left here to do cooperation in
front of it.
Production is going to be the easy side.
I mean,
as far as the set up and again they're
going, it's going to be the,
it's going to take a little bit more
massaging to make.
Right. So yeah,
but production is going to be easy from a
setup. So today at the estimating stage,
I imagine Tecla gives you a total square
footage and you guys just throw dollars
per square foot at it.
You don't really break it down or
depending on the operation,
but you know the system,
you know the system is 150 bucks a square,
just using a number.
That's what the estimators are doing and
the estimators also being told to
estimate.
Individual or is the system going to
actually estimate the individual center?
Work center time that she works with.
Yeah,
the time and material time work with me.
The system will send you time.
It'll tell you the cost of payment,
the cost of the need. No, no,
we'll eventually want to set up with like
I'm trying to understand the estimator.
Actually does today.
Does he call Moe when Moe just gives him
the number? No,
they kind of they they do talk and they
they go over what the you know they're
looking at size of the pieces,
what the requirements are,
what the painting system is and then they
put the plan together and say OK,
we're gonna run it through.
Pressure wash and then top coat.
And then there's a whole discussion on on
how to shop.
I think what you're saying is when you do
handrail,
the factors are going to be in for
handrail. When you do W8,
it's in for W8 when you do it for W12.
All those factors will be in there for W
12, W 44.
All those factors will be in there for W
44.
Yes. So,
but it's really what we need to do is
just keep it on a simple level,
just for the footage. Yeah,
it is not simple technical calculates
this work and then it does this side and
then it's so, yeah,
and it does a bunch of waves too,
the real problem.
That's super simple in terms of it's the
handling. It's the it's the big issue.
Fair enough.
Handling is the biggest problem in
codings because you have to flip it,
you have to,
you have to plus dwell time too.
Dwell time is a big deal in codings. Yeah,
cuz you sit there inactive,
their whole area is.
Is inactive. So we try to schedule.
It's stuff has to sit. So yeah,
it's right now it's scheduled in batches.
It's just batches, chunks. It's not like,
so you you have to do all the time is
huge.
That's my biggest pet peeve out there is
that. Is there a stupid question,
but is there a flow sheet of the whole
process? Has somebody built that out? OK,
all right. So I think, I mean,
I'm used to just you step by step to
write the process because it's like when
you when you write it.
It's just basic because and then when you
get into it,
it's way more complicated than that. It's,
you know, depending on how, you know,
to get off the truck and stage it and
then move it to this stage and then
pressure to watch it and then all that
gets to be other.
I know, but it's like, it's like,
it's like this,
it's five or six little blocks and that's
it. But then when you get down into it,
you look at,
there's all these factors and if it's
huge, we're gonna go, you know,
this route, if it's small,
we're gonna do this route, so.
It's not just one,
there's one general one,
but then there needs to be a flow chart
for all the different five or six
different scenarios like each one, 8%.
That's how it's.
It's the most basic process we have and
they it is it's just overcomplicated at
the same time.
I think I until you have all your process
flows there this one.
Because he and I don't know anything.
We know what we've done in other places.
I like a gallon.
I think they they they both high parts
are very big parts,
but they still charge the same price per
pound to pay for once they have two or
three different prices based on their
size.
Is that kind of what you guys are going
to end up with?
That's what we want to get to is the
first holidays is nuances. No,
but focus on the 80%,
leave the nuances for the specials.
And I agree,
lately everything's been a nuances.
Uh, like 100%. I mean,
I don't think you get soup pretty easily.
So we'll wait for that stuff.
I agree that ours are seem vastly
different than what the actual say that
the actuals are questionable anyway,
but the.
Oh.
What comes out of this in the back?
So yeah,
I mean the bits that it it also depends
on the estimator too.
And that's one where I feel like we need
to all get on the same page is like most
of my estimates with the exception of
like me going and estimate extras and
adding.
Manual time for just heating a plate
because it's the cold season and we're
welding the plates together and we need
to make sure that we're maintaining that
or adding additional time for breaking
plate. We have a plan plate in there,
but it just goes like.
.44 hour per part to it. Um,
if it's more complex and multiple breaks,
yeah,
I'll increase that and increase the
quantity and breaks.
That doesn't exactly what we need to,
but I'm always using labor codes and then
we're.
Bullets or if I need to include multiple
passes,
then I'll go down in the estimate
pictures and have those.
So those should calculate out pretty
close to being able to transfer that to
what production showing. Yeah,
so most of mine are a lot of the
estimators they'll.
Use the labor code sometimes.
Sometimes they won't use the labor code.
Sometimes they'll diet feel it,
and that's where we need to get.
All of us estimators on the same page.
Yeah, but I mean,
let's say if you feel like you're doing a
correct,
we need to hold a couple of your jobs and
look at them and say guys and then you're
gonna pull.
Around the estimators for R3,
the name I've heard,
we pulled three of theirs and say, hey,
this is what we expect and then let's see
how, you know,
see how they come out and see how.
Data is captured.
I'll I I'll just set yourself open.
I don't.
For us, the the, the,
the hours that are coming back from the
shop are too perfect. Yeah, that's right.
They are. Would you be OK yesterday?
Absolutely.
Sure. Yeah.
So we're monitoring that and Mo will be
here.
He's a Mo is a an engineer by school and
he is numbers oriented.
So he's very into this and likes to know
where he's at. Yeah.
So he'll he'll be here at 10,
which is 30 minutes and I want him to
kind of give a rundown too and.
He's a little rough around the head,
just to let you know. Yeah,
he doesn't think he speaks his mind,
so he's he's a really good guy.
I think we can see the honest information
about this. The main thing is,
is how the big question here is how we're
going to run Cody's own jobs.
That's really the thing that we're kind
of after, yeah.
Which even then when we go in here
estimate wise we have mag epoxy standard
prime broke out in here for paint systems
and their standard is always going to
apply the standard shop prime if you
select paint.
And then we have clean systems one
through 10 in here. However,
these do not have much broke up.
I think SP2, SP3 actually have anything.
Yeah.
So if if you do it like that or do SP3,
it should apply the the profile.
In other words,
you don't need to do a clean system if
you just have one if it's just SB,
but if I need to do SB, SB, six numbers,
now the.
So,
so we have a lot of time we've got here.
It's just fine tuning it because this is
kind of the level I don't know what
they're looking for for the next part and
some of these are most of these they go
down.
I think the last time you set up the
metric was the last.
The last breakdown that I got from
buildings and what I use for all the
clean cranes down since every hundreds
would be 100 square foot.
They get one man an hour for prep,
one man an hour for private and then the
paint breakdown is.
120 square foot hits me to get on.
So that breakdown is all pretty accurate,
but it's missing stuff.
So these are the prepaid systems are the
only ones you guys.
The only ones that are in the system, yes.
These are the only ones we're estimating.
Cone is not a good example in my opinion.
I think I'm gonna speak for a while and
say that's yeah, it'll have a different.
But while it's here we we.
We should probably go through some
different scenarios and I'll start
building out like you have there.
I'll start building out the other
workflow on this.
It's quite a way go to the maintenance
and escalating the paint.
I need.
So.
This this factor A.
Good. What about in this one of these? OK,
how many difference is the that's more
genius though?
So, OK,
and this one I'm pretty sure you too,
the labor multiplier because it's getting
that graph.
It's getting an intermediate code and
code. OK,
so it's gonna double layer on it.
Really for backup boxing you guys really
only put down 2 mils per code.
It depends because a lot of our customers
will have specifics and that's where this
needs to be defined further.
Some of them are 9, some of them are 15.
I mean, it's really,
that's really what you're saying is that
these numbers are dotted.
Yeah, these are not, these are not true.
No, I mean,
if you look at the spec sheet for macro
proxy, you can put down more than that.
Yeah, almost definitely.
So and that's where this was kind of last
time you're looking at it.
There was nothing in here and we had no
coding.
So I just,
we just put some information in here so
that we can tweak it.
We know what it would look like and and
then we could go back with them.
Like I said,
actually 100 square foot per gallon on
this.
What's our thickness nodes we need to do?
Is labor multiplier accurate?
Cost per gallon,
obviously that's going to fluctuate,
but can we get an average in here? I mean,
do you guys use product additions? Yeah,
because all that's on. Yeah,
for the most part it should be able to
get close.
No, the right data sheets are. I mean,
that's that's the Bible, right? Yeah,
that's the cut and dry facts.
So the problem is,
is I've gone off the cut and dry facts
and then I'll submit an estimate for
these and they say this is nowhere near
enough.
What the hell are we talking about?
And then I'll tweak my numbers to double
or triple and I'll be like,
if the numbers say that this shouldn't
work, like, well,
that's not what it is for us. So, OK,
so I've fought those battles in the past
and whether I bring in Chairman Williams,
Tonemic.
Whoever.
You know those that data is,
that's how that paint is supposed to be,
yeah.
I mean,
we've had to go to the even in power
coding, like, you know,
a lot of power code is.
I want to go there, but you know,
Intel's a,
you got to do it for the data sheets.
Yeah, I'm talking about the coverage.
Well, all of it. I in my mind,
product data sheets tell you how to apply
codings. And what I'm hearing is,
is what actually is being done is not.
They're saying the product data sheets
are ********.
Some of the products data sheets are
********.
Is it the the product data sheet?
Takes in the factors in the transfer
efficiency.
Also whatever your whatever your surface
prep is, it's not always perfect.
So what what they do in order to cover
themselves is they take what the the
coverage should be and they they they
change it. It's kind of like.
How we're changing,
handling to match our shop is changing
the coverage based on actual versus
damage.
That's something that published as the
calculator.
I don't know if it's a big calculator.
Unless you put those things in,
you got to be taking, yeah, they have,
they have a lot of those tools.
But again,
when you're hand applying paint,
we don't have a paint booth.
We're paying outside.
They're playing with transfer efficiency.
They're high here. I don't buy it.
It's super hard to measure in here.
Because again,
you're you're going to measure what
you're going to measure and check on
actuals and decide if it's worth
improving, right?
And that's kind of what they what they do.
But the way they calculate their transfer
efficiency from what I understand is
based on.
The the DFTS of the of the codings which.
Isn't always accurate because you you
have a huge surface and you're checking,
you're doing a check in so many spots and
you're saying, OK, everything,
we're going to assume everything has this
average of thickness.
Well now you just kind of everything's
kind of getting skewed at that point.
It's it's not super accurate on that when
you.
When I think transfer efficiency,
I want to be as accurate as possible on
that number because I assume somebody
measures paint thickness. Yeah,
it's part of the quality check.
So I assume you sample a reasonable
surface area.
Depends. Yeah,
like the pockets of beans typically is
areas that are either over sprayed or
under sprayed, right.
We have this job coming through the I
don't know how you forget,
but it was for the fire.
That's like freaking impossible,
but it's almost impossible to achieve.
But if you have anything off of it,
share everything off of it.
It's not touch up.
It's like how and you know you can't
control anything unless you can measure
it.
It's like you can and then how how
accurate are we going to measure
something you know it's.
I've always been able to view it. Um.
No painting things that are a lot smaller
by the two weight differences and pain
replied. So I got pain pain.
Same nightmare that you guys had on the
Miami Ducks. I was in the middle of that.
Do you have a station set up for? No.
We need to add some stations in there and
then add those into our route.
Can we go in the station in the route set
up? Yeah, yeah, this is.
Power.
A little bit of a loading stage here,
so ever since I switched to .
25 I it's been.
But a few moments where if I put anything
already now,
it'll say that was not responding. Uh,
I'm gonna message IT speaks.
I can't restart the server.
I don't know if this is because we're
running SQL 2019.
Every every bit of documentation I look
up online recognizes this to be on a 2025
Windows OS base for server,
but the what I said that.
Our SQL should be able to run this just
fine. What SQL version does it do that?
It is the It's not a platform version,
isn't it? No.
We've worked on the getting in there,
but wants to do anything.
But she said we were on the to be
originally on 8.43, something like that.
I know it was at 8.4.
I think you know more on the 8.1.
That's kind of the latest for the 2019.
Yeah,
there was an issue with starting 2025
that if you upgraded to 2025 but then you
were on like 5.
0 version of SQL then it was.
But things could happen.
And and it was weird. Sometimes,
sometimes you saw it,
saw a result that some people didn't see,
but like I went, I went once,
like they get to, they get to the board.
Oh yeah, but the next got good.
I made that sense as far as what it was
doing.
Some of the issues we've been having
because you have issues where you
couldn't import,
you couldn't add a a production job,
couldn't project management job,
but I can do everything.
I I still can't send it.
Transmittal, you know? Yeah,
I have to pull the transmittal from Sento
and save it.
But then it's funny when you pull it,
it doesn't put it into the folders. Yeah,
it just pulls all of the files basically
and.
It's Office 360.
You don't have an existing app,
which one the actual e-mail app,
because if it's if it's a browser.
I use the app.
Because yeah,
I I use the app that lets me log into the
app. You get the works signal. Yeah,
but if I if I use the online one,
I'm I'm on the app.
I'm not on the browser anymore.
Yeah,
I just know since I have to do what I
started, so.
So.
What was all that we're just shooting the
ship here? Uh, yeah,
kind of at this point we're waiting to to
to kick back in and first and then it's
coming again,
talking long and then you're not going to
actually bid.
Why are we trying to push the line?
I'm trying to push it into power for
tracking purposes. Yeah, yeah,
tracking purposes, cut links and layer.
I ran quite a few through here,
just running them as broad and then going
into my purchase of both sizes and
switching.
My approach is purchasable relates to 500,
one thousand 1500 and 2000 linear feet
and then this is for cut lengths of wires.
So I think that's a portion of what
they're trying to do is.
To be able to have an inventory system
for spools of wire and then cut links so
the technicians have cut links for their
wire with running through conduit and
whatnot.
And then I'm assuming also in the same
sense of tracking links, conduit,
the receiving cable trigger.
And buyout items and whatnot.
So they want to have a separate entity so
that that inventory is not in our steel
inventory and or one connect and they
will then use that too.
So they can use between triple connect,
they can load up their own models and
everything that area of the system.
Isn't necessarily where they don't want
the money they can use.
They can use that without messing with
the and that we have,
but keeping their production jobs
separate and.
Inventory's found that they can sleep,
not sleeping.
So and then they can get other different
files.
Everybody can answer that question
because it's it's we're not. Well,
I see the logic. Yeah, that's no,
they that's their logic behind it, but.
You know, we don't.
They just tell us what to do. Yeah,
that's that's what we think.
That's what I didn't.
They they made requests and it's not,
you know,
I I like to know the why is and it's more
like, hey, you can do this.
We want to see this happen,
see what what this can do.
Yeah,
and Jerry's granted is that there isn't
necessarily a system that does that and
that does worse specific.
And then we can add our own shapes and
sizes in there.
We just need to make sure that we define
them so that the system's looking at it
correctly.
Tracking the linear lengths and adding
sizes in there that are tracked piece by
piece,
not necessarily by size and stuff they
did needed.
They were requested utility to fill out a
project that had.
So many different boxes and features with
wire.
They're trying to automate the process so
that they can import, combine,
throw that into the requisition,
have the big picture of this is the
quantities of these items they need and
then have the inventory tracking with us.
Because at least my understanding with
what Jarrod's goal was with that.
So I don't know,
I don't necessarily think they're trying
to do an estimate estimated side of it
more with a a combined inventory tracking.
Thank you.
This is, uh, Tom works. Tom works. Yeah,
you know, so.
I hope I get a response from IT quickly
and the server gets restarted.
I was hoping maybe we're going to run
into this. So what are your goals?
Coming to stuff in Takla.
Great.
I want to see what I can do personally.
I don't know what I know what you're
trying to get at,
but at the same time it hasn't been
explained what we can put in there and
what we can expect out of it.
No, you can. I mean,
just like the general literally,
you can't estimate it in there. So it'll,
it'll, you apply things just to do it.
It'll tell you how much time it takes,
how much film cleaning and all that.
So we're going to do that on this side
and then on the production side,
then you can also then be tracking if you
want has it been,
I mean really whatever you can you want
hasn't been blasted, hasn't been cleaned,
hasn't been.
You can do multiple codes if you want to
track multiple codes.
If you want or you can just say how do
you spill it or if you're not,
you know so that you know exactly which
pieces are done and which pieces are.
So that way you'll have.
The real function on this on this project,
you know.
So you can try it to really whatever
level you want to try to do.
So as far as this thing,
does it already have preset book values
or is that something you have to do again?
It does. It does, but.
You know, I would not.
I wouldn't want to make it any longer
that way.
You want me to put in whatever your brand
so that everybody's doing the same thing,
right.
So it doesn't matter if you do at that
point, you do the same the same thing. So.
But yeah,
it's probably customizable for that, so.
But it can be done.
The estimate is very customizable.
So again in in this case then you can
have everything in one estimate if you
want to get the original estimate just
for the steel and then here's the paint
estimate on top of it.
It's all in one system.
You want to do the same thing.
So what's the effort?
If you receive 10 truckloads of customer
issued material, you've never modeled it.
You just got 10 truckloads of fabricated
steel. And what's the that's the effort?
To get that into the system, well,
if it's saying it's going for a little
time,
hopefully there's certainly a file that
might be Michigan board and then and then
all that material gets in there.
So that has to give it depends, I mean.
That's,
I mean that's one of the concerns that I
had is how much time to take put that
stuff in there.
I mean some stuff is custom fabricated
like that and is our job.
They're fabricating the pipe supports on
set and they give me a general.
This is how it looks and it can be from
24 to 48 to that.
So your and this this would be a.
Cody's only project, right?
What you're saying?
How much of that is it like from let's
say a structural like thing versus like
to say or whatever.
Who all this is coming from is the
question I got.
In the field fabricated,
this is probably the only specific job
that comes to mind.
But at the same time I had a job recently
with WW and they supplied the kiss files,
but they were all screwed up. Yeah,
they had sizes and.
Metric in the mix in the interior or one
way or the other, right?
What do you like a square feet steel?
Yeah, I had been doing.
I know it wasn't done. Yeah, it was. Well,
let's put it this way.
It those guys ought to be able to produce
a file, right? That actually works.
And then it's just been important.
So if it they ought to be able to produce
that now,
even if they need to you to make sale,
heck, we can important sale, right?
And then.
So even that's all I've got.
You get all these documents sheet up on
that one and you get everything to
imperial over everybody that we're set up.
Let's say it was wrong. What'd you do?
You went out there manually to the take
off and you received the trucks.
No.
And it's not. It wasn't that.
We just got a payment.
Let's give him a safe number, right?
You just said that's 10,000 square feet.
Yeah, well, they gave you a like, this is.
Pretty close to the square footage out of
their program.
It's like this is this is pretty close
and and then we just added added on top
of that the debate over disagreement.
I got the talking and somebody said that
bonding was X and you said no, it's not X,
it's Y.
I remember a conversation in your office
when Jeff was introducing me to you and
you guys were talking about the
discrepancies.
Quantities and nobody really cared if the
unit price bid once she does figure the
quantities. Was that that job? No,
that was that was lump sum.
It's not necessarily the business unit
price contract.
But it gives me a ballpark aggression of
you that,
but your biggest concern really is
getting it into the system out of it.
I like the idea of more tracking and
value that ability to track through the
process and account and everything,
but it's never been used.
So the the files should not be a problem
for these guys.
That should not be a problem.
If you get it again, then you notice.
All the all the pieces I would want the
the overall process would be I would
important production control and get my
bill of materials and then I would if
it's me I'm taking that I'm pushing it
over to a zero dollar PO so I can.
I can track the receiving of it as well.
I can track the receiving of it.
So I know what I got here on site that
that that I that I can actually work on
and then I'm going to track it all the
way through as well and do do the do the
production tracking on so.
So then that would be the, you know,
process. So you know,
if you give them a subcontractor POS on
picking the inventory,
so they'll have the recipient.
Once the money is,
we get a phone call in the morning
potential for a large project.
Steel is on the truck and he's gonna,
he's estimating to lower the phone at
this point.
The stuff shows up when we start working
on it. You know,
it's we start to finish six hours.
There's no fine.
It's not necessarily to do.
Do you want to try and catch what you
wanted to say? This is truck one,
this is truck 2. How?
Yeah, that's what I want to get to.
Like how simple can we make it so he can.
That job was a huge money maker and we
don't want to have a delay from getting
started.
He wants to track it in the detail.
We want to gather that data. You know,
that's another.
Just the DOL, right? Just the DOL, right?
They didn't. No,
they didn't give me drawings. I mean,
we can just go off on DOL.
So it's gonna take, well, I just.
Is this fabricated? Yeah.
So they they didn't have his files
probably because I asked him to work with
and they send me a screenshot and it
looked like they were using tech look.
Yeah, so that's how I estimated them.
Like you said, the whole thing,
the steel was on the ground and they
processed it since I was,
I'm a very stubborn.
Idiots sometimes.
And I I was just very much be like I know
nothing to be filed.
They can get it in about a few minutes.
So it it's not a problem for me to get it.
I I'll just rip a set of no as an answer.
You know I know that's that's easy to say
but.
I mean,
most jobs I go to with something like
this, they just don't ask. It's like,
well, they don't get,
if you want to do the job, get it to me,
right? So it's very,
especially for a user,
but it's it's a two-minute process, right?
I can literally write through and screw
the same thing like that.
So that's that's kind of where we're at.
But if by some chance we can't get any of
that, we want to understand the time,
the process and how simple can we break
it up.
Like like Eric's saying with a truck load
or something like that,
just as a lack so we understand. Yeah,
definitely.
It's it's very simple to get it in there.
It's very simple to get it in there.
A a drawing number, a main mark,
a piece mark, quantity, shape, grade,
size, length,
and that's the main style benefits.
So yeah.
For all the pieces.
So is it faster to keystroke that into
Excel and import it or go straight into
power?
I do it because in in Excel I put in the
W 14 and 23 which doesn't exist and Excel
will let me.
If I do that in here then it'll know that
you got to put in the balance size.
So I've to for me it would be easier to
still get here. I'm used to it right then.
But plus it has the it has the controls
to make sure I'm either going to get
property as well. Yes Sir.
I'm personally an Excel guy,
but I hear you because.
No,
I like Excel and push because I don't
know the screen if it's a function.
Let's see, like I can put in a piece mark.
Can you put one in correct? No.
Can we put one in to show them how to do
it? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Yeah, we can.
Everybody's it sounds like it's a body.
How long does it take to get it done?
Well,
and independent is it's going to be
monitored longer going this way initially
anyway,
just because there's going to be a new
process right now, so.
Yeah, if this was functioning,
we shouldn't.
So annual entry is a part of what's the
December, so.
Deepak.
It's not to be trivial stuff.
So if if you have a,
you know this is PB and SP.
If you have a bee with a bunch of flag
plates,
you're just calling it a bee and skipping
all the flags for us.
It depends when I also try to.
Very exactly.
It's actually very footage of I think.
Then I need you guys to call it parties.
If it's just made in tracking so that
they know what's going out and they're
not worried about accuracy of the weight
of the oils because they already have
prebuilt the oils from an exterior entity,
I can run maintenance remarks all day and
and then we can at least have the level
of tracking for the one of the assemblies
and that's.
That's fine,
but if it sounds like we use it for a
footage number, we need accurate DOL,
so we need everything into my T and I
don't give us to add everything's with
the exceptional hardware into that. Well,
I have a feeling when a job like this
comes in, price is not driving it.
Yeah,
so you might be less inclined to be every
little flag type that you may not be
training that build something.
If I have a KISS file,
I could get to just a shut up. Yeah,
if I have a KISS file and we pre-build
these routes that that we need,
that's the point.
So that's the three with the primer.
I'm going to build whatever I have to be.
Depends on the size of the project. 50,
000 square feet, 50,000 square feet.
Where it puts loads at least over 100
assemblies,
depending on how big the assemblies are,
I can go the end of the route to all of
it and then kiss in,
so in theory 1010 minutes at that.
It's important and the project
inclination and routes to it and then
just glance over and make sure you don't
miss anything out. That's how it works.
10 minutes is like PSMC 5 three maybe
five.
But you have to run. Yeah, yeah,
that's the one you got from rolling
plates, right? Yeah, yeah,
that's approach. That's that.
That's that 200 package that they were
talking about earlier this month.
They got what we needed 69 times or
something like that.
Yeah, OK, yeah, I have that imported logs.
All of the what's what's the things,
I think,
because they got two things that's on
that ship.
I'm doing the part line only place.
There was one where it was a good
presentation, guys. We um, well,
while they were coding it,
they had only sent it.
Wherever they were having COVID was
having issues,
so we opened everything guys.
What are you finishings would like you to
do? Do we need some finishings for that?
There's a dose need to be cleaned up.
There's a couple of,
but they're most of it's paint on paint
gallon. Yeah, that's red bread and butter.
We don't have anything to find specific,
so and then.
Even before I had my permissions,
whatever any estimator,
Joe Schmog imported,
but then 02 P 03 P Yeah,
so whatever coding systems,
but there's a lot to clean up,
'cause you got to do every job and clean
the.
It's terrible. Yeah,
this would be what our scope of work is
14 since he had three.
That looks like it's, but yeah,
that's things down a little bit. Yeah.
So this isn't this.
They came to us somewhere like, oh,
you should probably talk to the coders
because you know that they're all fine.
And this is one of the ones I want to do
have the quality issues or have the time.
We were told rolling like that.
They're taking up to the 4th,
so we want to check that. So yeah,
which they mentioned in the meeting.
So the distance,
I can even apply cleaning those routes to.
So we need to find a job just for I think
they should be.
I think they should do it anybody that's
already in there.
Well, well,
they're going to be different packages,
different jobs, different projects.
I imagine you guys would be following the
CV roads in Manhattan. Well,
I'm saying to bring the ship back from
Rolling Blaze is shipping. So they've got,
they've got storage in our that's got 400
plus loads and they're also reaching out
to that was going to start shipping to us
directly.
I also want to know that store is 2 or
two weeks. I think it was five or six.
All my deal was was in here.
So you subcontract back this four shop.
Is that what you're saying?
So they got,
they got a contract from Shuff and the
paint will do the paint and portion and
we have a contract with Grove of Plains
to paint for Shuff.
So we're a second tier something.
Separate Johnson. Yeah,
separate Johnson instead of you. Sure.
Otherwise, I'm not sure.
But if it's something you're finding and
you've got and you're important. So yeah,
we'll get the files from that. All right.
I'm just worried about the current job.
I don't know.
It's going to be a hard time trying to
keep this stuff.
Yeah, it was separate. Explain that.
What are you tracking that tracking that
because we're basically doing the same
job as computer.
Yeah, so we have already a separate.
You guys have a separate bid number. Yeah,
yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
They want everything sticker too. So yeah,
you guys are entertaining the new chef
stickers on.
So can you guys clear up like your lay
down areas on the start?
They have a conversation now with me
because that's going to be kicked back
harder than the freaking you know, slow.
What kind of tracking tomorrow?
I imagined.
Breath. Whatever the system, yeah,
standard process of private and prime.
If there's any other additional poster by
a track that as well.
So pretty much from the initiative or
some sort.
Do you want to do like contact points or?
'Cause if that's usually the last
standard composable.
Yeah, so would it be?
Prep prime. Are you doing checks in there?
Yep. Did he want checks?
Did he want checks out? Yep,
because that's where I have to tie each
of those to an inspection.
So somebody to get that to.
They're gonna have to go on PM go and say
yes, this is through this checkpoint,
check by and complete and then that
update my status and you need a
percentage. You want full visibility,
so it's not yet on CS full visibility.
Now,
because on top of everything else decor
that is the key for him is,
like I mentioned yesterday,
we're running all of it.
No course direction.
If he's got real-time updates,
he can make adjustments on the fly.
That's one of the key things for him.
He's he's a project,
so that's what that's his perspective on.
For scheduling,
you're going to need to know it, right?
Because you're going to need to know if
you can move to the next step, you know,
next schedule. I think it works.
What what is what at what points does the
QC happen again?
After prep and after each total. OK,
is it 100% of everything is is QC or is
it a sampling or depends on the contract
requirements for prep usually everything.
For a for East Cove,
it's usually just a batch.
Is it a is a documentation you're filling
out or is it? I'll just check it,
you know.
OK, so.
The the reports you're filling out where
where I'm going with this is whether this
is just a station we say cool 1B1 done or
whether we're saying 1B1 here's the
here's the things that I checked.
Here's the things that we did.
I'm filling out a form for each piece or
is it?
It's just done. No, it's just done.
I mean, once, well,
let's say we've got a truckload seal out
there.
It calls for an history 2 preferences of
pressure washing.
You make sure it's not oil or grime or
anything. All right, this load is good.
He checks it.
He can check off the peace marks,
but he just takes pictures where the
report has to. He just takes pictures.
Spaceball was done. That's it.
Do you guys use the flagging system?
Or so let's say a guy checks and does 150
meetings. I don't know what issue,
but three of them.
He didn't like some of them.
So typically one of the systems I'm used
to,
the stuff that can move gets a coloured
flag.
Stuff that doesn't gets a different
coloured flag going.
Those got to be pulled.
Do you guys do that?
How do you know which one's the 4th?
So we don't usually have issues on on
service. We do one or two pieces,
you just get something out there.
Doesn't they just hit this again or does
the form and hit this again and you're
good.
Rarely have issues for service for for
when you do find,
say a light spots or run stack.
Or something.
They would grab the boot in their marking
tape. We didn't just put it on.
I'm used to it.
I'm used to a flagging taping system.
Yeah,
otherwise the verbal part can't find the
guy who wants to take it down, you know,
whatever.
Yeah, no, we don't.
We don't have issues that we're not,
I guess,
you guys have painting systems where you
have to monitor environmental controls.
So how do you guys not environmental and
that like it needs to be 30%?
How do you guys know that the paint
system,
what what customer wants to report says
hey, during this period of time,
the humidity will get a sunny guy do that.
They don't require that.
The customers require from us what they
call a paint log.
So when we prep,
let's take all that pipe up here,
for example. When we prep, right,
we're going to take pictures of the pipe
happening to prep.
It was prep coming to SP2.
I'm talking about.
I haven't done that one yet,
but this is a prime outs.
They got a paint system,
so they got their days,
it's going to tell their viewpoint,
all that stuff,
and then they'll report that.
They'll take it at the time that they're
going to paint and they'll put that
information in the report.
Does all this go in the power fab or is
it just not going to the power fab?
What what is being filled out is you can
create those forms within here so that
they are a part of the system and it's
like I I did that with the bank where I
was in the shop I used to be in.
I need all the environment stuff on there.
So any form became a document,
became a record.
But I think if you have something that
takes you a lot of time,
now is the time to ask because I think
the system can do it. Yeah.
And and so like when it was when you said.
I feel this.
I say here's what we did to it and I'm
typing that out and I can move forward
with here attaching the pictures to me in
here. So yeah,
that's what that's the whole KC portion
of it is.
Right. Mm-hmm.
So this entire system will be contained
in as directly now. Yeah, he's on. Uh, go.
Yeah, he's out there.
You gotta take this following checks,
puts it in there.
You guys get notifications that it's
completed and it's completed.
You can't move.
Fly through the city to be more and still
it's done.
So you know the problem we're getting in
eight months that this will help.
So I pulled up.
I pulled up on the pay months we had for
the last meeting.
It was great deal with job,
but it's the same report either way.
So it doesn't work if I need payment that
must have been.
So you got a section for environmentals.
Usually just take a picture of your age.
It does a lot of environmentals like you
when it's viewpoint, it's cumulative.
It's better.
That one was an acid engine that a
pressure wash the coating material they
used in one coat.
So it's a prime intermediate top code.
They put in the batch numbers of paint.
And then paying related information.
So shelf back thinner. Yeah,
see what else specific one sign off. Yeah,
we can build that into here.
The the thing that I always had a problem
with was the delay and stuff getting back
to where it needed to go. So there's.
Never can see anything because the forms
around the paint area, right?
You can see that, right?
And so we put them in there and makes all
electronics so successful.
I mean we can down the slide at that
point.
So that's that would be easy to build so.
You know, 'cause it's basically,
it's just that basically, so.
I think we could do it now.
There's a lot of benefits,
especially when you have these customers
that want shipping.
They have multiple checks before they let
it go.
Like your document package has to be
complete. Mm-hmm.
Before you can even they give you a
trucking release.
So is it so that everybody did it? Yeah,
everybody's had two or three estimates
reach out to me and check those down to
them over at the Gilbert facility.
It's currently affecting our audit areas.
See if nobody can actually see can go
over fully.
I messaged him multiple times.
He's in a meeting right now.
He's responded, so he's no fault.
So, yeah, second. What are you doing?
Why did you do that? I'm not working on.
Is there a way while we're waiting that
we kind of go, you know,
do these processes.
We've got to go here and get some buy in
on what what he wants. Well,
can you run the show?
Or do anything with it.
So can you run locally?
Can you run locally? I can,
but I don't have your system, so OK.
And then we have to use the the system.
We got the food then and duplicate
everything that in the system.
After that we have lunch.
It's a restroom break, all actively. Yeah.
I quit this year, so OK, thank you.
What?
It's happening, man. Yeah,
I don't drink soda.
Drink a lot of water now.
It's almost tricky.
And drink lots of water. I don't have.
Smile things.
That's all.
It's, it's flawlessly, right?
It's obviously. Yeah, G conference.
But you guys,
you guys on the Broadway for when I say
that the currently? Yeah,
what about where do you eat around there
for dinner?
Or do you got to go eat? I mean,
I live over there, but I don't know.
Where is it at? 52nd, 52nd, 56th airport.
Oh, it's a good restaurant. I don't care.
I don't want to spend $5,
but I don't want to spend $100.
But you know, I'd like.
Please.
Just need to meet somebody from Phoenix.
There's some restaurants here that you're
in person.
There's a place called Eurega in Tanjin.
It's supposed to be pretty good.
I haven't been here yet,
but it's reasonably priced. 30 bucks.
I would like bar food more or less.
So like after work,
that's easy to get here or am I fighting
very good traffic?
Traffic that way, this way, this way,
we're fine. That's it.
See that every time. OK,
so getting into town, no big deal.
Just go up to 10. Yeah. All right.
So that way he's also going off the
Broadway curb and he should be OK.
But as far as that energy goes.
So we can, we recast the restaurant. Yeah,
it's like that. That's all right. Yeah,
both our food and the restaurants cost.
That's it.
I don't know how he's in Tucson.
Everything is down super expensive.
Oh yeah, that's nice.
But he's on expensive account,
but I don't want to spend my products.
Thank you. I tell you, it was funny,
between these two jobs,
I went to Europe for a motorcycle.
And my girlfriend was there and two cups
of coffee, 2 pastries, like 4 euros.
Come back here, that's 25 bucks.
But I just say the tempting marketplace,
whoever tempting marketplace.
There's there's right off the tube open
in the playhouse. You're not that far off.
There's new line, I think there is right.
That's everything, right? Yeah,
there's a lot of different.
There's a big variety of piece, you know.
Nice. What is that?
It's like a good place. You'll see.
The seal is possible.
The seal was the seal was a month ago and
actually three or four months ago.
I got 12 ribs. Not as good. No, damn.
They got a deep price to pay.
You got a deep fried dev today. Awesome.
Uh, spin them today. Yes,
he's got a deep fried. Oh, OK, yeah.
You're also at that point you go across
the river here.
Yes, some place like, I don't even.
I know there's a safe place there, right?
Yeah, I know.
I would really appreciate that.
What's the advice? Uh,
they're on Washington.
Take 44 Spanish state place.
Yeah, that's pretty, pretty close. Oh,
I can provide the star here.
I'm not a huge fan of it,
but it's it's true. Yeah,
you know what I mean? What's the answer?
You can help me in trying to stop it.
It's a personal, easy salt. That's cheap,
actually, for steak. But I mean,
you go to Firebirds and still spend $58 a
trip to go to Buck and Ryder yogurt. Yeah,
oysters. Yeah,
you can get us a nice New York for like
45 bucks, which is not.
And I keep hearing about these good
places, but no invoice.
They're over 30 minutes away from the
office. That's the stretch. Well,
from this office,
not in the Gilbert office.
Gilbert office is a lot.
Gilbert office is and this option.
When they got to talk a little bit later,
the main Hoover Valley goes, yeah,
that's that's the downtown Chandlers,
but that makes really so difference.
Going to like, uh,
on the ostrich and speak easy. It's fine.
Really strong to insert. Why did that?
Why did that? It's fine, right? You know,
I was. I mean, it's.
And it gets up loud. Yes,
the murmur turns into a slick steady yell.
You're right next to the first thing
you're there, but then you're hollering.
Say that right in my ear, please.
You can't speak very easily in the
speaking seat. Oh,
I I like the way I read it. Yeah,
he also just the same order, yeah.
Yeah, that one's cool.
That's the one that's like a ship. Yeah,
that one's off.
Yeah, I I hope so. Yeah,
I thought Spooky been trying for a while
there, trying to find a hidden gems.
We did the cooling and drop off fixing
the pop up noise. It's not worth it.
The wife was having. So yeah,
it's not too. It's not nice. Exactly.
Yeah, spot on.
Everyone makes a big deal out of it.
I'm like, no, it's overpriced.
Postal Fox concept restaurants.
I have an agenda.
I don't know if they build something in
that parking lot.
I don't know if they took that.
It's still there. It shows.
Even I want to guess on my.
OK.
Yeah, couple times. I'm not impressed.
I've been a couple times. Cool.
I don't know that back in the day when it
was.
I think there's only one in Scottsdale.
It's great. Yeah, it's really good.
And then they branched out and it just,
yeah, like a dog. Well,
they used to actually customize the menu.
Yeah, and have interesting things.
Now what's the safety of the temptation
for everyone's?
Depends on what charts and be you're
talking about.
I'm not coming in that area for.
Was he better? Yeah, I'll use more.
I would like to listen to the second part
at Queen Creek until I approached the
option.
We're actually trying to stop him from a
new offer.
Did you know who those homework? Oh,
I knew. Oh, I knew it was homework.
But I also knew, crazy enough, that, like,
he put me in my car,
like there was no problem like keeping up
with it, but it was a matter of.
I'm like, if I was crazy down,
will for sure hit me.
It was crazy enough to keep his foot down.
Yeah, well,
it's funny that he's crazy enough to keep
his foot down.
It's he's crazy enough that whether he
has from him or not,
he's just going to be affected. Yeah,
he's one of those I miss.
Just the exit and I'm driving within the
inches of the cargo to give back that
little highway 'cause it was, it was like,
I'm just gonna like go with him and make
him like, take the exit.
And then I was like, no,
it's probably used to battery in some of
these countries where lanes don't matter.
Yes, he was telling me this morning that.
When he was in Saudi, he said.
I was telling him I was stuck in track.
I said people just keep hitting their
wrists. I want to hit them so bad,
he said. When I was in Saudi,
I had to hit the guy in front of me and
ran into the barrels. It was funny,
I I was in one of the streets back in my
youth and we were in Dubai.
We're driving the license plates on our
Jake. It's number one and it's down. Yeah,
there's seven United Arab Emirates, right?
And so I'm Austin and I are 10,000, 6000.
So we go to a parking lot.
We're not supposed to be driving.
We have a driving car. So first mistake,
you shouldn't be driving.
We turn this Mercedes coming around us,
my boss.
Hey man, you got #38 boot.
The guy steps out, military dude.
Another car drives and takes the
passenger and they're gone.
The military and their car show up,
their buddies. I said. What do you think,
man? Hand or a foot?
It's like, what?
It's like punishment here is every
Thursday.
They're gonna take a hand or a foot.
But we, uh, try. I don't know.
We had to spend six hours until our fixer
got to sell. And then we're not allowed.
I mean, we're not allowed to drive anyway.
That was a billion dollars.
That's crazy about the country example.
Customs are very different.
Saturday was close.
When I said the right lanes are more for
like center in like you center the car.
In China, they don't give a ****. Yeah,
same in the same way in Saturday.
There was there was a guy that *******
cut currently. So it was 6 lane.
Road all the way from the left.
It's that time ready, so.
That's.
Yeah, kind of. I don't know,
'cause you there's sometimes over the
years I see the the the issues driving
the stereotypes.
I see a lot of those guys like.
South America wants crazy.
It's all like countries. Yeah,
but at the same time, Arizona better.
I'm just going to say that.
Yeah, but they try not to help you.
So yeah,
I was gonna do the 50 on ******* 65 when
everyone's doing names.
They ought to find the people who are
creating traffic and take their license.
No,
just just just give all my like pardon
for you.
Don't stop causing traffic. That'll be OK.
I'm sooner. He will have a situation.
You have a parking for a year and go
clear the way.
Good.
That's for real.
How long is this happening?
It's happening.
No, usually it's about 20 minutes,
but usually IT is relatively available.
I'll just reset the server and and then
we're back up and down.
Do you want to just you want to just hit
it? I wish no.
So now put all of our drives down and
then more systems will have to be
restarted.
So far.
Kind of it is a log.
If they give me access to the server,
I can go on and reboot it.
It takes about a minute to reboot the
server and this will get back up.
I just don't.
I need to have an IT administrative login
to be able to do that.
They've added so many different firewalls,
different safety checks that everything's
you can't even can barely update my
Google Chrome without having to ask for a
yes, please.
I was going to say that you can.
He did not miss it, yeah.
So even the even the programs that I have
company installed on here,
I can't update without. Yeah, I asked him.
That's why when somebody comes on with my
system is like, hey,
can you pick these up in the states? Yeah,
well that was the same thing with this
tech update.
I put in a request for the tech update in
the beginning of November.
And then I got to the summer and I was
like, this has to be done on 12/3, no ifs,
ands or buts.
And then it got done on 12/3 and night
time.
So we were working through all the issues
on Thursday last week,
getting everything buttoned up.
Server restart, server restart,
everything's down in the morning and then
because they have all of these processes
in place,
IT had to go to every single computer
manually to install the update.
Whereas before we used to be able to just
go to the location where the update was,
run it.
I think it was updated and we're good to
go. Yep,
to get in the morning it would have a
full file after you just started.
I can do it. Yep, it would.
And they use the. Hey,
your database is updated.
We notice there's a an updated update
file in the folder.
Would you like to install this?
When you're built,
obviously the property and you are now we
have to go through this tedious process,
but we don't have enough IT personnel to
design above and Keith,
Keith's on help desk,
but nothing's going to change. So I don't.
I can't. Some of the updates I can't.
I can't. Now I've got IT admin line.
I love that we still have a plan and
Taylor's number up there.
All the safety personalities.
Yeah, so.
Shots where it seems like we're not going
to allow me to do a good and I'm
considered a hole in the firewall.
There's safety precautions for that and
they can do, but they're like, no,
I'm going to do it.
And I was at one shop and IT said that
and they were an outside IT firm that the
owner had hired. They're like,
we're not allowed to do that.
And the owner's like, yeah, you are.
This isn't my system.
I bet you you're not going to tell me
that I can't do it. I can't do it.
Yeah, you got that.
So there was an error last week that I
sent over and I see that initially that
was.
With this 2013 lost connection to server
doing query blah blah blah blah database
connection logs and then restart and so
then we ended up going to techlist
support and then that.
And it's essentially the ITC technical
support said that that error code is
vague and now you'll be see the trouble
shooter.
So they'll need to know if it's going to
the same work.
And could you provide us any solid
feedback other than confirming that we're
on the AS My hospital version and they're
known for this version? I got it.
I'll just we're detailing though.
Most of it's all extremely, sorry,
external Indian or external somewhere US.
We have a couple of options on the US,
but there is one of our main retailers is
a yeah, that'd be link. So I well.
What's the name of your idea?
What she was asking there is one of the
main ones that we use.
Sockeye detailing is in the US,
South Dakota based ANC.
We also use them there in Asia,
but they're a main branch that takes up
California.
All over the US. Who's going?
Who's like a good like a small
miscellaneous metal packet that I see
coming through from the mine sites?
Who's doing those?
They can do anything from big contracts
and a little miscellaneous.
They have a pretty.
Three is the main contacts that oversee
our projects.
One of the contacts does big projects,
one of the contacts does little projects
and one does.
So and how much back and forth is Sir?
It it kind of depends on what we supply
them with. With them,
I like them because they'll ask the
question if there's anything uncertain,
otherwise they'll buy in from the census.
How does that work with the time
difference?
Usually they're pretty on point.
Most of their most of our contacts are in
the US.
The people who are physically doing the
detailing, they're sending to our seats.
So the people drawing it up,
but our contacts,
they're always readily available for us.
Occasionally, worst case.
It's something like really early in the
morning from them,
but they they were late and they'll ask
me my questions.
So you won't see the job until the PO is
left by the customer. Most of the time,
yes.
Sometimes they'll get ahead of the ball
game and.
We'll be in detailing with the notice to
proceed without appeal or contract with
him. How about this Arizona water tank?
Who does that Arizona water tank?
A lot of that's done by detailing.
He's kind of one of the small projects
kind of guy.
That's second term in the US stock on it.
S OK on it.
SSOCKDYDW something I'm in trouble with.
Something like the Sam and yes, it's Sam.
Very well.
Did you get the tech from the handbook?
It's updated.
Do you think that you guys are going to
get this tank job? Yeah, so it was that.
I just think about yourself. I am not. OK.
No, Rob, where's the water?
Brandon is telling me about it. Oh, OK.
If we're in Mexico, then it's white. Yeah,
it's mine. So.
I thought it was.
So there's a lot of things.
I don't think that's hearing on the
plugins. It's usually the major,
major cities, the other two,
but I think it's not for things.
So they're going to add them like this.
Yeah, yeah, certainly fine. But um,
and then again, we're.
Would you try?
Would you try to do it or would you try
to move yourself it?
What is the dealt which is those two?
I'm trying to pull it here off and see if
I can get it.
Yeah, he was asking me, you know, for me,
those are easy things. But for here,
I don't know. No, we don't.
We don't do 10,
but we did some up this Saturday.
We've done some before.
We ended up doing any sections and
piecing it all together,
but it it was such a pain that we ended
up. Yeah, we really got pains, yeah.
No,
there are not actually two of Chuck's
guys. No, no, no, it's one.
The Chuck guys work on a tanker from 13
years to allowing. Well, the door sheet,
Central Heights. Yeah,
they asked me about dental.
OK.
Yeah, they asked if we could roll that.
He said an 8 foot radius.
We can go by 8 foot.
We got a 10 foot wide liberal.
So anything over there we're going to be
placed in the 10 foot sessions.
So but that anybody as long as we got two
guys on it, so we can roll with it.
Are you going through earlier or what are
we doing?
We're putting a new door sheet on it. Yes,
Max reached out to me about it.
He's asking me a bunch of questions.
It sounds like he submitted on it. Well,
we did the door sheet,
but thing is we were planning on using
the same one.
We just we just took it off of the
meeting side of the bank.
I think tomorrow they're going to.
They could swing it back in last time.
Yeah, because that's no,
this was right and that's right.
We're reproducing.
That's when the last time we pulled down.
That's a bad one. Oh.
Hey, holy crap. No response. Oh,
that's how people. Well,
it only took almost an hour.
But it figured itself out,
but you're desperate on time.
They checked.
Yeah, they go to.
Good.
Yeah, well.
I thought we're going to be 20.4,
Citrus and 35. I don't.
Let me see what I'm on. Yeah,
that's the one that I'm running too, so.
It's only since you weren't trying to
play fill out, really, just since start.
That's that's the that's really it's
pretty cut back process. It shouldn't be.
It is. It's very simple process.
But I guess it is what it is.
So this is our this is our TSMC job that.
I'm gonna spend some time after hours on
today,
but this is the one that you guys are
gonna be killing is the.
So.
There's a decent amount of things on this.
But our finish is we've got.
Quite a few different conditions.
I that that's actually fairly including
to what I see from that a lot of shops.
So believe it or not.
So do we want to sounds like production
is most important.
And we want to look at routes and set
things up and then I will walk through
and say here's what it would look like.
Yeah, that's probably your best bet.
Put another fabrication maintenance way
out there. Oh, that's right.
They may be just in the stations that we
want for pavings we want.
Bread from what we want.
So when we, let's say we set it up,
we set up for the most complex system is
going to be a prep, prime,
intermediate and Tacos going to be a
great global ship back.
Barney was a portal system too,
but we can assign how many stations we
have.
For a job, right? Yeah.
The only challenge with this that you'll
have is that still the Ramsey,
very seminals of stations. Yeah.
More smoothly routes, yes. Yeah.
So what we do and is it gonna get
affected by the finishes I guess.
So let's say for finished you got painted
and unpainment right now,
but if we want to do like that,
say SP2 and shot.
That SP3 and shot point.
With the number of posts,
they can get fairly complicated. Yeah,
we pretty much use our simple paint
linear when we do a simple paint linear
or and then the simple paint linear.
It's pretty just calling up the two
different kinds of press.
The on those are basic enough that I
would think those could both fall on the
same level of simple just because they're
it's not necessarily coming from blast
and blast is where we want to go like.
Complex P,
so linear CP and then six and then that
one can have that one.
We can add more routes to it or add more
stations to it so that it has a little
bit more granular tracking.
The other two it tracks.
Similar of you want the cloud,
you want to prime and then a different
model of the client if you were going to
go for a complex and you need to finish
code because each of those is going to
have an inspection tied to it,
takes the problem,
the station to be added to it and the
rock sits assigned to it.
Not saying you do this long ago,
so if we got a job we want to start going
through this and it's others, the decent,
see where it's just the simple present
time. You can go into the job pack. Yeah,
you can do it.
And the idea right now is for us to set
up.
One,
tweak our current fab routes that are
going to associate coatings with it so
that it has your stacking to it.
So when we're loading something through
the system and it's going to be,
we're just applying routes like we always
do and you just incorporate the art as
its tracking to it,
but then also defining your separate
routes.
That if you guys import KISS file and you
want to run a simple paint tracking,
that's it.
You can globally edit all the assemblies
and you have that there.
Then all those inspections are popping up
for you guys in the in the in the shop.
And and the stations can be set
processing the stations saying they're
going to be separate from the QC as well.
In other words,
so we can be able to QC test that here
and they can process that station saying
that station is done.
So that you can do like a.
And saying prep is going to or crime.
The crime is done by filling out that
inspection list or you can just even say
I process this station without having to
fill out a QC list and certainly be done
either or.
So that's why I was asking if it was a
sampling or it was 100%,
it's it's actually every single one.
How do you so you probably get asked
what's your capacity? Do you have time?
In three weeks to pay something.
You probably could ask that.
Are you going to is are we gonna want the
scheduling part to be able to handle that?
Seems like you'd like that. Yeah,
I'd like that actually plan ourselves to
work.
So it's great to say yes to that.
I get it,
but eventually you're going to have so
much work that you won't be able to do
that. That's the goal, right?
So you got to really be able to say,
squeeze it in.
I think you want to skip it. I want to be.
I'd like to skip it right now.
The way I go about it is I'm like,
book the shop.
It's really so hard that you don't have
to.
Do you move between intermediate and
final or you just let it sit there and
you paint the same place? No,
you just let it sit there and paint the
same place.
But the only move,
the only move you have is from prep to
blast, blast from blast and paint.
That's essentially it.
That's prepped in place in the paint.
Yeah, but that was when you were.
Well, it's gonna be capacity by area.
I'm just getting to the point of capacity
by area,
but sometimes you'd have more or less
blasting capacity or more or less
painting capacity.
Well,
the past time lasted where I wanted to
and painted where I wanted to,
so the capacity wasn't really.
They.
Just build it into the functionality,
whether you can use it or not, right?
It's just, I think,
I think make it as flexible as possible,
right? Now what you're saying right? Yeah,
but just have the the work center.
So you know the capacity of that works
number.
Not to figure out the capacity, yeah,
but because if we run everything through
the building like we're supposed to,
that's really easy to have that small
square feet. Don't need to have the laser.
I mean,
is that air quality thing going to happen
in the next year or the next month?
You know all about that.
I hope it doesn't happen, right?
I can see it. I mean,
we ended up having houses nearby as and
all of a sudden.
Our whole painting system had to be
changed.
So, so we've got the stations in here.
Now it's just incorporating those in.
So you mentioned Wes,
we'd want to go even further than this,
but right now we've got prep.
Prime, intermediate code,
finished code and most of the basics
would be a six to seven to add into our
standard production route of prep and
prime and then I would just have to
associate an inspection to your prep or
prime.
Since you guys are already doing your
your checks at those points and then that
can give us a percentage of complete in
production for the side.
Got a job we can apply us to do that
remember we'll let build the the wrap but.
We're not what we can apply to right now.
So then we can have a, yeah, say, hey,
let's go out and let's see what this will
look like out there. Yeah,
I haven't this TSMC Fab 3,
I haven't used for Fab yet,
but we are gonna be coding in here in
house, so.
Can apply the production and put these
routes to that and now we can be
available and we can give it a shot.
Do you keep your stations together by
paint and by weld?
Right now it's kind of Willy nilly in
here,
but in theory this would be set up at the
same layout of shop.
I'm through because I noticed you've got
finish code as 32,
but a lot of your painting is in the
teens. Yes,
those are ones that I've so these are
ones that.
And after the fact,
these are ones that are early stages that
we are in the initial,
which is what we have. Yeah,
we gave everybody blocks of 10,
tried to keep them together, blocks of 10.
So like you're the painting guy,
you want your stuff.
You know you're always going to be in the
70s,
but they don't see the numbers anyway.
They don't.
They don't see the description. So, OK,
I'm used to seeing both numbers and at
least we're in the process of it out on
the floor.
They'll just see the description. So OK,
but not what about the office?
Pretty much subscription.
It's not unless you will see it. OK,
is there like a report or something you
pull in where the numbers are filtered?
So let's say you want to pull.
Now you want to see the pieces that are
following this path or using these steps
and numbers. If you have a code slot 70,
you want to see everything that's called
7 the the the builders.
You can get your step through for more.
What's the script?
So you'll you'll have a right by the
spreadsheet and not by.
That's not ideal, so I can ask prime code.
How many square feet of prime did we do
in January?
You can.
Um, yes.
There's not going to be a report
specifically that says that,
but I ought to be able to pull all the
pieces that went through that station and
see how I can see the square footage
point.
All right, we won't do it in a route.
The next thing I want to know is what's
the difference to how much SP510 or six
did we get?
I want with this 10 or five.
Now, if I was even with anything,
but of course they might even give you
water. That's part of water.
Maybe the old gas industry sometime in
the car sometime. No,
I'm trying to think you're right,
but not much, but.
He was always the semiconductor guys with
persnickety on.
Finish.
On the blast.
That's the line.
I think I was bringing ain't big enough.
Here received the job site,
which received the job site we didn't
really need in there. Honestly, Yep,
we'll make it happen instead of shipping,
the shipping sites tracking,
just an extra category.
Yeah.
Make changes but here actually.
Yeah,
you'll say how you want to describe this
for.
All the different stations.
Yeah.
Complete 3B station version was on for a
prime,
but nothing else you wanted on for other
stations.
Or do you want it all off?
This one because this is cut to size
before the order cut to size plates that
are going out. So what does that mean?
You have to set the quantity as complete
before you can move it.
So like with with the way it was.
If you try to pick from the brand at mid
there,
they will put a fly and say you can do it.
So yeah, it's kind of holds you again.
So you see there's follow and show
letting their stuff in accurately on time.
So yeah, there is, but there's time.
So if you put in QC.
Before or after present after private.
Those are going to be have to be tied to
a report where you can just split that
step so Chris, for example,
can go out there and mark that each piece
of the PC without the reporter blocking
it from moving to the next step.
So if I don't tie an inspection to it,
you would then just have to go to the
park tracking and when you're marked off.
The quantity that he checked.
If I add it in there as a quality control
step,
then I would tie an inspection to it and
they'll fill out a report for each one.
But it's not 100%,
it's in the district body piece,
so if it's not inspected 100% it.
And we don't really want that as part of
the route because then it's going to
require you to do it all here every
single piece. Well,
not necessarily at the time,
but I mean you have, you have your,
can you make the same stuff about tiny
time inspection?
I mean as a whole,
if you guys are the same quality control
step, but you have all these steps,
so we'll be here,
nothing's not anything you said.
Copy a step and change the description to
whatever you want.
Maybe oversimplifying it,
but what are you saying now?
I'm not following.
So you have all these steps in here on
the top side,
but is any of it tied to anything
inspection to you have to have this done
before you can move to this,
that kind of stuff. Yeah,
so that's what that complete previous.
The inspection first is it would say you
can't do the next step unless the
previous one was done.
Now whether it's tied to the inspection
test or not is is different than that.
The inspection test just says if I if I
successfully pass an inspection test.
It will process a section.
So if crime was always going to be an
inspection test,
it's always 100% I want to do every
single piece.
I thought of an inspection test and let Q
and QC is processing that, not the guys,
because if guys said I I primed it,
but they but.
QC fails it. Now I got a false positive,
so.
Quality control.
Can you set um a sampling?
It will not. It will not pop up and say,
hey, we're going 20% here.
He's not using any. Yeah,
you got to choose feedback, so.
Well,
the other is going to be in order to
overtribe so I can kind of see it.
But oh, excuse me.
And can you have that same test twice or
you're going to have to label it prime
QAQC and that one and two and it's you
can't talk basically.
So that's what it's in there right now,
but it's not tied to inspection, right?
Yeah, it doesn't have to be.
It doesn't have to be. So,
but if you're doing it for for that,
then yeah,
I would probably be able to do an
inspection here or an inspection for
because.
Completed this successful class and you
will process the session.
So you're not able to do both.
In other words,
I don't have to fill out a form and say I
process the session with you.
When you say process or form,
is that digital on an iPad or are we?
Yeah, so there's no transcribing required.
Great.
Yeah,
that's why I think we say if you if you
are going out,
listen to get it in here because it makes
it live and.
Is it smart enough that it pre-populates
standard stuff or do you have to do
everything every time?
What do you mean pre-populate standard
stuff? I don't know.
Let's say I have a QC guy and I had a
weather station out there and I gave it
the order every morning,
grabbed the weather station data.
And automatically take my form past the
weather station.
I don't have to go look up,
but the humidity is.
These are basically like 3 form bills
you're filling out. I can do a checkbox,
I can do a drop down, I can do a text box,
a number, a date, whatever,
but it's something to read from anywhere.
So that's not gonna be not gonna be pull
all that. So well,
remember what I did yesterday.
I mean, let's say I was the same job,
right? And I did the Monday report.
Is all the stuff going to be there for
the Tuesday report except the differences?
I got to do all the stuff every time.
Now there's an option in there to say
copy from previous tests.
There's some previous tests I just did,
like I was out there and I did crime and
then, you know.
This is how long will it take to fill out
the report?
Depends on what what the one that you
want, how many you want.
So depends on the second seconds.
If I build these and I want to very click
friendly, right?
So literally we're defined in the fields.
So if I've defined 25 fields, then click,
click, click, click, click, yeah.
You know,
so this is this is like our inspection
that we've defined in here and added the
minimum information that we need possible
to do this and then if you're him.
We shouldn't even have.
I've got a little mine inspections.
I think it's going to get on wrong,
probably go to the traffic instead of
seeing if we want to.
Sure.
Let's see if we got it.
So once you plan on your project,
build your inspections,
select your assembly.
Doing here some of the inspection and
then get fit up so.
Of course there's no routes. OK, perfect.
So from here we can see it passed.
So this is what the information looks
like on here, but if you're on EBM go,
this is how it looks in the shop and then
you fill out this information.
So like your location,
which inspector did it test on the
employee checkbox for passing.
You can add notes if it was performed.
So everything from employee to mail
discuss models,
whatever you want because that was built
from scratch.
So that's whatever you want it.
Do we have standard inspection forms?
Yeah, we haven't already built the site.
That's what we use.
Do we want to build and move them to here?
No.
It's gonna be piece by piece.
I don't want the guy spending three hours
when I have a truck or two truck was a
stupid line. So what are your forms?
What do your forms currently do right now?
I just so it's a section for environment,
a section for the paint we use and an
open field section where we have
environment.
Yeah. So that's that's the difference.
This would be about moving up to 1V1 and
I'm expecting, I'm expecting 1V1. Yeah.
Now if I'm doing my environmentals that
applies to everything I do that day,
right. So that's a totally different form.
We can build this.
So that would be a problem.
This is just the guy saying I've
completed this step. Yeah,
this step on each piece.
If we build those forms in here,
is it just going to be essentially it's
replacing side docks? Well, I'm assuming,
I'm, I'm assuming.
So if it's,
is site docs just that form and you're
filling it out, site docs,
we were using it for all our forms of
JSAS and other forms.
They would they prebuilt the forms in
there that anyone would go and pull up
the form you need.
Fill it out, submit it,
then you can export it or do whatever
it's it's our it's record-keeping system
to be local forms,
but they're trying to get us something
else which isn't more than at least with
that. So, so.
You're actively trying to get rid of
something else. Is that correct?
They want us to stop using site docs,
but they have what we need in the other
side of course,
so that's what we're still using at least
for that for those. I mean,
I was going to say for that particular
thing, if if it's not tied to a piece,
I don't know that I would move it.
In other words, don't break, you know,
don't fix it. It's not broken, right? So,
but if you're needing to rid of it anyway,
we'll spill it real quick and show you
what it looks like.
The the biggest limitation of fixing that
I don't want is I don't want to cut it a
piece back and stuff, yeah.
So that that wouldn't be appropriate.
So just think of this in a four wheeler.
That's all it gets.
You can talk to me or you can say no,
I don't want to talk to me or I can talk
to a truck if I wanted to.
I can do that if I wanted to be better.
But then it's it's very customizable.
So let let me tell you what I use.
Then it's it's an inspection model,
so I'll tell you what I use it for.
So I did use it for a piece by piece
inspection. OK, so I I could be 1B1.
I didn't get check on it.
I didn't wheel check, right.
So it's designed to do that.
I also used it for OK,
a truck's doing that.
I've been accused on trucks.
My shipping guys were really terrible.
So this guy had come to this guy's truck
and say everything was on and take
pictures of it and attach it to the
record. I used it for that.
I also used it for just.
A general form type thing.
So we did do about a minute on there.
So we did all that. We did come, man.
I had in the morning on the floor that
you got to do inspection on on the floor.
I did that in there. It was just a form,
so it's just a formula.
So it can be very generic.
It can be very specific.
If you want to.
And what the I guess you guys know about
that is it. So if I have my green guys,
they want to start putting reports in
here and they're going to have to have
licenses and all that kind of stuff or
yes, what?
Well,
if we're going to ditch site possibly,
we're going to start using the ports here.
That's why I'm asking.
We're going to start.
If we're going to use for ports in here,
we just need to give them BP to go access
and those are a lot cheaper than a full
power band and go.
So we can, we can increase our amount.
It's like 15 bucks more than one than an
employee or something like that to add in.
Yeah,
so it's that's the easy one getting check
the power file.
I never seen person's computer that's
where.
It would be like Chris Pinium would be
something to have it you and then with
Alan assisting he already has access to
the past that.
So to start there let's let's take this
route rebuild and we'll come back to the
inspection.
We'll we'll take this route rebuild apply
to a piece and let's get out.
To go and say here's how we would process
and say these pieces have been painted.
These are the problems.
Yeah.
Yes,
your routes are probably going to go up
by three or four of them probably, yeah.
But that's shouldn't be a big deal
because the logic behind it is pretty
solid,
so it's not like you're going to have a
lot of different.
Tell him it took an hour.
I'm a bit removed.
OK.
So now you're being only simple, you know,
like, come on, let's see this, it's, it's,
it's not, so.
That was something that's OK.
Does this track paint usage and paint
like how he knows how much to buy?
So you can go to the estimate to figure
it out.
You can see the square fluid issue to to
figure it out,
but it's not going to pop up and say you
need to buy this much of this paint,
that paint, that paint. No,
it's not going to do that because the the
estimate will give give you.
I do it today, Daniel.
How do I do it?
If I can get split wood on redness,
go off historicals potential. I mean,
you already have standards for grace,
you know,
like for different types of things and
depending on what standard of vignesses.
So it doesn't really help you to do it.
That's what I think most of it. I mean,
we can put in the parameters,
but like let's say if we put in steel,
I don't know if you can build a database
with different paint products or we just
want to put in that standardize it if you
had it in there, would it generate?
Purchasing requests automatically.
For paint cause it's it's technically not
filed to a specific paint like the
estimate is.
The estimate will tell exactly with how
much of which paint that you need.
Production is is is just can you push the
estimate?
You you you can push a piece of in an
estimate of a person, but not the payment.
So he's key stroking it in. Yeah, yeah,
I'm trying to get him out of the key
stroking. Yeah, you got to put it in.
Well, somebody's got to put it in.
The question is.
Who puts it? Yeah.
Whoever you choose.
So you got the surface area up there.
I can filter for anything and tell me
what my surface is.
This one I applied.
the nearest symbol too.
Visibility here. Uh um QA QC.
Are you going still?
And I was missing.
How difficult is it going to be?
Let's just say from estimating that'd be
really difficult.
I want to know how many square feet I did
per month and how much primer I used and
look at how much primer I've actually
bought.
It should be difficult to get.
There's not going to be one report that I
get print that says I'm OK with that,
but yeah, you can filter for that.
Yes.
OK.
As far as everything is broken down with
job numbers,
you could never finish for all of the
project. Yeah, you you can.
You can run reports across projects here
and you can differ on just that
particular finish if you want to do it
with you all.
Your love piece is over 25 minutes.
From and it has a dash here,
so in production it goes to the middle at
the top.
You can just type it in at the top.
You can find.
OK.
That's so hard.
I sit here like that, period. Once it did,
it's actually direct character. No,
I forgot I entered it in here this way,
but whenever I'm in the file system,
I have to I have to dash, I have to dash.
You know,
they go one way and then they go another
and so.
And you're you're right.
And that's why the best you have to be
back up and then in other viewers have
been more strong in a ways than
production tracking.
I think it's the personal flush.
Here's your.
There's not available without suspensions
back with it.
So.
They went, wait,
what if the priming guy wants to know
what it is? He's not like his law.
That's we supplied in the shop reports
that our service area personally.
Here's how we can help you to process
this in the shop.
So you're on this screen in the shop,
so you choose the station that you want
to do now.
Add is adding one piece at a time.
Add batch would be multiple pieces.
I just painted these 25 pieces so that
add batch is typically what.
Um, guys out and pay for who we use it.
So let's hit that batch on print.
And then you Scroll down through there,
you're you're picking the ones that you
did. I even did one of those.
Go on down,
we can do more and I only find the route
to the one.
I only find the route to the one.
I got your question.
So it's all down the board. Yeah,
so but if you have multiple, so I'm just,
I'm just selecting the ones that I do all
the way down through there and then I'll
hit update.
And then it will, it will process that so.
OK.
Like to run.
And we're not like it up too, so.
So by highlighting,
like that's your bulk adding, routing too,
yes.
Yes.
So.
Now if I go back, I have to refresh it.
Cool.
Now we're going to have that to see
multiples.
That should be more than what's in there
either, and we'll just get an update.
So now I just updated it in the system.
If we go back,
go back into the desktop and do
production status,
we'll be able to see that that's been
done now.
Who else is working at this speed here?
Uh.
You mean like in the technical interface?
Yeah, you're moving fast.
Who else knows the budget?
So you you guys are the masters of this
company. Yeah, see,
the prep has now been done.
So it's marked as done automatically.
So it's mild in the system of that one.
It isn't practice, but it doesn't.
What was that screen again?
This is just a thing I forgot to this one,
but you can see.
So from here this is what it's going to
look like on the tablet.
And so if we went back to production
tracking and we went to prime and all of
these assemblies were completed in prime,
you would then come down.
Got here. This one's complete.
This assembly's complete.
We put it update.
And this updates all these successfully
updated. I go back to my production.
This is instantly updated.
Now on that screen it had hours and
minutes that is that supposed to be the
time to complete that?
You can add in hours and so if it's if
it's a prep stage, however long,
so you guys have that specific part,
you can handle and have that level of
visibility.
You can do that with like our saw if we
have if they're doing the cut station and
they have a cut list out there,
they'll cut it.
It took me 4 minutes to run this piece.
Took me 5 minutes. So if you start it,
you can get rid of the batch and it gets
started. That is, they start spraying it.
I'm all done with it, comes back,
gets stopped and processes those pieces
and then it'll all be.
Steve, I mean, it'll,
it'll split it even like based on and
that's what we want on the tab list.
So we don't track the time. So yeah,
that's like that. Yeah, I'd like to have,
you know,
actually not how many square feet they
get in one hour. Yeah.
And what is part timers?
This is for individual individuals. Yeah.
So how many,
how many guys do you have putting
information into this?
All of our shoppers on the floor are
using this, this process.
So if every slaves are welder,
whatever step he does, he puts in this.
Yeah,
but they're not using the start stop
button.
No, no,
pretty much going to be using the start
stop.
I think would be our detail department if
they're at the saw just to kind of track
and see if if blades are running out or
times are going high or if there's
trouble with the equipment,
you know our times are going high.
It's they kind of have an idea of what it
should take them and and then we can also
take that data and go, hey,
took us this long with W new 14 and took
us this long,
took W10 and you would kind of get some
of that data at least pulled back so that
we have.
So the way I see this for our guys is
they have a batch.
Not gonna do time per piece. Yeah, no,
I don't. I don't blame you.
But high level, like if you have an iPad,
this is exactly what it would look like.
You can be here.
You hit start and then you would come
through and as your QC meetings and going
through your sections and go through and
you finally get everything done and you
would update and stop your timer.
And then that's going to track your your
completion for everything things upon
when you when you figure your timer,
does it,
is it going to populate the hours or
minutes? Yes, you have to still have. OK,
it just didn't populate here because it
wasn't.
So is there a way to set it so that at a
higher level where you have to use it to
start and stuff? No,
there's not a there's not enough must on
that.
So do you guys have a meeting?
Do you have a meeting before you start
painting?
Do you have anything before you start
painting? Like, I mean,
he could be in your office talking to you.
It's starting.
He works 8 hours and he can finish it and
he gets to stop.
It doesn't doesn't work that simple.
We're not at the point where we need to
have a painting outside.
One,
because of the different material when we
get close,
we'll be that we don't have enough space
to spread a lot of stuff out.
You get over sprayed,
you get over sprayed,
you have all that kind of stuff.
The other thing is painting goes much
quicker than anything else.
I mean, as soon as you set the pot,
I mean you have to stay on top of it to
not cook the paint and screw up your flip.
So if it takes them a full day to
probably say a truckload of steel,
it'll think they got 3-4 hours, I think.
Three or four different dogs in one day.
So he has not had at the ponds
essentially that he can keep cool in the
summer.
He can hit start stop every time he
changes a batch.
Yeah, well,
if it doesn't even have to be 3 buildings
and have to take time,
you know who painted which piece on
Monday.
And you don't have the amount of time for
that.
So you got that level of detail by doing
this. So if you want to set up stuff,
I'm sure you can have a set up stuff if
it takes an hour to set up.
It takes a man hour,
about an hour for two days to get the
paint gather to mix it up.
I'm sure if you wanted that you can have
a set up.
If you wanted to know how much time he
was painting versus how much time he was
setting up to paint, you could segregate.
You you could in a sense.
There is a time tracking function in here.
It's clunky outside of that sort spot.
It's a little clunky.
That that we were doing is tied to a
station for a particular piece.
Now if I'm doing,
if I'm going to set up like the paint,
it's not tied to a specific piece that
said, right?
I'm not going to process the piece of it,
that's what I'm lucky.
So start stops is the only thing that
spreads the hours over the batch. Yes,
yes,
you gotta use start stop for spreading.
Yes,
it only depends on what you want to know
here if you care about setup or not setup.
Depends on what you want. So how can we?
What was concerned was setting up the
patches. So yeah,
do we want like setting up to record that
that sort basically.
I'm just trying to think of the flow over
here.
So when you guys get a package you have
in sequence 3 about one, let's say August,
you guys have done all that.
You stated you're not saying it's ready.
Shipping and receiving brings that whole
pack is out. We start prepping it.
So that batch is already recreated, right?
So you should be able to go to the
technical. Say you want to pull out.
See this three hot blood and you'll have
all the pieces in there already.
All the guys got to do is hit start on
there, right?
They start prepping, they stop.
That's the time that's done, right?
So if it's already pre-builded, right,
then we should be good.
But that's not stuff coming from you guys,
not stuff that's totally totally.
So how do we approach that the same much?
I'll I'll go with this.
The main thing here,
like it's a similar setup.
I'll just apply a different result here
because I made those those coatings the
only ones.
Your guys out there really won't see the
difference.
It's still will be on processing the prep
station,
on processing the private station.
It really doesn't make any difference to
them when the risk carries only or by
then can you know? No,
I understand the step is the same,
but the whole so when it comes from them,
they already have it built up for
sequence for a lot of her package.
When it comes to us, if I get a kiss file.
I'm not necessarily going to get it
either by truck load, for example,
by sequence or by load number.
I'm just going to get a policy,
all the pieces in there and then I got to
break it out and sequence it out. Yes. OK.
So that's what's going to have to happen.
We're going to have to have someone we
would include that and then we'll just go
through and.
You would tell me, hey, I'm in fact,
you know this is gonna be each load and
if we want to do loads of sequences and
blocks,
then we would just do it for sequences.
Well,
what about if they if they deliver the
what?
What we do now is we just go in there and
select which one we want and place it
into sequence a lot.
Can you pull up?
Can you pull up WWB 123092?
Select. Yeah,
but that means the guy's got to walk
around and take the regular pieces and
put them in, right?
So when you do it like,
let's say you're doing batches and you're
just doing chunks,
you're going to capture in that start and
stop time.
If you were to do the whole batch start
and then you're you capture all you're
moving and handling all of this thing.
You know what I mean? Yeah,
I'm I hear a few things about some files.
So yeah, this, this is an example.
This is a big job that was customer
supply. We got the case files from them.
Now,
do you see anything referring to like
bone number regard of the ship? No,
I didn't see anything in the just just
their specifics that they have.
How it shipped to you,
is that what you're saying? Yeah,
I was shipping to us because so.
Reason I got this,
I got the spot and then one for square
footage too,
because there was a doc going on for
about two years.
Our city and receiving guys were making
BOL's out of this,
so that helped us out a lot.
But when it was coming in,
I mean we could get truck loads,
they would have mixed pieces.
Mainly it was space sequences,
but you'd get the object that comes in
with one sequence.
The good thing is they wanted it
delivered by sequence.
But I'm just trying to put worst case
scenario,
if I got a batch of files and there's no
organizational system to it, all right,
you can organize that.
So you can re-sequence it or you can put
a lot number on it in order to organize
it the way that you want.
We can and and and unless you're on the
stats and you see it, but they do good.
I guess there's a lot of money you're on
up there.
There's some lots and some stuff maybe.
The laws could correspond to what came on,
you know, in a particular truck.
You could. I I personally,
if it were me and I had this,
I would take the main piece and push them
over to a PA before the trucks get here
and I would receive that I I'd do a $0.
00 PA.
And then I would receive those pieces as
I get here.
So I would then have visibility here
what's received and what's not.
You know what I'm saying?
Probably just like you buy it from.
What nerves of Denver? What?
You is your process that way that if you
receive something,
you must have either a PO or a customer
PO, a $0.
00 PO or can stuff come into this with no?
Anything coming in should help.
The.
All those ******* schools coming in the
wire.
You set everything on one BOL and then
it's in the.
Yeah, that is that's why I got it.
I have **** that's out my side.
I picked up to bring over here to process
here instead of process on site.
That doesn't have any paperwork or
anything.
If you don't do it, in my mind,
somebody's going to say, well,
I sent it to you and you say no,
you didn't.
You get into that argument and it's
really they need to.
Their BOL needs to be accurate.
We need to create a BOL of it.
They don't know.
That builder stuff,
that's just it's small. It's a small,
but instead of last you get out of the
field,
whatever incurred cost is over there,
we're just bringing it back in the shop,
processing it here and taking it back to
center.
Where you're sitting that regular stuff.
It's for, but yeah, we're doing it.
We'd rather do a do a shop and do it out.
But everything else, yeah, it comes in,
it has a BLL and it has to get to work
with.
Are are you wanting to re sequence or log
it just no matter what came in or is it
for for the user of the production
process?
So yeah, here we can do that.
We can just select whatever pieces it is,
pull it over,
put it in a new lot and then you're in
the filter for that lot.
But like you could be in when you when
you are, let's say for the print,
you can filter for lot 4 and just those
pieces show up.
And you're saying I'm processing this lot
4, so and this can be done on a glass.
So let's say that it's all against the
truckload of steel and all over the road.
You can go in there,
select the piece marks that are on that
vehicle,
sign the bottom of the one floor and then
that's how we track the big production
process.
Yeah, yeah, we just have to show him.
I've shown him a few times.
Whenever this is special,
so very very simple process.
This is how we define most of our
production by priorities for different
areas in here.
Sometimes I have an area of work and
priority.
But then I go on the categories and you
can find me further in that category.
So then I'll I'll even go into the
subcategories.
So many different ways you can get your
data refined for once.
So it's kind of there's quite a bit you
can do.
Go back in there and in the go filter for
block one so we can move. Yeah,
let me do a file.
Isn't it?
That's the one.
Yeah, I was. No. Yeah.
A whole load for you. Jeez,
that makes you wonder,
I'll tell you right now.
Free bleach.
All right, EPN go.
That was nice too.
So when you get a production tracking now,
go at the very top,
the upside down triangle in the upper
right and hit the work package there and
you'll get a seat block there.
Now when we're getting units,
we just build it for lock and lunder.
Now when we get a print or something,
get a batch only didn't show up to lock
and stuff.
And so you can literally say start if
you're building all that in print at the
same time.
Then there's actually a Max update,
but it's not when you say all that is
done and then hit update. Yeah,
Max come over.
That's kind of a cheater button, but yeah,
if they go through it and they get it all
done, you know.
Sounds good to me,
but you can at least leave this screen on
when you're tablet while it's going
through. Now here's here's the picture.
Now does it take into account,
for example,
if I'm processing your play versus an ID?
Does it read that?
It's going to,
it's going to average that time and on
the cross, it's going to have it.
It don't matter about processing the the
gas being a small *** plate,
they both get the same allow for that.
When you do it this way,
if you use the part timers and do it in
the 70 cases, then it got start and stop.
But yeah,
just just give you an average across
anything.
So but if I leave this at a minute,
I'm going to take a minute and now
there's so many parts in this.
So you can hit stop and they just fail.
They're going for the hours.
Sewer says IRS.
You could manual the Internet. Yeah,
you could.
If you maybe if you hit reset down there
and yeah, now you can do it.
Do I know that you did that? No. When?
When we go to see, when we go to see,
whether I'll be a Sarge file or whether
I'll be able to do that.
OK.
And I agree with you. I don't like.
I don't like the mirroring because if I
took nine hours to do something,
it should take two hours.
I'm not putting 9 hours. Well,
I don't lock. I mean,
to my university time blocks,
manual time adjustments are long.
Matter. Yeah.
This is where they did all the loads.
We can see all the loads in their jobs,
marketing.
So if I if I got this job in and got it
in the system and I wanted to ship it,
but.
I didn't want to do any any of this stuff
in there.
Can I still ship it or will it prevent me
from creating a shipping document? Yes,
you still have to have pieces in there
shipped, but yeah,
you can do it with that. OK,
without moving against it. Oh good.
So the system I'm used to is if you don't
complete service.
Steps.
It is not ready to ship and you can't
ship it. No,
this will allowing ship regard.
So there's now that's in 2046.
That's a new one we've featured where
production has to finish before it's
going to be an option.
So what you're really saying is they're
moving to more of these more locked down
systems. We want to have some,
I mean that's more clear meters and so
yeah.
Well, we have potatoes,
so they either have a potato or a
sandwich. There's the first here. Yeah,
potato. Yeah, the softening.
And there's peppers.
Yeah.
No, it's not. It's.
On that, yeah, but.
I actually can do that.
It was inside.
This works.
I don't see.
There's nothing to go about,
but then you know to the package right
here, I think.
Oh, right there.
Yeah, yeah.
Anybody want water? I got water. I'm good.
Thank you.
Part of the matter.
White.
I think they're on their own.
There's some.
But.
Somebody else want the barbecue sauce,
Lauren. Open it up.
I won't sign no problem.
They're different, so you can.
Grab this with your toss.
That's the that's the not spiky,
not as spiky, but still, yeah.
I think it's all day I actually need.
What do they go over there for one day
off, one day off or two day off? 3. Yikes.
About the people.
OK.
I'll probably work on it.
It's about three here.
What are you going to be talking about?
What a painful.
But I think it's like what is the problem
we want that Cory came over.
So what do you think?
You're the best staff to the W7 the
bigger ones, I thought we'd say.
We're on the break.
12, 2018.
If you got to have one piece of equipment,
what would it be? How much work?
It was.
The one that's not inspection,
it's a regular one. Yeah, OK.
Yeah,
the coach will start with and does
everything, yeah.
It needs to be in line.
That'll be with the other restriction we
run into goes to about 36 inches.
Recently stopped about.
Breakover point for like a Python. Yeah,
they are in the Python test.
What's it do? What's so that again?
The pilot system? Yeah.
I'd be your all-in-one.
It would do everything,
but then at some point it comes to
bottleneck.
Do you want to be cutting and drilling
and coping at the same time?
If it's me, I would be.
I'd look at like if I'm starting with
something like that,
I would do a Bortman or something because
then I could get a drill or and a saw
later and put it in the same system.
Python has no they don't have any drill
or saw,
so I couldn't tie anything into it.
It would be one system.
Oh, like what we sent out to.
They usually have a.
Just because I got KC Jennings represents
the case.
I'm trying to place it showing up in his
Gucci shoes in the shorts.
Unbounce.
Yeah, it's still bad as a video there.
They had someone for us to reach you.
They're tackled though, but there it is.
Yeah.
Still haven't finished though the old
bell.
I just put their we're gonna be selling
some new work for this.
But.
It's moving any of your.
In their own slaw,
they put wheat in their ******* coleslaw,
you know, coleslaw,
green corn and all that. They add.
You only should have.
OK.
That's the sovereign.
You want to be and so yeah, yeah, yeah,
everything's good and free here. Yeah,
you can do it. Just like I said,
wouldn't want you to be part of this.
I think they also do that.
I don't believe they just one or or as
well avoid like that.
There's probably cross, yeah, a lot of.
So they're like,
who's Bobby and you're supporting,
like adding more to gasoline type of
things thing, OK.
Mhm.
Inclusion for my own dietary.
That's all I want.
I'm gonna go to a Christmas party this
weekend. I'm gonna be a **** for me.
Now be able to drink.
No.
Hello.
Thank you very much.
OK.
It's stupid.
Or maybe.
All the same hand.
Please stay from there if we have.
Right.
That was my guess.
She had a real quick. She's speaking.
And she tried to be both.
It's possible and I just said goodbye.
You want to provide about that? Yeah,
yeah, I'm sorry.
There's a certain section,
one that's assuming that's.
There's a wall. There's all over.
I think we'll take the plan well.
Really so bad.
I'm not just being too hands.
How much are you?
Nothing.
File. We need her again. That's fine.
There's a nice.
You know from.
Mr. Todd.
That's chopping paperwork.
My turn, Richard.
Oh.
Which can be great with training.
Oh my gosh.
And not just.
Sign in.
What need to sign up?
I'm baby, love it.
Next time, the last one,
you know how to use.
Or should I just put Chris Nay?
I would like that.
That is phone number too.
Yeah.
So.
Make a very, we'll send you 30 drops off.
Anything else we buy,
we'll just disappear.
Or after the word.
The.
Period.
Let me put that pesticide from back here
first.
Well, everything that she.
Yeah, there's only six or seven.
I don't know.
I just did congestion every time I come
in here.
What if you stop that's being over?
Go and sleep in your mouth.
Yeah.
I will see.
That's a free test.
Fabulous.
In the line of question question.
They're actually not. Yeah, yeah,
that's that's that's. Yeah,
it's a program. Is it for?
Yeah.
Yep.
So I'll add that to this that order
that's been working to put the Christmas
that day and we'll be,
but in the story still be impressed to be
better. Wait, wait,
does your son say this?
Half by half by 16 gauge at 60 foot. OK,
I was like, that's a channel. OK,
that makes sense.
I was like, no, baby,
you try to have by action. It's 50, bro.
Yeah, see,
that wasn't the I think it's gonna look
like you're freaking. I don't know.
The moment.
I actually got a 64 button sense on the
matchmakers.
Yeah,
I feel bad like so many different people
try our best to get.
So I'm amazed that it's not 5 to 6 feet,
so it's good to be brown.
That may have evidence, but, you know,
I'm thinking it was there since we're
here. It's on.
It's coming. It's not. Oh, yeah,
it's going to spend the work.
I'm not sure why don't they respond to
submit.
I can't import China or the import is
very responsible. Oh, there we go.
They still got us.
So we have to do I have invaluable
products where I have to do it and
they're really it's not that. That's cool.
And how do you?
But there's domestic and then there's.
Yeah, yeah, that's the big. No,
most of it is where you're active.
Project big.
Better than the inventory,
but this is the device.
It's the best place to build in this day.
I've never had it before.
Yeah, I'll try it.
It's not. It's like a cluster file.
Tom's not bad. OK,
I can't believe this from Lanza.
It's all right.
What's good to do in San Diego?
It's good to do in San Diego.
Have a food here.
He wants to go to surfing,
go deep sea fishing.
I'll possibly go somewhere on the first
week, like San Diego. Don't worry,
at least find that you're not really
approached. Yeah, that's.
I'm from there. I'm from, yeah, so.
Two of us go to San Diego, hop on a boat.
It's in the next in March.
It's a big old vegetation course,
not this time of year,
but feel pretty fun. It's rock.
Sounds like a gas.
Take them my way to get them. Oh,
I don't understand Carlos and coefficient.
What about the expense part?
Carl's is cheap.
The San Diego, too. That's good.
That's good. That's good. You did the.
It's there to eat. Yeah. What's that?
I can't stand on the well,
the Safari Park or whatever.
He's to be like, yeah,
that was pretty cool.
Change through and it's like the Savannah.
I just thought I wish to get it,
but I'm fine with Sam.
I think I some carnage. Yeah,
there's SeaWorld, which is kind of.
I like I'll see real from the Pongo.
That was good. OK. Well,
it's like Orcas of the. Yeah, it's like,
you know,
you should just have a fear in general.
It's pretty cool.
I mean,
this time of year you can go down to Rio
Pereira. I'm going to see you.
See what else?
The one that's in your house. Well,
that's a big reason to see your house.
Yeah, I don't know.
Good flight or something.
That's bad. That's a very,
very few challenges.
She's out. I mean, I think the response.
Let's see this. I've never even.
You don't just get remakes and one plot
is like nothing, right? But this way,
something.
It's.
It was very much.
It's a new to both. Huh.
Yeah, I'm.
Oh, I go there all the time.
It's what the one I the one I need.
It's good,
but it's not like 90% of it was clear. OK.
You know, you might like this.
Try a hot pot.
I'm stopping. That's like all of them.
You get all of them.
OK.
Device for Kyle.
Oh, thank you. I'm still sorry the budget.
They were trying to.
Don't die. You didn't die.
Yes, if you want to do that,
you can also try to model it.
It's not that expensive. I don't care.
At like 25 bucks, you're a decent person.
I'll toysters. So if you can start,
the key is you guys don't. So like,
that's what you can say. No, I understand.
There's still ******* 100 to $200 before
drinking.
Put a bucket right now.
$20 that's you know I'm trying to say it
was $60.00, don't worry about that.
Watch to deploy.
OK.
Should be much.
He's probably not receiving anything from
our end.
Now you're supposed to get something. Yes,
I can give it to us in fact. Right.
There are good reviews. More than others.
All you're reviewing, you'll find out.
Yeah, maybe something,
but have a little adjourned because we
got that. It's been our portal,
but that is, that's legit. Yeah,
that's legit. Yeah,
I think you sent it in and said it was
fishing. Yeah, it's not fishing.
She sent the e-mail and said this is
actually we didn't get an e-mail. Yeah,
I just got no, I got that. No,
you didn't get an e-mail. No,
she sent out an e-mail.
I said expect to receive an e-mail from
this website here to set up your account.
You know, maybe I just look on my phone.
My phone keeps grouping up and now it's.
We use the restroom. I'm all finished up,
so for a meeting once I get back,
be good to go.
I.
Anything about Rose?
Sounds good.
Which projects are you going to help
manage?
They told me they were going to help me
work with the other guys for now,
maybe 2-3 months to give me specific ones.
Yeah.
What do you like to run multi-trade or do
you care?
I mainly structure on this lanes.
I don't do other trades,
not very knowledgeable about electrical
or much of anything else.
My whole industry's been the best.
Yeah, so they are specifically for mouth.
I said I will coordinate those people to
the same time.
Do you know how percentage low row Rex
versus bills and Rex?
Yeah, I can do any of them. I mean,
it doesn't matter. I've done it both.
When I was at Sheffield,
they buy out everything.
So they would buy out fabrication that
advantage it, buy out direction,
that means that.
And I did the same thing in when I was in
California for for Bragg and rigging.
They didn't do any fabrication,
but they did all their own direction.
So I would try out fabrication there and
sell it.
So why does the crane company do steel
rection? I don't know.
I always thought it was kind of a
conflict of interest, right?
Because they were renting out cranes.
They had three different businesses.
They had a crane rental business,
obviously,
which is basically why they had a heavy
haul business.
And then they had their, yeah,
now I might and when you come visit when
I'm waiting,
but it was really just installation.
Can I have a problem with those guys who
want to let you see? Yeah,
mostly to every hall,
because that's your people using this.
So when I was at Bragman Rigging,
I became the construction manager.
That's what I was when I left.
And the only reason I left was because my
kids and grandkids moved to here.
So I told them when I get a job there,
do what I do and I'll consider moving
because they were bugging me, you know,
so I'm sure that makes sense.
Handler. Yeah, one in Scottsdale.
So they would ask every patient that came
in,
even if they were looking for somebody in
instructional steel industry, you know,
then somebody would shelf steel the game
and search them that and, Oh yeah,
we're looking for somebody just like that.
So.
2-3 months later, that's where it was.
I think Shelf's also changed a lot since
they got. But TDM Global here technically,
yeah, yeah,
TDM Global's bought so many other
companies and find them with Shell,
you know,
like the division I was with with
Sheffield Management that became.
Gray Wolf. So it's now Gray Wolf.
It's just by the name of Gray Wolf.
I wasn't really a lot of that purchase.
The Gray Wolf wasn't doing very well,
and so that's why they wanted them so
cheap.
They underbid a bunch of big *** jobs and.
I'm the project manager that usually gets
the most difficult or hardest jobs to do
and so they plot them out and next thing
you know I got $30 million job I got to
have done in like 6 months and.
I look at a bid and I'm going back and
get way over bid this.
I think we're expecting to lose 3 or 4
million.
I can't turn it around,
change order to death. We broke even.
Maybe made a few bucks,
but it was difficult. Where was that?
That was in Texas. It's Steel Dynamics.
The they're a mill in Texas.
Yeah, that's it.
How long goes about we did my create?
Probably four years ago.
You don't got any Tom Schuler? No,
I don't.
We're trying to chat.
But I think a couple of those guys are
now ended up at Gray with one.
They were working for Chattanooga.
To finish that job,
I went to Salt Lake for a year and a half
and another $30 million worth of 6
projects all on the same site for the
West Valley Prison.
So they built that and they had another
project manager assigned while I was
doing that steel dynamics job.
That guy was screwing everything up and
wouldn't return phone calls for like a
week.
And so they were ready to throw us out
the job.
So sitting recognition steel dynamics,
Tom, do you want me to go now about?
So I did like 2 weeks later,
the other PM that was sounding, he quit.
I think he knew he was probably going to
be fired.
But so I got all these screaming guys at
me for a year and a half.
So I actually went there Monday through
Thursday every week. I was in Salt Lake.
For you to have.
My friend lives in Scott Logan.
Is that right? Which is nice.
My daughter's in.
She's probably six months ago.
Yeah,
it might be the focus on free contact.
One day we'll have to work with
guesstimators. We'll get a phone.
We haven't even met them yet.
And is that during the interviews?
Nothing. I've only been there a week.
Went to two days of training and then on
the last last day of the last week
basically got my office set up,
spent a couple days getting blue beam up
to date because I have surgeons anytime I
like to blue beam for like to do my own
takeoffs and stuff.
So that took me a day and a half and then.
I started doing a take off for that
Bechtel thing and then I'm here.
So I'm finished the take off through the
one. I mean,
I was just going to do a portion of the
three hyperaction, whatever.
They're not real hyperaction,
they're just structural steel, I mean.
So like I say, I haven't met anybody yet.
Talk to them on the phone one time or a
couple times for a meeting.
We had all that meeting THC for like 1
minutes. That's it. Have you other team?
Right.
So currently at this moment we have these
routes defined in here.
We don't have inspections tied to them.
This would be a question from all.
Did you like the way that that was set up
for your tracking?
You guys are going to continue to do
follow inspections in site docs or do we
want to time an inspection to each one of
these? We do that,
then they're going to have to go.
I don't want to time inspection because
right now I don't have a dedicated QC
person.
Is this what at least involving in
percentages and tracking?
Give you some time,
some realistic times for what it takes to
get the process done without associating
an inspection to it.
Then marking a completed APM bill will
give you that activation of the process.
Just not going to have the reports.
If if I go to any of our previous
production jobs,
I can go in there and select the
associated assemblies and pull the
collection resorts,
which gives me the QC that inspected it
and then the reports.
Some of my customers have asked for that.
This is moving forward.
We can do per assembly, not per assembly.
We can't just do the department assembly
or we can, you know,
we can build that inspection that is not
tied to.
I'll send you guys all the old one, see.
I'm trying to get in a site box anyway
like that. That's our job.
It's gonna build one.
I haven't been since you're going to.
See,
I have to see that it's not a specific
piece. You have to make pieces for it.
She can build or it's not a piece.
So if you want to do your environmentals
and all that stuff, so.
Yeah,
let's let's just do a fresh move so that
we've got it. In that in that report,
you should say that the system crashed
for an hour. It has been doing.
I've got some big cabins.
So to do the to do the doc,
the document that is currently on site
docs that is not tied to a piece like
your environmentals and stuff.
We'll be able to run one real quick so
you can see how it function and you
decide what you want to do if you're
trying to run a site doc.
You can see now how it works here.
It's an option. Yeah, that works for you.
Um, hit that drop down for test night.
And you know we could just change it to
environment or whatever.
You know we can we can build whatever we
want here.
That's that is just hit that one more hit
that one more time.
Those right there the only ones that need
assembly part and load go back into the
job and you have to do it.
Whereas everything else in the category,
rich building form is all we're doing.
So it's just a category that you hit.
So you could do another page,
you could do another environmental,
we can build,
we can do whatever category you want.
Finance is to do it under the page.
Yeah, and then yeah,
you could add multiples under under the
paint designation really. What?
What do you want to be?
Well, what's what's on somebody's?
Yeah, you know,
I guess I can try and regulate at least
the the topics that it covers and see how
we can associate the test fields with
what the data currently.
OK.
That we can build these in it,
even if the artist building for one
requirement is some field somewhere has
to have the ability to fail,
but that's one of the requirement here.
Well,
actually we do a surface preference for
it, but we're gonna need him that as just.
Method and I guess profile if it's
splashed.
Cool.
So now we're just building the fuel cell
here that we want.
You're going to get date,
you're going to get who's doing it anyway.
That's just part of the fence.
We're we'll build everything. Well,
you got who, when it happened, what date,
who did it and what area you see like
there's a there's a location you have to
fill out.
Other than that.
For you to build the fields.
So what what do you want as first field?
What would you say your mission? Method,
method or standard?
Let's put standard that is SP2 three.
Do you want a nice drop down with
different options?
Unnecessarily, no. So do we have to?
Can it be free? You see there's tabs.
Bully is a checkbox.
So we can build a checkbox.
Numeric is a number, date.
Text is a phrase. Memo is a paragraph.
You want and then drop that.
We can build a custom drop. Yeah,
I think it'll just be test SP2 or SP10 or
whatever.
Just call out the standard.
So I'm not going to do this test since
it's just SP2 or something. Yeah,
why sometimes like I'm galvanizing stuff.
So instead of the galvanizing,
if it's been weather six months or more,
all you have to do is an SP block.
If it's less than six months.
You can pass it and then that's the one
or you can so it can be.
That's why I just want a brief so the guy
can just type in whatever he did.
So is it always in the SP4SP3? Yeah,
it's always going to be in this.
SP1 one I might put SP-1,
one I might S1 and if you want to get
start working with the data and trying to
build it for some of this,
that's going to make it very difficult to
open it.
So maybe because it can drop in two weeks.
Yeah, we just have on standard. Yeah,
who we didn't drop down.
They get rid of the pair and drop down
there.
So you're just going to get a new option
and then put in the SP factors here.
Now we could do the SP one as we do put
all the SP factors.
We see that we're still options up there.
We could uncheck that and you I could
pick one of those that makes sense.
We kind of updated it too.
I'm on these things here, son.
Easy.
10 and then for 13.
This is Rashad,
I want to make security so I can't read
that thing.
Just be in there. We can you want to.
You want to turn it off so you can.
Say that again. You want it? We go.
You want it to turn it off so you can't
have this work? Yeah, whatever you want.
OK, cool.
What else? What in the field do you want?
We don't need to worry about job number
or anything like that, right?
That'll be associated.
You'll be associated. Yeah,
a job number that's in the system. Well,
this this type of test is not going back
to your job to do anything.
So it is for a particular job.
Yeah, yeah, right. Then put in, yeah,
put in the job number.
Just texted on that and we'll be open.
Do you guys have forms for each step,
whereas see paint forms for preps here?
We have a prep and paint application for
prep and paint form and then we have a
code SQC form.
Wait, what's easier?
Is it easier to put multiple things on
one form with different sections?
Or is it one per? What's more efficient?
What do you want me to do?
You can like require certain fields to be
filled. If you have, if you're doing them,
if you have a record where you have a
prep session and your paint session in it,
you have to have a ball unlocked where
you can leave it empty and not respond to
it.
People just get complicit with that.
They'll start filling in just doing it
quick.
Think of these as you're building one for
each point in time.
So if it's like like some people want to
build a QC test where I have one traveler
basically says I I did a fit check,
I did a well check,
I did the final final check.
And they want, they want one for them.
That won't work for this because like I
wanted to submit it for fit because I
want to fail it. Well,
it's required me to do weld and paint as
well. I don't want to do that. I need it.
I need a second pace for each each one
time.
So you got a job number in there? Yeah,
we got, we got a job number.
Yeah,
I think that I mean we can add profile
for blasted.
But leave that unlocked where he can.
He can leave it on field because they're
getting.
We're doing a.
OK.
What else do you want?
I think that's simple.
You want like a notes field or something.
All that. Yeah. Is that in this month?
Or do you ever you work?
We're gonna hold back on what's not to
paint, yeah.
We don't.
We don't worry about that on report.
So we get our guys, get the drawings,
they look out and we pull backs.
I'm going to build the option. That's it.
But in terms of production, it's not,
it's not better than.
And.
There's not before, I guess.
We factor in when we bid,
but we figure out what we want to be
there. Yeah,
I don't feel that has the ability to fail.
Good job.
You have to do it on the system because
that text and memory can't fail.
So we should be able to fill out if he's
if he's required to get an SP1 and he did
it. That's that's a bill right there.
I mean SP 135133 are single.
So why don't we leave?
It's supposed to be an SP1, let's say.
But then there's a lot of people says,
yeah, pastor bid, but significant.
It is these points, for example,
when they're required to blast an SP6 or
an SP10,
if that pass the SP6 to everywhere,
you know,
you'll have some shadowing or some, yeah,
some stuff for that.
So.
They're already one of these set up for
all the types of blasting for that
separation,
but is that not if you want to? There's.
That's what we're involved.
So there's probably a record for everyone.
We have everything.
So I just wanted we're doing all this
trouble and track specifically codings
when we do this same type of thing or
blasting as well. Well,
that's that's how we generalize the
service, but whether it's supplies or.
If you put it down as prep, period. Yeah,
you got it. OK.
And then in prep I can say,
is it a pressure wash? Is it a power tool?
Is it acetone wiper? Yeah, it's a sandbox.
Yeah. OK,
will then be on the tablet or the desktop
tablet?
Let's grab the tablet and we'll see what
it would look like.
For this,
just click on tech power at the top and
you can get back out of the what do I
have to do it in the job.
Just get general inspections there.
I.
Please.
So this is on SP3.
So profile I won't be because there's no
profile required on the speed read.
So you have to fill it in.
You can't dig a blank. No,
you can definitely whether it's whether
it's optional or not.
So let's get that profile thing optional.
That's been on those. Yeah.
See the attach that I had filed to get
that on the tabs.
It's generally no say you want to make a
picture. You want to grab the picture.
I can fill this out and then just take
pictures of one thing instead if you want
anything. Yep. Thank you both.
Hmm.
You just want to do is you click in the
text file.
2.
Actually protection add files.
Thank you.
This database must get huge when you
start throwing pictures. Well,
the pictures technically don't get saved
in the database.
It it has what's called document index
and so you can attach it is the document
index is just followed on your server.
So take it and it'll put it there and
then the test actually just has a link to.
To where it would.
So the database doesn't really hold the
the pictures, it's just the links.
So that's a I used it for about.
I don't know 8-9 years,
close to 10 years and didn't really move
anything out of it.
And I think about that that's where one
of the half gigs. So wasn't messing.
And how do you know if without this form
of the lake,
which pictures were for what job?
It gives it some kind of naming.
Yeah, it it, it stores it in.
It has a forward system that it uses.
It creates it. Yeah, yeah,
it it manages it for you.
So you really don't have to be able to
back them and pull anything. It doesn't,
so.
No.
Nothing more today.
It established. It doesn't work.
Looks like there's another problem that
is looking for somewhere, yeah.
Do you want to have do you hit the the IF
files over here?
OK.
So I'm really freaking out on you guys.
Any one value there?
I think it's something.
OK.
Hi Google.
Stop.
She.
That's what I said.
So we can turn that off, but.
You'd have to probably leave it first,
but yeah, yeah.
How do you get the form to capture the
loan growth memo header and all that?
Just go ahead. Oh,
you're going to hear me.
How did you say what over there?
No, no, I didn't.
Oh.
If you failed it then you can run a
follow up to it if you want to and you
can have like I I used to say that where
if if it failed like there was a I was
getting 0 NCRS in the shot.
That ****** me off.
And so I would require that that when the
inspector failed anything,
whether it was a piece,
whether it was something else,
then there were some fields he had to
fill out.
They were basically not the mortgage
fields and they had to fill his house.
So you couldn't build stuff like that and
then on the follow up.
Then there were certain other fields they
had to fill out. OK, well, what happened?
What'd you do to resolve it? I just.
So there's all kinds of stuff like that
you can build into these forms if you
want to, but.
Yeah,
we got put a few different ones in here
and then we got welding machine
inspection.
We got to work with inspections, uh.
But all these are associated are.
You could, yeah,
you could then like I used to get it.
You set these up to send your reporting
on it.
So like I used to get reporting that
would anything if they want to have a
report need helping at the end of the day.
So I had a for for another so.
So you can set those up.
I'm going to that thing inspection.
What was it?
Yeah, that's good. Apply filter.
So hit the Sheffield's over here on the
left, the check box over here on the left.
That should all the fields.
So a lot of times when it came down to,
I'm I'm looking for trains and what not.
I would just get the data here dumped out
in Excel and then I start pivoting some
bar graphs and all this.
As to see if I'm getting any issues or
whatnot, but if you go to the top,
just go to just so we can see reports and
then you can get the just do the
inspection test or everything. It's cool.
So if you needed to just e-mail us out,
maybe not in.
And let's go on on my system.
That's the big time.
This is the only kind of guy who clicks
and I know exactly where to click before
the next screen rolls.
**** really messes that up.
I'm sitting there clicking in the area I
shouldn't and then I finally loads and
then I'm clicking to something else.
Yeah, but if we think it's up to Trimble,
it's or they'll let me add job sites.
Every time I try and add a job site,
as soon as I click save,
whole program should come.
Couldn't get a job site address to show
up on my road list to save my life.
We're every workaround they're trying to
do it and not get it to save in there.
So I don't want it to revive, not revive.
You know,
it was on the service pack three. Yeah.
And so then they were like, yeah,
you know, go to service pack five,
that'll probably fix it and then we
switch to I instead, so.
But I can. I can't.
It's not asking a close down. You know,
I just keep having these reoccurring
issues of of the system,
giving you the spinning of that.
And then you're wondering,
can you guys go back?
Yeah, we've got a number of versions.
The reason they wanted to go through this
version is so that we can preplan future
production is this 2025 pie has the
ability to because we currently have the
production planner for active production
jobs.
This portion has the ability to forecast
future work.
Which is kind of what we want to get into
this and we know we got this many hours
coming up.
Usually we can't go back because all the
data that's gone in there since you
updated is in the new table format.
And so trying to get that backwards,
you kind of lose all that so.
Right. Yeah.
So depending on how long you have your
update on how much you're going to use.
Because I'm sure it has to go back to the
exact date,
but it was the region's favors.
But when it's warm,
I don't see this anywhere else. You know,
I have to think your environment.
I don't care if I see the bad or not so,
but if it was worth that help.
I would say this is how the issues and
every time it doesn't a second on TD
restarts and we go get back to normal.
Yeah,
they should probably get somebody looking
into our system.
Yeah, there.
You can.
There's a there's a way to submit a
ticket from in here.
It gets all the long files in the
background at the end of the backup,
sitting into them if you want to.
It's getting ahead of it. Yeah,
once instead of the Logan,
the scheduling program come along
compared to like Microsoft Project and
their project schedule is.
If we're doing a project or re verify,
it's pretty deep value.
I think I was here a couple of years ago
was wasn't anywhere near as good as
Microsoft Project.
It was so it's it's that same as one of
us two years ago.
Yeah,
the problem that most people have with it
is they they want to,
they want to bid for Excel with this and
they know Excel and they sit down and do
this. It's like Microsoft Project,
you know. So that's the problem. It's.
I think it's incredibly powerful.
Will it do the stuff like sales? Like, OK,
this has gotta be done for for the start,
stop and finish to start, finish to start,
and it'll give all those type of settings
in there. Yeah.
So you get the advantage of it reads the
information from within the system. Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah,
I always thought it would be cool to use
it, but every time I'd ask,
I was told that, you know,
it wasn't really as good as I I love the
schedule in there and I made a 10 part
video that I wanted on my on my YouTube
channel because I think people want to
use it.
People don't give it enough.
Uh, they'll have a patience.
Let me put it that way. Yes. Uh,
Microsoft Project could be that way too.
It'd be so big for patients to learn it.
I understand. Yep.
Does the scheduling module in RFM
incorporate costing?
No, no,
it's it's pretty much your timeline and
percentage is complete,
schedule hours and that's what we don't.
It doesn't do that.
It has the hours of it,
so we can tell you, OK.
You had scheduled it to be done this
percent here this day and it's gonna know
that it's not done there because not
hours were spent or yeah,
it actually does it. It looks at the.
There's a number of different ways you
can say it,
but essentially some of the pieces of
literature that are not regardless of the
hours understandable, OK.
This video reports to the supplier.
Now there's actually.
I'll I'll call it reschedules later.
There's the project schedule,
which is the Microsoft project that can
field what's called the production
schedule in here that says OK,
this meeting hours over this time frame
that spreads the hours out.
A fairly simplified version that they
came out with what's called production
planner in 2025 version that is a much
more in depth.
Shop schedule where they can take your
available hours and say, yeah,
you're gonna meet those available hours
these weeks and these weeks you're not.
Yes. So you basically,
I've done that on Excel spreadsheet,
but it's yeah.
The conversation and then it's like I
I'll have a year in advance. So OK,
three months from now it looks like I'm a
little slow, you know,
or or I'm overbooked.
So I gotta either hire more guys or work
overtime. Yeah,
but it'll do stuff like that.
And this is the one.
Yeah,
so you basically you use what's called
the work packages and the work packages
can be auto populated with hours from the
estimate if the estimate's in here.
And so it says I've got 350 hours of work
for this package. Well,
you can drag it into a week and they'll
split it out by apartments if you wanted
to.
Yes.
Just to like you, are you you wise?
I mean,
I'm hard like you're on the same way home.
This will be the same thing you would do
every time I try to edit.
Jobs and units to and spins and spins
around and I go right back into it.
You need to.
You know we shouldn't be able to do this.
Guarantee you,
I'm gonna purchase it so when I try and
view one of my reports,
it'll show me this area of the.
System is not having.
We'll text it wasn't ahead of Technical
Support,
but I'm not sure that I don't think he is
anymore. I can talk to you.
This is.
That's a brutal, yeah.
Yeah,
especially since we're trying to update
this program right now and get all of
some stuff in there and have this problem
sucks.
No, let's not.
It's a new thing with us and hospitals
and suburbals, you know,
keep us on our clothes.
So I used to use natural and near
unfactual and I just wait, wait,
wait to be aware of water,
drop by the water cooler,
chit chat about everything come back over.
So I'll give out another few minutes.
You were using it. I had, I had the old,
old bathroom and and so it's the path.
Yeah, yeah, it was awesome. You know,
I had, I had the same phone. Terrible.
Can I use it though?
This is my exit board and I asked you to
phone.
I asked him if he's seen any network
related issue for 2025 out and he said
have not seen any that I'm aware of at
least not.
We've been show the training so.
It's just that you want me to see if one
of them can help me in and do what it's
what they saw. Not a bad idea. Definitely,
especially if we're going to start
feeling productive and then getting shot.
Mid-thought, yeah.
This is.
It's not condition anything.
Do they know you as Revolution or do they
know you as?
I'm pretty sure everything's been
switched at this point.
All of our licenses.
Yeah, that was a that one was locked out.
I had a bunch of top projects that had
been pushed through.
I couldn't log in effect of this.
We didn't pay,
didn't pay for licensure control.
How many of you guys are gonna use last
planner? Anybody gonna use last what?
Last planner? I think you heard me.
So.
I think we're talking about scheduling
CPM. I know it's critical path.
It's a plan that assumes everything goes
right.
Last planner goes to the other production.
It looks the other way.
It says these are we need what are these?
So it's going to take the main time.
So a lot of times the engineering
companies give you this primavera 3 level,
6 level,
I have no idea what level and it's like
this is what we need and all the reality
is.
Very beautiful.
And so a lot of the construction trades
from what's called last time schedules
going the other way and there are really
good YouTube discussions over the pros
and cons, but if you're really the guy,
you want to deploy.
Last month is better for you.
If you're the guy pushing the program,
you may do CPM,
but it's you're assuming all these things
actually work when you schedule it.
Now you can add folks to all kinds of
stuff to it,
but if you guys aren't familiar with us
planner,
it's pretty used to establish the
construction.
In the industry, uses it, uses it,
uses it.
I guess.
People sitting in an office can say all
day long how long it's going to take.
I drove from Ogden to Durango. Actually,
I was driving.
I was just listening to last night or
YouTube, you know,
YouTube for a lot of that drive.
Because I figured I was getting ready to
go into, you know,
more of a construction based business
like this, yeah, like.
There's some tools there and that's the.
Everybody loves Gantt charts.
They look because they're easy. Yeah.
And for me, these days,
if you don't have earned valid,
then you're still doing that extra earned
valid work because everybody wants to
know you have to.
All right, this will be a start.
I'm on top of you all again.
I'm just the last one to call.
Yeah, but you know,
I don't know if it's going to be 2
minutes or two hours. I don't mind.
So usually when I hit up the head of
support with it,
you kind of expedites it a little bit,
pushes everything through. Yeah,
they kind of.
I've got to have a agent and if I'm on
site I have a lot of troubles there to
try to get more.
I would they know you're a lot of times
you're at, you're at the site training.
Yeah,
because you know how it goes out a lot of
the next week before you referral.
That's true. They've been doing.
They've been doing pretty good with their
gear support stuff. That's good.
So usually 2-3 hours at Max.
Otherwise I sometimes I call and within 5
minutes I can get somebody.
That's awesome to go.
That's been the exact thing for really
bad over the past year or two, so.
Now lean in there,
try and generating report.
Let's try to report the user everything.
Thinking there's an issue that I don't
know.
Basically saying that more than that
because that's what I'm working on. Yeah.
So this one you need to go where you want.
So you you guys have to value what you
what you're going to say.
Obviously if you need to do this,
I think there's advantage to put
everything in one system because it
drives everybody two to one system.
This was consistent,
but it definitely what what you really so
so you can't be on this though when I do
you are the one that asks for certain
pieces.
Yeah, what the heck?
Now there we go every time.
The spinning wheel of death. Yeah,
the good thing is that it's a repeatable
problem.
Yeah, yeah. Otherwise you have a problem.
So now they logged in on me,
they can see it, right?
Theory. Yeah, there's meeting.
I don't do what they did last time.
This is Steve.
There's something wrong with your system.
You should freak out. Yes, there is.
That's what.
Reinstall. This is that on my page.
Let me do my job, please.
Only imagine what audit's doing if you
can't pull reports. Yeah. Are you sure?
Like, how are we?
How am I supposed to pull each member
report for a job if this is working? Yeah,
well, so.
They are excellent on the production side.
So we've got to say we can track
everything we you know what we need to do
there. We looked at.
And then the inspection basically set up
and be on that, right? Yep. Yeah, that's.
Is there anything else on the production
side for the cadence? I don't know.
I can think of that, Kevin.
The flooring's only in the flooring's
complex.
If you want to expand on those,
you can do with coatings complex with a
specified prep that we can do,
but that's just gonna have more stations
in your in our system.
What's what's what's the.
What's the part? What's the? Yeah,
you see the issues, the questions,
any problems? I mean, you know,
that's one thing I have to worry about.
I'm not going to have anything. Yeah,
that's good. So right now, I mean,
I've said what I what I thought.
I'm going to find out, but.
It's we're not going to find anything out
until we actually run, run,
run my job through it.
We'll see what the case are other than
time consumption aspect of it.
If I'm going to have like my painters
specifically started doing this or if I'm
going to have a lead out in the shop.
Be the one taking down all this data
because it can,
depending on the side of the side of the
job, it can be a lighting process.
I don't know if this would be I don't
think I can answer this.
Hello.
Yeah, I'll tell you what, I have a client.
Can I call you back when I leave?
Is that OK?
Perfect. Yeah, yeah, just send.
Up.
That'd be perfect.
I can perfectly help you. All right,
no problem. Thank you.
Sorry, that wasn't there.
I'm guessing is what do you gain if we
put the breakdown instead of this?
Hang simple or main complex or whatever
it is, we start doing it SP1 simple thing,
SP2 simple thing like break that up.
What other benefits you could get?
It would just be the.
Being able to differentiate your start
and stop findings, how that differs.
So at the end of the day,
you're getting the same data,
you're getting the same markup,
but you're going to be doing the same
start-stop system and you'll be able to
identify what's taking longer.
You're just gonna have different.
It's the same exact setup,
it's just a different call out for it in
the same start stop.
I'll probably want that in finish. Yeah,
you can have that in the finish field SB,
SB,
simple or complex or whatever you want to
do.
Hey Nancy,
you have that you have visibility to
finish field in there and then the routes
you're tracking because I'd like to get
to the way to where I get this job.
It's a it's an SP3 with this this primer.
I want to see what our historicals has
been before that specific system.
Be able to filter very easily.
We do it as a paint simple prep paint
complex and it's going to give me a boat
load of jobs that I'm going to have to
filter through all based off.
Makes a lot of sense. Yeah, yeah.
So if you if you did that as the finish
of P3C.
We would be able to filter for all these
pieces and the time for and if you do the
start shot, yeah,
that would be filling out. But yeah,
it's something to finish.
Yeah,
I was gonna say you might have to clean
up some of that.
Yes.
Do you have any type of standard
legislation for that? OK,
so then I have to come up about the
system.
And if you can get your detailers to do
that field for you or you can just import
it or that would make it very simple to
to use to import it cause they're already
putting on trials anyway, right?
So although if it's if it's a coding zone,
you'll have control over that there.
I'd say that and see what you what
primarily runs through the shop, I mean.
Excuse me, SP2 or SP3,
maybe SP6 every once in a while and then
beyond that I don't think we're able to
get 2 on a driver or two coats of paint
pencil, yeah.
Or zinc. Zinc needs to be separated.
That's really surprising to me.
Like my impression though,
you guys were doing lots of SD6, you know?
Well, we would keep them on paper, right.
But as as a fabricator, we, you know,
sometimes we want to. I mean,
they're sending delightful.
They ain't sending delightful by now.
Now again, they'll send the light bulbs.
No,
we don't have any comment that we
recently got done so.
He wants to go. I've done it.
It was easier.
But that's at the speed six. Yeah,
I think it's actually correct. OK, yeah,
it's too close to Derek finish.
I think the complex is pretty much always
in the I guess complex on the SP2SP3 and
SP6, yeah.
Probably never see one week.
No, that's a big.
We rarely do miss the money.
It's honestly never happened.
What about all those water stuff?
Isn't that SB10 on the water? Yeah,
but that's how I feel.
I have nothing here in the shop.
We have some tank plates.
That's all SP6 too. Maybe.
I think just the group there,
not the group that was SP6,
the pipe schools are around here.
What is that? Is that? That's all right,
three times.
So that's just an SP2 handstand and just
pressure wash to get the dust off.
Somebody else? Yeah.
So a lot of the coatings always we do.
We exclude manufacturers, prep and prime.
So any steel you want to ship us in the
shop we're a bit more.
We do a bit more from scratch,
but all the field stuff.
We try to get away from the initial just
because it takes sandblast and no one
wants to pay for it on the field.
When we run a production job,
when you import, get everything in there,
you have to find your codings only route
and they will find and finish and then
they'll have the ability to filter it out.
So that would give you the.
The granular level of load over here
going forward,
but I think this will pretty much cover
us. So SP2SP3, SP13 or we'll see.
I mean down the road.
These are the most common stuff.
This is super easy to have anyways.
If you have to ramp up,
you're calling to SB6SB10 in the future.
Big deal. No big deal. You know,
just take some dirt. It's got a yeah.
Did the hall you do how many tests?
The old Joe smoking refreshment.
No,
the biggest problem I have out there is
the guys realizing the difference between
SP6 and SP10, for example,
making sure they're using the right. Yeah,
a few months ago we had some new guys
start blasting and the first thing they
blasted was one of those government
trailers over this weekend.
And then we have those big WW calls
coming in and they thought they needed to
get an SP10 and it looks like an SP10 and
so it was taking a guy 3 days of last
night.
We brought a new guy just about last time
he was getting a call.
Yeah, yeah,
that's that's a big difference. I mean,
give the guy a credit.
I don't know that I could,
especially with all that gear on,
tell the difference that easily something
you got to learn what you're constantly.
I can't something easily.
You gotta see them both side by side to
realize the differences, then you're good.
As well as you do it all the time.
What I was just going to be into is now
that we have you know with us going
through what we do have set up for for
coding's estimation.
We have SB1 through SB10 are they broken
up in there.
I don't know what we have to look up for.
As in labor standards.
And then we have our current few
different coding systems in there and you
can take a look at those and we can make
adjustments in that tab if we need to in
there. Tell me what you got to see.
So.
So we didn't know how many square foot
per hour you guys are doing and then how
much would be abrasive pounds per square
foot you guys are using.
So we kind of.
So it's SP2. I mean,
right now we estimate like all the post
stuff, any of the runways, any shop stuff.
We do it on.
We do it on prep at 100 on the paying
gallon square feet an hour.
The problem is,
it really depends on the type of material.
If you're working with the structural,
you'll get a lot more square footage done
and you're working with smaller trues and
angles and places and that kind of stuff.
So these are customizable.
You're not stuck with this.
You could do that.
SB2 like or something like that and have
two different rates if you want to apply.
So you can bill these out differently if
you wanted to.
Mr. Potentious, it's probably not support.
We'll do that. Do that hungry.
Uh, our SP2 is just. Yeah, this is. Yeah,
so you can. OK, this seems not why.
That's.
Sure.
Do that at once.
I love you got these numbers. I I I'm,
I can break out a little of the number of
shops that have these numbers.
It's so it's great to be out.
After every job I go back and I see the
challenge I face in making sure the guys
apply the time for the right clothes,
yeah.
But I I go back and I try to clean it up
to where I am.
This is how I know this is how much
production we get on this type of stuff
or that type of stuff.
Um.
Watching the screen.
The code is all new ones.
All I set up was the.
Sure.
I would just run with what we have here.
I'll make the adjustments as well as to
make sure all the employees of their
coatings have something associated with
it and we can make the adjustments on the
runtime and then do a drop date of when
they're going to contract.
And make sure all of our active projects
have been out on the board meetings. Yeah,
solving cleaning,
going faster than power cleaning.
Is that legit?
Solid cleaning says 600 square square
foot per hour and power tool cleaning
says the thousand square foot per hour.
This is probably amount of.
So.
See where you have.
Affirms.
From America, I told you.
You're the one who said things like the
******* piece, so you can throw it up.
That's me one.
I love it. We don't do it.
SP3 is our standard,
so whenever an estimator creates a sniff
and associates that one with the little
asterisks is the one that's going to
default.
So I keep that.
So this one's going to be.
Do we want to do something similar with
that as as small and slaves and then
heavy structure? No, no,
that's that's the same. OK, SP5,
that's pretty, but I'll do it on that.
But I'll say put it at 10.
What do you think we'll iron orders?
But that could be.
Obviously these are all things that we
can go in and go in the maintenance and
codings. OK, SP6SP6 put that at like 130.
And then you've been trying to know how
many panels and if work bounds the.
The good thing is I have to come in today.
We can put on a sandpots,
start getting guys in the middle of this
year.
You know where I got that from?
I shot lasting clean, you know,
and grace of use on that one. Uh, four.
Keep it at four. No, that one too. Yeah.
I'll do.
Near why put that at 90 other hours.
And then four hours long, 5 on this one.
So we got the speed that actually bring
bring that down to 8 on this,
so I'm going to get the the use of
accurate.
Yeah, me as well. Well,
I think the future you're gonna have it
if you can save us.
Get us some status and we'll put it in.
Where are we going to do that?
Is that the?
They've got these to find. You know,
you've got some public cycling areas,
some of the perpetual issues,
so potentially.
Yeah, exactly. I mean,
while we're on the blast,
good fabricated information right there.
Do you know what the plating embrace of
prices up there? Is that Saturday or 10?
No.
Uh, is it per time? Yeah, per time.
Do we take great things for God to listen?
Yes, well.
It's the very.
And.
18 magnitude. No, that's what superset.
That's two times, right?
400 is 2 * 9565.
So can you put in different braces?
This one's just in the one.
It's just we need different consumption
rates. OK,
so I'm already clear then about pricing.
There's there's always a way.
So I mean if we zero this out,
there are other ways to do it which would
be a little bit more difficult on a take
off basis, but we could do it.
Because here's some we're trying to get
the shop fully on technical.
Basically use the shop or new garden
recycled garden because I got recycled
over here and use and steel stuff.
I guess we do, but it's.
It's not like it as consumable as.
But it's more of those poor bank prices,
each ones at a different price.
So how do we account for that?
What determines which one you need?
I think you go with the new one.
New Garth. Yeah, yeah, that price is good.
Is this the local place to put all this
stuff in for the whole system?
This is your estimate.
This particular folk are playing just for
isolating.
But I don't see it in here,
but it's not populated.
The data was not populated. Yeah. Well,
now most of the most of the estimating if
they're adding like material pricing or
if they're adding consumable pricing and
stuff like that.
They're pulling the labor out of this,
and then they're creating separate line
items and pulling their own data and
putting it in there.
The estimators don't use the system for
much more than labor hours at this point.
They're consumables are a separate line
item.
We're going to send that letters.
We were talking about adding that in to
the first quarter because they want us to
track consumables for a job and it's it's
like a with the way certain machines work,
you wind up with all the consumers on one
job.
So every time you purchase,
they want you to put it all over a job
you're working on. So yeah,
I want to try to figure that out.
What's future plans today?
The interstate estimating they want to
really be in here on it.
They want it all to run through this one
system. We all the proposals have,
but what I really say is it's not in here
now,
but we need to mention that we need to
roll all that **** in there,
even their time,
even their time to develop the jobs.
That needs to be accounted.
Everything that would have us put on the
jobs need to be in the estimator.
I'm just saying right now I'm just doing
this as a blank field.
I'm not sure what you're looking to say.
You know,
so they've got the capacities in here.
You know, are these numbers right?
I'll bet you they are because they're not
the out of the boxes.
I'm sure we've looked at it before.
So yeah,
I'm pretty sure that's a lot of this is
really you got an angle that's big when
you run through your angle line.
So a lot of this doesn't have to do so.
So much of the time it's on this
particular spring.
So the sphere there is one.
I'm cutting the plate that says if I can
share it based off of the perimeters I
have here apply that time there for shear.
So here it's here now so it's not going
to do any shear and it's going to just
always assume burning.
So yeah, yeah,
we zeroed that out last time because
we're having a lot of issues with our
plate done.
This majority of our stuff is able to run
the sheer,
which almost nothing ever was about all
weird. So.
Your paints are probably pretty much sick,
right? Those are pretty much. Yeah,
I think most of those were were well
defined in there.
There was some tweaks that we had to do.
So is that the 80% of what you did right
there?
Let's say, well,
you got the manufacturer off macropoxy,
but yeah, macropoxy. All right.
Now for that, that container size,
is that like the minimum quantity,
I guess you'd say it's a rammed up type
feature, so.
So Ben just adding .
75 of the L It's gonna round it up to one.
Yes, yeah, change that to.
Macrobox is either in a two or a 10k
opportunity.
Uh, Manufacturer is Sherwin. Price is 49.
Drop to the next.
Double layer,
double layer of multipliers on the labor
rate that we have in here for us to
become a more if this is simplified.
They're not a record.
It's a intermediate filler and then a
finished filler. The product is separate.
There's a there's a setting back that
says paint or say 43 beam.
Here's how it's most people are saying
that. Here's what it doesn't.
Prime that and that's how many minutes
that is.
So that later multiplier layer of two
says I'm going to double that time for
for macro oxy rather than prime.
Now right or wrong we can set that later.
Well it it kind of makes sense but I'm
thinking not because it's too close but
because you most of the time you got two
guys.
That's your painter and you got your pot
center. So whatever,
if one guy spends one hour just to pay
physically, you got two men. So I mean,
we can keep it there, I guess.
If it doesn't, so cruise it up.
Did you say 45 or 40?
49 and we can we can set this number to
run on the same desert following.
Steel spec compared the size to 5 gallons.
And what back of proxy we use since 46?
What was that?
What box do you use? 646? Yeah,
but but it's 646 because it's another
back one that we use occasionally. Yeah,
I use the tenants and move.
That I don't care.
Uh,
also change this the thickness for that
one else.
Oh no,
tell them what they just keep it for.
Usually just do one code.
Steel spec container size is 5 gallons on
that.
This is a change. It's over.
You can keep the coverage at 1:50.
I said six. What's the numbers on that?
100? Yeah, it was 100. Yeah, yeah,
put that at 1.5.
Oh, for the for the Max.
And you can do the same with this like
big structural smallness.
So when you have that cost in there,
you need to pick up all the costs for
thinners and all that stuff.
So people will have thinner in there as
well.
So they'll have it separately and just
there's not many times when they just
move for the for the government.
So you can you can include the the
theater in that or have a separate
theater in his parking places.
There you go. If you want to,
you can do it.
I'm sure you're buying so much thinner
per gallon.
So was there a way that that can be tied?
If it's estimated 20 gallons of macro,
it means that I need 5% of the dinner.
Well, you can say $29.00 add 5 bucks. Yes,
either that way or do you want to say so
much, so much for dinner or so much?
For for a problem or do you want to just
like from?
I'll carry it through to the end of that
number.
Either or that's that's what we got.
The estimators are going to just want one
number. They are one number.
It's going to make it easier for the
estimators if it's just all in one. Yeah,
just copy pasting numbers.
Yes, so you are here.
Or they wanted specific, yes.
Oh, it's.
Of course it is.
I'm just saying if you do get a special
requirement, because I've seen it,
what's the 80%? What's the 80%?
What's the majority of your work?
Uh.
It's not about adding it,
it's about how do we deal with it.
So that's more of your question,
100% what I just respect.
The question I can't remember off the top
of my head is the spec and the data sheet
are in line or not.
So what what you would do on that if you
had something?
So especially when you start your
estimate,
this will pull into the estimate.
Then you can adjust these for that
estimate if you want to.
So yeah,
let's just keep this thing here as a data
sheet.
Same thing on the quantity for the other
steels bag.
So.
No,
Kate did not think that doesn't talk
about the third line.
The third paint type we got. Oh yeah,
this one.
So you have 5 gallons and 36, yeah.
Oh,
you got that for small miscellaneous
stuff? Yeah, and you can do it.
I saw it's in there.
That's all they're here. Yeah,
doing the data size of 1.25.
Cost per gallon. It's it's like 90 day,
90 days coverage one.
160.
Uh, take this for call 2 minutes.
I will take the speed notes.
Thank you.
Do you want to double multiplier for the
next? I mean,
if it if it still translates to where we
have been on the pot tender, let it know.
That's fine.
It depends on the time that you put in
the background.
So if it's literally 15 minutes at home,
then the two will get the two guys,
but if you say 30 minutes.
To account for the two guys and we want
that one,
you know it's like in that time tracking
that technical adult. No,
there's some like go up to maintenance
estimating labor maintenance and labor
standards.
get down to a beam or something or
whatever,
whatever material you want to go to.
Do the paint there says 44006 minutes.
See at the tops it's standard length of
40 foot.
So that's what it's going to apply.
So if you say 2, there's going to be 8.8.
12.
So this is this is what it estimates it
will take depending that when I put that
multiplier and there's going to say that
there's going to be 8 minutes total 4
minutes for it.
So if you can do it whichever way you
want, you can do it.
You can do the two multiplier over there
if this is the actual.
In the actual time,
whereas if they don't have the birthday
skin, I don't know it will do one or two.
Yeah.
Do we want to give them a little
structural dislanges for each one of
these and call it?
What is I saw? Is this 890? No,
it's just I saw.
That's that's their product.
Just know all their products by number
'cause they have different slightly
different numbers here.
In the system we find we have a job.
You need to put one in there for the hot
solids.
Since we have 11 years of pain.
Yeah.
Who pays to make this one? You customer.
Customer usually says give me like they
don't pick the brand. No,
they have a spec. They tell you they want,
you know,
their crime coat to be an epoxy crime
coat percent solid, but extra at least.
You pick them and then I I got to submit
something and they got approved. But yeah,
I have a choice. OK,
but do the estimators know what you're
picking?
Like there are other standard systems
that they know that estimating is. Yeah,
so for because I did estimating where I
was at and we created.
Couple of paid systems and we attached a
total the one price cost to that total
system.
I really didn't give you about Prosec.
This system cost this much to do.
That's the only point.
It's just like giving them different
options, but they're yeah, you didn't say.
We have clients.
Sometimes they clients are like,
tell me how much it would cost you to do
with sherwin-williams versus. Here's,
you know, baseline of the work.
Here's the practically Sherwin.
Here's the other. Yeah,
we hated different vendors.
'Cause you ended up with lots of left no
propane.
Yeah, you know, so all that.
Well, that's why I'm curious, right?
We just pick systems and only if the
customer forced us into somebody else's
paint when we do it.
Now now how do we figure the time for
actual thing? How do we figure that?
Is there a is there a rate we got for
that or yeah, I got,
I use just 100 square feet an hour
application rate.
So I've got two guys actually working on
that task, OK.
OK, so that's with the two guys. Yeah.
So technically aspiration over 200 square
feet application.
So then we can get back in the language
standards,
pick a size and figure out what the
square footage is for that piece.
And then we'll um.
Then we'll get the rate and will will
apply to everything so I can put in.
Or you can do it. Just go to an estimate,
put in a 11.5 point,
see what the surface area is for that.
Then we'll figure that out what that
timeline is.
Cream beside the ********. Yeah, I agree.
I mean, it's. I'll come.
Bless me at this point.
3.
40, yeah.
Also 82.
So what time should that be 82 square
feet?
Delete notes.
But you want to report it completely.
This is,
this is what I was estimating in the
network.
So if I go back into the survey now and I
double click on both the summary for
these two,
here's the thing also I'm thinking of it
right here.
What I'm seeing is this is actually done
time. Well,
I'm estimating that I'll take a space in
my account. I'm asking you for the time.
I'm still tears. So please.
Perfect.
So yeah, question is,
do we separate that kind of stuff?
Can we make a practice or can we do a
vast group?
So we need to do a vast and how do we do
that?
That's we can't contact that because we
don't even get it from.
Like there's there's no way you know how
much you have to mask until you get the
drawing and you start mask. Yeah,
no one's going to give you this long
square feet of that.
But you're saying in 8 minutes you're
going to do a point with B.
Which is reasonable. I mean,
but that's like I said,
it's it's done time.
It's time on that spray and getting that
thing on there. Yeah.
And then increase it so it includes
masking time, right? Yeah, yeah.
Don't forget the the efficiency factor.
I don't know how we want to handle that
because you say you go 100 square feet in
a home, yeah.
How you doing the 18 square feet in 8
minutes?
So that that 100 square feet an hour,
that's for two guys and then that
includes all the handling, labour,
domesting and whatever they got to do is
get that piece from a prep to paint to
finish paint.
But this year,
this is just calculating from what I see.
It's just calculating. I'm on the go.
Well, so does that,
does that 100 square feet an hour include
cleaning as well? Yes.
So maybe cleaning is going to be separate.
So we we had that.
Separate from that,
we said how much you work per square foot.
Oh,
the problem with cleaning is it's a set
time.
You're talking about thinking like to
paint in your palms and that kind of
stuff. No, no, I'm sorry. It's for.
Correct. So no,
that 100 square feet does not.
So that's that's essential.
So once it's done correct,
they go to the painting phase.
That includes their basking sometimes,
setting up their pump, yeah,
grabbing their material,
parking up a little desk,
all that kind of stuff.
That's obviously the paint. Yeah,
that's our square feet program. Yeah, OK.
So yeah,
I mean that it's the problem is that it's
really, it's pretty lumped up together.
Yeah, that's that's the problem.
That's why we're getting that high of a
rate compared to this and that high of
permission.
I'd like to be able to get it down to
break it up, but.
Yeah, it doesn't serve your purpose.
I guess not really. OK,
if it doesn't serve a purpose,
I'm sure if you've got it right there and
we roll with it,
just that efficiency factor,
if your default efficiency factor is 75%.
It's going to be above that up another 25.
So you're basically going to be up to 25.
Excuse me,
there will be less than 75 per hour.
So they want our efficiency factor to be.
90 or 95% for when we plug in this bid
and get our numbers tailored to closer to
accurate where we're shooting for 9 to
95% versus hitting an accurately in 75.
So,
so the way you want to put it in the 100
square feet and then I'll put it at 100
right now and then see what we actually
get for this. Like I said,
the biggest thing is tracking the guys's
actual time. I mean,
we put the budget and we've gone years
ago to apply it to.
But if you have this, it's a toss,
not how far they actually follow.
But when we have this,
if we start tracking it actual in
sequence,
we'll be able to dial those numbers and
adjust them as we see through.
I'm still confused.
You're saying it's 100 square feet in an
hour to paint?
That's what we're saying. Yes.
And here we're saying that this, this,
this is a book value.
We're going to put this in.
This got pulled in for whatever database
are, but you're about to put something in.
All right, good.
Yeah,
let's see what you're going to put in.
So that was what, 82?
It was 82 square feet,
so it'll be 48 minutes.
Now you can pass that to all of your
response, just to let crap out.
We can pass that to every everything else.
I said keep that for after.
That was just the case.
And then it scales in for length too,
right? Yeah. So I'll take that back.
Good to be like more operations right
there.
Let's just make sure it gets by the
square. Yeah,
by the painting a surface area,
some extrapolation back. So yes,
so it's going against piece and it's
going to surface area of each piece and
and make that rubber shrink.
So yeah, OK.
Why did it not calculate that number?
Already. If I could be able to put in 48,
if we knew 100, if we knew 82,
why didn't it do the time? Well,
because it didn't know 100.
So at this stage it didn't know 100,
right?
It it just had the the can down in it.
And so now that it knows that once we say
send and everything else,
it knows the fact that we want to use and
then it'll use that.
I was a little bit of everything, right?
Well, that's one.
It's only one operations.
So like to do that for angles, plates,
tubes as well.
Did you get that same square footage
right, regardless of its shape?
This is the same number, yeah.
We use 150 just to let you know that was
my safe number.
I always got burned on the plane by
always to.
That's that's that's why I'm using the
because you see all that back also there.
Thanks.
But what this system will let you do,
you correct me if I'm wrong,
you're selecting the shapes where the 100
flies.
Select the shapes where something else
applies.
We could, yeah,
we could apply and incorporate different
changes that we want.
So if you do like everything round was
this and everything not round is that you
could do that there if you want to.
Because eventually when you do the
closeouts,
you're going to start seeing which ones
are 100 and which ones take longer.
You're going to see it.
Do you want me to take the questions?
We got.
We got to do it.
We talk about this for paint, the paint,
blast, all of them.
So blast is set already the paint that
again, we got to set it for.
There's five types of material in here.
One is beams, which includes channels,
beams.
WTS anything be like we got a bit for
angles,
we got a bit for plates and tubes as well.
OK, so that's how the extrapolations work.
So you could have the separate factors
for those families and categories and
then push them out. Yeah,
but in reality you could have a you could
have a different factor for every single
size of every single.
Well, you're in warranty,
but the way we're doing it, yeah,
we're pushing that by family basically,
so.
That's one angle.
This is that 40 square foot per 140 foot
piece and currently oh, but same,
let's see the length up.
There's a pain hurter.
It.
On a start for Neil 10 square floor.
It's 4.
35 that the wall simulator or that's what
we'll see there.
So for chains for your foot, the fixes,
yeah.
Mm.
So all angle will be judged in terms.
Yeah,
but that's the default that it uses to do
that track motion. So yeah.
So what happens when he has that lock
screen job up there? What's the intent?
What's it's?
Where is this data coming driven from?
Which one of those categories?
The the plant, since it's.
I'm assuming it's about the plate there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shouldn't that be 16?
10 minutes, 10 divided by 6016,
what you have to divide.
So 10 square feet to do 100 square feet
an hour, so it's .1.
That was going to be about a six to be
given percentage.
How many minutes it takes to do 10 square
feet?
How many times to do it?
How many minutes does it take to do this
piece of ankle? Yeah, 46 inch square feet.
I do that on this work on that way.
Mm-hmm.
So that is something else. OK.
Come on, give me.
No, I think you just took a tent.
I'll sort of it backwards here. Yeah,
you you skipped what's there.
But.
40 foot on it.
How many more schools here?
19 Yeah,
I don't know how you thought it was only
that come up with that recently.
You're probably there right now.
We use 53.333.
You're still very confident in the 1st to
show up.
32 minutes.
They're not telling ****.
That is the penance to do that.
That's what I've I guess because that are
changing unless there's a labor in stage
in there.
That's right.
Any estimators not in the estimator?
But.
So I guess it's more of a question,
but anything that's going to be done here
at the shop needs to be estimated.
So is Matt going to be estimating the
shop stuff for your Tecla and kill stuff
for your take a job and make a good of
whatever since I was talking yesterday.
Like it's start, then it's.
That's something we will with the scores
only.
Then we'd have to have Matt do it or have
one of those guys anyway.
It's the same I'm saying,
but even in here it doesn't.
It's the guesswork out. I mean,
that's the whole point of this is like
anybody.
That's the whole point of this small
lesson.
We do it based on your numbers here.
I'm sorry to say you're.
Why are you sorry to say that?
Is it frustrating?
It felt like it was a hard tilt swallow,
but they have.
I just want to make sure.
It's going to be a current curve,
but I would like to get started since I
get something grand with this.
This one we got one one when you.
Yeah.
All right, please.
So what if you have a contract for the?
250 square foot.
How can we build that here?
OK.
So maybe we need to drop that.
Start with that.
Is that other circle includes the two
guys? Yeah.
So we probably will take that two off of
there so it doesn't double up on that,
right? And it's going.
Am I thinking you correct?
Yeah,
so if that's if that's the time for the
two guys,
one guy spraying a little guy on the pot,
then yeah,
so when I get a I get a job that's 1000
square feet,
I'll have 10 hours paint that.
Then those 10 hours essentially going to
be 5 hours of painting and five hours.
Yeah,
we need to take that out of the house.
So how does that affect the schedule?
It's also been sent to the battles
regardless. Yeah, right.
It's contracting for a matter,
but the most people are saying for the
other one. Yeah, yeah. Well, no,
it'll be excited. No, it'll be.
You said how many, how many guys got out.
It gave me your capacity.
It's 600 hours capacity,
but not like it's being utilized.
That space is taken up for 10 hours on
the schedule. If it's out, yeah, here,
you'll be here. Look at that that way now.
No space is going to be important.
As you see, the resource.
It thinks the resource is 1,
even though we know the resource is 2
guys. Yeah,
so you have your pool of hours,
you have your 10 guys running 10 hours,
you have a lot of hours,
but and then you're just pulling 10 out.
So you're you're houring your work
capacity, but if we're looking at space.
I'm just thinking ahead.
We might stop digging inside and we're
going to be trying to figure it out.
I mean also goes down the drive.
So the the the new planner,
the the newest schedule in there,
it it can do the the,
it can do the capacity two different ways,
either hours.
4 tons that doesn't give you space,
but it gives you some other factor,
you know what I'm saying?
So and you can talk between the two.
And it's all factored in production,
but I break.
Let's set up a list. You know,
first I'll add something in there real
quick and we'll see where it comes up.
I will have to cover it quickly.
What do you want to get the shot
efficiency there?
And I'm also coming to be against 75% of
investment independent. So right,
they will need to change the payments or
pay systems or point systems. OK.
Look, look complex and you really can do.
Do you know the hours on this job?
I do still spec in background,
still spec in high songs.
So you can change.
You can change one of them to these.
So are you, are you saying that here?
Are you a little class stating shot?
I'm just going to put both of those on
here, OK?
0 SP6.
Go back to your clean system real quick
just to make sure you understand if all
you're going to use on this job is SP6,
you don't need to do a system,
it's just going to use some drop down up
there.
But if I need to choose between SP6 and
SP3 for different pieces,
then I won't do systems,
but otherwise leaving it like that,
you're just going to get SP6 so.
And.
I build systems for all these different
codes and it gives me a breakdown first
for coat. Well, it gives you a breakdown.
Here's the type of gallons and cost for
the page.
Here's the total hours that you got to
that as well for each coach or the the
the hours you're going to give is going
to be the total hours for the bank.
Now we can filter, we can get that, yeah.
So we can filter with that and we can
just the nagrotoxy and we'll see here's
total for just nagrotoxy.
No love today. Oh God.
Let me help me back here.
When you hear me in my desk and you see a
Lego that flying across the room,
this is what's talking about. Yeah,
you haven't been in my office. Yeah,
they got Legos all over my desk.
I think I remember from last time.
Yeah, I got a T-rex in me. It's awesome.
See.
That ******* basketball's doing that.
Guess I can't go out there with not much.
Yeah.
That's me.
I'll see the leg over there. Oh,
that's awesome. I've got, uh, the uh,
storming night.
In here as well, on the map, one of the.
Yeah.
Is this something only or is this bad as
well? That's bad as well. Did you ask?
They're going to.
He's going to rise to make this one to at
this one too. I've got to.
Yeah,
all three of those are almost $300 a
piece and inexpensive.
I didn't think about it all the years,
but for the zoning projects,
probably to create.
A labor committee that only includes pain.
That way the package will be globally
applied. I think it's going there.
You just pick where you see things you
want and then it doesn't have all the
other faculty.
No,
you don't have to switch everything in
the AA.
Yeah, and lots of other,
I'll probably do a P&
T or something like that.
And they just have to thank labor
operation. That's it.
See one of these days it might get in
here.
Keep on to your start.
8.
Don't spend it.
OK.
Well, it's set up. It's set up.
It doesn't show up on a line.
That was here,
so 100 square feet per hour.
So correct me if I'm wrong,
but this fabricated job.
So fabricated job that you was gonna have
unloaded and loaded and everything
included in that.
So if you paint on top of that,
are we building up on a load and
unloading some of that in on that? No.
Receiving in the material,
moving it from the lay down of the
process and take it out and then putting
it back to their finished.
And then for us it's taking it from there,
putting it out, laying it out.
And then we got to put them in either the
contact points or depending on how it's
got to get sprayed,
either depending on the material or what,
what. OK,
is that what you get through print and if
we have to move from one station to the
other,
so we have our own handling portion that
they don't have.
Say we've got 100 square foot per hour
for the paint,
but we need to add in load and unload.
I don't think so. We can add them in,
but I'm not going to have any kind of
rates or quantities because it's all
built into the paint and prep.
But if we add the men,
we can have the guy start tracking to
that and then track an actual thing to
paint and see what that delta is.
We can do a,
we can do what's called a labor code
review, which just picks.
Labor and we could we could use the load
and unload that's already that they're
already using.
We say load and unload and paint.
That's the only only three categories we
would get.
I don't want to do that at the beginning
because I already have 7.
Rate production rate for my pain and my
prep and then I double up by adding
happened to it.
So you're putting the 100 square foot
dozen where you're standing there.
So at the end when they grow on the
structural thing we are doubling up on if
it's a structural.
If if we're going to fabricate the job,
it's going to include loaded and unloaded
in that.
So if the fabricated job they have their
own loaded bundle from receiving the
material in to processing it,
depending on what process they use until
they get it to their finished document.
So if it's only a fast job,
they had done for all their voting,
it's done. Yeah, I get that.
But what's exciting is to go to, right?
How do you define load, unload, load,
unload the truck? Yeah, the truck,
the truck comes in and I've got to unload
it and say you can find loads and loads.
I think you can move that's that's my,
yeah.
So the the fabricators send you,
let's say show,
show sends you a truck load steel and
somebody asked me that he's about to drop
seven days somewhere.
Is that account for the 100?
Under script. OK,
so then should we in coding's only job
add more time for that?
If they're going to be tracking shipping
receiving signed two jobs,
I guess that'd be.
So then in that labor code you probably
want low.
It's one of the guy charges time to when
he unloads and coming on together.
So you need to do that or I mean a lot of
times they'll charge the overhead and
just spread that basket out across every
actual project for the year.
Yeah. So it sounds like a pizza. Yeah.
Well, and you know,
I'm not trying to re read the wheel.
I'm also part of that is when you go down,
right.
If you're bidding it at 100 square feet
per hour, then we're having two beds.
Screw you up and get all you making money
at it the way it is, you know, and so.
And then with the high school reference,
hit my mind to be there.
Some would consider it.
Yeah, they just was too solid to ask.
It was going to like 8 or 10 assemblies.
And there with this one.
And it was exported from this production
system, so.
How does it benefit us to add the
handling code in there for our stuff and
then load on load?
OK.
No,
the main thing is so when these get
imported and it'll make more sense when
we look at it,
all of them are gonna be a code AD
associated with them,
which is gonna be the default tab like
your code,
which is gonna have material handling.
And cutting to the length and everything
associated with running through
production.
What we need to do is create a tone to
paint so we can globally edit all of the
assemblies so that they have paint code
which swirls.
Take into account the coding system that
we have removed the production factors
and we need to make sure that we're
including a load and unload for shipping
side of it or do we not load and unload
for that side of it so.
Because it's definitely right now it's
gonna add material handling,
load and unload,
cut to length and I think there's only
three cut size material handling load and
unload.
With the standard game that's going to
associate with what I need, so.
One of these things we'll be able to
check this out before today.
I really estimated estimating all the
paint and all the handling we're talking
about.
Were they even using tech loaded to do
the rest of the material? No, no,
they're all the spark foot is memory.
That's the.
But they're only pulling the square
footage number and applying one number to
it. Yeah,
are they mainly tackling the square
footage?
I got we got a spreadsheet that has a lot
of stuff built into it.
Not everything on it works, but.
We do some steel.
I'm able to use it for tanks.
That's right.
I've heard there's a they run it through
a program that automatically pulls off
sticks and it pulls off the square
footage based on the autonomy.
Is that correct?
I know there are programs,
not this program. No,
I know there are programs when going into
the drawings. It'll say, oh,
I got so many W 14, five, whatever,
so many WA,
so many W 10 and it will calculate all
those.
And then you know the square footage
already and it prints it out and hands it.
Yeah, that's kind of like that. Yeah.
And there there isn't a lot of companies
using that.
I assume that that they're using it here
because when I was talking the other day.
This job we're going to be looking at,
they said, oh yeah,
automatically get all the stick down.
It's like you go to outside detailers and
these outside detailers do that all day,
every day. They they sell an estimate,
an estimation package to where you don't
say exactly how many sticks there are,
which size and how many square feet.
It's happens all the time.
It's been happening for years.
So I have to assume that and I have met
with our estimator,
but I assume that that they're doing that.
So they already know the square footage
right now before they ever even go into
the program.
It's my assumption, but I I don't know.
No, not not for fillings.
We have never used that.
And when we steal stuff like this,
we either go to Gavin or we go to Ron. OK,
hey, I need this information. But see,
I think Ron, you really got the same.
I think he utilized the program.
I could be wrong.
I'm like as long as he's always trying to
screw me. So I didn't shoot one.
I haven't even been up again.
Is the 95 cents a square foot good for
you? Give me a give me a break.
I love that 95 cents a square foot is and
let me give you the price.
I have an AI tool that works well for
structurally. That's right.
It it doesn't hang up as engineers
connections,
as the connections in goes the model on a
workshop. It's unbelievable. What's that?
It's called COG.
I've actually developed and I was.
I was having to set up this and they
they're like,
we got to get set up to get work.
And they're like, well, let me show you.
So they built it and they're selling it
as of January 1st.
It's on the label on shop,
so but now what's it's? What's it?
Was it grabbing it from PDF? PDF.
It's grabbing it from PDF. Yep, Yep,
it's pretty great.
I'm sure it's pretty great.
There's another one out there that's been
happening for a while called Um.
Gosh, the software is called. Yep,
I'm trying to think of the company name.
Um.
You know,
they've been out there for like a year or
two probably, but they just do sticks.
They don't do connections. They do,
they do columns and beams and you have to
tell it how big, how,
how long the columns are,
whereas SkillG does it all.
It figures it all.
It's the top speed when figures it all.
A lot longer than you can do with these
new programs. OK, yeah, the new programs.
I have never used them.
I've been hearing about them.
I've been in Arizona too. I just have.
Yeah, yeah, I'm I'm shocked.
They're they're in vain right now,
probably about 28 months. I saw them.
20 of my clients on on the beta version
though right now,
but as of January 1st they're out,
it'll be automated in sale.
I will take over the world when it comes
to the structural estimation.
Thanks.
It was loose.
Yeah, it wasn't this night yesterday.
Yeah, we have gathered today.
This is the sweater's fault.
I had three other councillors that didn't
want to.
That.
Um,
I don't see any more promising than you
want to. For her residence,
Josh would be doing, for example,
like that. I think it wants to be.
Let's make one. Did Oxford building. Yeah,
he doesn't. It's probably getting.
You got 2 hours and 180 books to get this
****. Well, I mean,
you review all of yours.
All my jobs, you can, you can't do that.
Well, that's what I'm saying.
So he's got to review all of them before
it's sent out. He was like.
Actually something is asked.
Sketch back to your left. Thank you.
There's coding involved.
They're a little bit more mature,
but they they grew so quickly.
I think they quit developing.
What they're doing today is pretty much
what they've done in the past,
which is columns and beams and no
connections.
It does not be able to follow that and
then garnish. I mean,
it looks like there's 5,
five of them just like that. Yeah,
but I don't see still taking.
They probably are not.
They are actually similar.
I'm sure if you want to see it, sure.
Probably.
Yeah, it's anywhere over here,
it seems like.
All 13 entries.
The last time you started,
you thought people down here,
you would expect to go check.
This time I'll sit here and pick and work.
He told me there was a dedicated gigabits.
Line to the server.
I asked the question this morning for the
pipeline problem.
That's what I was wondering.
He says it's barely using it.
But yeah,
we looked at all the all the surrounding
on there and it was not even barely
glipping.
Because I thought it might be your pipe
is too small,
like you had a one MB pipe and it says
you got gigabit pipe. Yeah,
it's barely even.
It's barely even anything you know.
Not in my computer. That's in our server.
I got.
Do the beast.
The reason they actually took away my
ability to install anything was because
this is a game.
This thing runs to me about the tank's
like, you need more.
That's good. Yeah, this one's my 3D model.
Honestly, it was called tech support.
I have a 3D model.
I was like 40 people are running this on
this app.
So it's special requests.
I said I'd be good to this because I
wouldn't get any.
Probably not having the technology issues.
This is a beast.
So they have a Ryzen 9 gear. I got a 4090.
I've got 64 gigabytes of RAM.
This is single 10 standards.
Who did you ask? That's OK.
That's all I mean for the guys that do
heavy bottling,
but we're really going through big models,
you know that.
Yeah, what do you,
what do you go through the models with
Intacla or do you use Natasource Intacla?
It's supposed to go to AutoCAD on my
computer. Also Atlantec software.
They I get for 3D models of each art that
I'm processing and all the all the CNC
files are going to be at the end of
running.
Hot cuts and weird intricacies, so.
Just a while on this.
It's given this thing on for its money.
Well,
we'll get rid of the I don't like the
difference going to the.
So you say end up price control,
go to price control,
just right from the grid. Dump that sale,
probably import that sale,
see if there's anything different.
2.
Should make a difference.
See you right for this.
Yeah, all these fun ways I get,
they don't supply any files,
so I'm manually import them in the new
storage as well and then we'll have an
estimate because I like make sure I can
take production a lot better than I try
to submit.
But I checked to see if but still we're
doing this seems to be before when it was
completely frozen I couldn't even go and
go. So it's not it's server issue.
It doesn't seem yeah but.
What space structural do you guys do
versus others? I think it's a good mix,
but we got a lot of structural coming in
here for the last part of the year and
the beginning of next year,
so the SMC coming up.
It's going to be a lot of.
So let's see what's.
I need a lot more backs up. You might.
I'm sure that I'll take off start for me
that you can tell us about any of that.
I have one that I have saved in my notes.
I can't remember if it was from the last
time.
I don't know how much the expectable cost.
I guess that we go behind this one say
from the last time we were here.
I don't know how much we are jeans.
Super expensive, but.
It's fine. If it's, I'm here 40% of a uh.
Basically it's my salary. So if I can,
if I can and I'm here that you,
I haven't got clients that are using it
and they were,
they're saying they were getting out
about three times the estimates.
So if I can spend 40% of an estimator
salary to get three times more estimates,
I'm doing good. So yeah.
I don't hear how much it cost,
but not sure,
especially when we get some of these 3000
ton periods that are due the next day.
Yeah, please ship this out.
I'd like an answer by tomorrow morning.
Yeah, those ones are.
That's where that's coming on the same.
Still,
it doesn't just give you the thing off to
your board and it includes the labor.
It's crazy. That's fun.
How many people do you think are working
on back home?
Two or three? Yes. How many?
How many estimates are we up to now?
That's the thing. It's people,
people with Colorado.
This facility for well,
just flat for Southwest. No,
not just that.
OK.
Yeah.
It's three or four.
I think I've got a third pocket in here.
Kernel. I see things and I just.
I mean,
we'd be able to tell because they're in
here. We go to, we go to the estimating.
Adam doesn't work here anymore.
Admins kind of roll over here.
I don't even wanna something.
Ben doesn't work here.
Boo doesn't work here.
Building, building, building and ice.
What are you going to do with all these
guys?
Ross Harding. He works here. Ross Harding.
I'm working here. You just mentioned.
I'm well-being. I've become a Mohawk.
Why?
Because he had him a lot when he worked
with Sheffield, man. What's that?
How was he? Oh, oh, honestly,
he didn't last very long at Sheffield,
man. What's that?
I didn't want to get very bad about
people.
He was what? As a he's a good guy.
I like him. Yeah, as a person. But he was.
I can't ask the problems,
but he'd rather spend the whole day on
how things are wrong. Mm-hmm.
Figure out exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, it lasted a few months. Yeah,
you told me to wait for two minutes.
A lot of work was studying all that.
I was glad when Eric came, I was like,
hey,
someone gets to use all the nice
equipment.
Oh,
he was adamant about working with
component first, right?
He wanted to do that over there too.
We just,
we don't want to say that's working on
when it's there'll be in the office.
It's a mess. Besides working from home,
I got two boys chilling on the feet like
me. You stop bringing a policy.
The long rolling soon,
it like put in a no dog policy.
So I can't bring my dogs in here anymore.
This used to be a chill.
And you sent me the the.
You might still get support.
I thought it was.
Oh, shut down. We restarted the upload.
Yeah, yeah.
It's good.
And we're trying to get the whole shot on
this. Yes, this is not an issue.
It's not sure.
It looks like an issue today or yesterday.
Don't ask me.
You guys are aspiring. This is a fixable.
I haven't gotten.
Yeah, problems in IT.
It's Reach up.
I've had him try to fix it twice and he
says every time.
Oh, oh, I've never seen that area before.
Our biscuit people, they're like, yeah,
we've never seen that. And then that's it.
And they don't.
That makes sense to the biggest thing.
Cool. Yeah, yeah,
he's even cooler than 98.
Other than that, though, it's very good.
But we've been asking.
We used to have somebody here full time.
We had a person here because before
Gilbert,
they were in an office down the street.
So, so that the volume, the song revenue,
the problem is separated.
We have a person here full-time private.
It was even though they hired one guy to
work out and hired another guy.
That's not that's not Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy.
My daughter is working for the the
attorney and spent Jimmy the so she had
to get taken off the case. Oh really?
Yeah, Tom said this ago.
I don't think I expect you to.
I can imagine if you were here. Yeah.
Second,
I've come in the office to talk about how
to use the cyber security,
cyber security stands.
I call it something before Ox and some
emotion. I'm like,
he's a shy figure every time we go and
get drinks.
Talking about how he's got all this money,
he's driving all these fast,
fancy cars and he can order all these
Patrone shots and be like, I'm like, oh,
**** me,
I got to get something clean as little.
I'd go out drinking, you know,
make friends with my team. So it's off.
It's off, so.
No, I wasn't.
They make it too easy for me.
So when Jerry wants something,
he just text me a picture of his credit
card. He's put it on this. What the hell?
Yeah, and it's only the chair. It's a far,
sure.
Jamie's perfect for all the business
accounts. Thank God you distrust me,
but I was a part of both of them when
they.
There,
that was having trouble and helping out
with cleaners property and Jimmy's are
still working bartender and he's living.
The important anything question control
since you.
Nothing.
Bye, bye.
Sends everything.
Hello.
This is now taken a while.
I don't think so.
And pretty much everything manual.
It's last Thursday.
I don't think we got any.
Yeah, this is.
You can text my mom and I can say, hey,
there's somebody on this. We're done here.
Yeah, it should be.
And that's life's of the right tray.
We send it over.
I don't think it's going to be.
Yeah, the $100,
000 word with them and they didn't answer
for John's information. I guess we should,
we should,
we should have been pushing them.
The only invoice being pushed through for
is that.
The one year $4000 one.
They're trying units for **** that told
them to not publicly.
Did you see that one?
I sent it on Monday because she sent it
to us. Replacements.
It looked like replacements,
but they actually built. It's like.
Sure. Yeah.
You said all the there are three of them
in there.
I don't think the other two are in.
None of them are from me. Oh, yeah, yeah.
She's e-mail us on Saturday.
I'll sit there on my P chase.
You're not thinking about work.
And then count. Well, thank you.
Yes.
Oh.
Alright.
So that's why I give you.
Well, is there another job in here,
but we can do that same as I have that
file that I'm trying to import is this
right here. This is just the one I did,
so.
For that,
I know I can just make the adjustments
reporting.
Because, yeah, that's a good few.
Off really, it's like.
We report it. Almost. Almost.
When you get it, I'm sorry.
Oh, I don't think I can talk to you.
Although Task Manager did his.
Is what CPU is moving on.
That's not.
Do you have Internet connection?
I know you're hard wired in.
Are you getting? You're on a test,
you get something.
And can you tell the number of users we
talked to? Yeah, yeah, if it's,
if it's not,
I'll give you next to this brief.
I was having people whoever's left in and
somebody else could be running some
ridiculous thing in the background.
So even then, when we've had 15 months,
we're all actively showing on that.
And we're going to have some, you know,
hundreds of employees and.
No issue. Well,
it's just listing every operation,
probably.
Wow, it receptor you do now.
Here.
That's really not too tall for you to.
Everybody, everybody thinks it. Well,
I also think we should create another
estimate.
Go into that current estimate and push
your life lever to another estimate.
We can do that. We're getting better.
Let's see, I'm guessing.
What's the main problem? It's like,
oh my God, here it is.
No shipping or receiving, you know.
Yeah, that's that's.
What are you talking about this?
How many personalities are you behind?
Yes, you know.
And you could then put it into another
estimate.
You'd have to have estimates for you
though.
Let this go.
9 minutes listening.
So what's the thing? Where? Where are you?
I think they should get that's funny
times before endos, right? Yeah,
only the other day.
He's like, oh,
all the boys and the triple trucks out
here. I'm like, whoa, that's our seat.
I mean, he's awesome. Well,
what about the straight metal now?
Awesome.
You know where the logs do in here in the
default? Yeah, let's open it up.
There's an error login layer.
To change it, switch everything.
Let me see that. See that.
Let's see where we're at.
No, I have to.
So we've got according up with you.
You can tell a play on that while, right?
Just anywhere in the white there, yeah.
Not sure which one.
Open one of those top two.
Oh yeah, the way at the bottom.
Oh.
And.
Like the matrix. Excuse.
OK.
This is what's the database.
Yeah, I see. So, but let's cycle.
Let's do entertainment.
I think it's like getting a lot of stuff.
Yeah,
the record law is kind of what we're
getting.
Walkway.
And if I move at 12, take on a second.
This I'm gonna sounds,
so what's up will be?
Open.
Thank you.
I just can't do it. What?
Can you do a little motion?
So this is my God. That is what this is.
It's every single.
Go to another.
Let's see what's in the end.
I'm not sure what the difference is
between 22 megabytes.
It's huge problematic, except.
Application is.
I'm thinking something's wrong with.
Yeah.
And which means what? Bad install? Maybe.
I don't know. I mean.
I'm I'm not not T gas.
I'm I'm just I mean,
I know that this were happening anywhere
else. Tecla would be just, you know,
down there. They would be, yeah.
I mean that that.
If I were shooting from my hip,
I'd if I'd reinstall a signal in the.
See this.
So really.
Hello.
OK.
It.
Yeah.
It is. I think that's the problem.
I shouldn't. I can't.
This biology here wants to be treated.
We can.
Is.
I'll reply back and everything looks good.
Yeah, you're call prospects.
You want to call on the against the Green
Rover.
Yeah,
little bumping model wasn't even there.
It's only we said I'm coming tomorrow and
that's the old thing. No, that's not how.
I don't see what your issue is.
Spock me a little box.
What's the difference between sitting
there and sitting at home?
I don't want to be active with anybody.
What's he gonna do?
It shouldn't be now.
It's not lost in your house.
That's reasonable place.
You'll never have to give me a ride.
I want somebody to go over once you get
home. Just leave on the left door anymore.
Yes.
I guess something we can mess around with
is labor units.
You have any things that are going in
there? Yeah, yeah, let's try it.
Since everything else,
someone's just giving us relief.
Yeah.
I have to speak to come tomorrow for
electrical and efficient and working with
the new home.
And that's one thing I need to follow is
to see if they actually successfully
created that secondary.
As of this morning,
it didn't sound like it. Talk to me.
Then we're going to have to push that
home.
The whole operation. We need to.
We probably should find out in the next
half an hour or so. I mean,
we can send out a message. Well, don't,
don't tell them this,
but if worse things are worse,
so I can pray to.
And then if we'd like to be,
we can transfer that to the original
later day, such as the bill. So, so.
Guess we're going to have to make one for.
Yeah, yeah.
So what do you want to call them? OK.
Sounds good.
So then, yeah,
this goes back to the question,
do we leave unload and load in there and
then we.
Just make and pay and make everything
else out. I'm going to do with just that.
No, we keep the load.
So they have pretty much the reserved.
Well, not dollar values the same,
but I guess it's just quite amount of
time. So yeah,
it's based on the calculations and then
basically materialized.
So we went to that labor of our.
One man hour per 100 square foot against
the hingles being made,
all of those associated.
Now when we go into if we can ever get
you one of these sesame,
we'll apply this clean labor code to all
the items and then we'll remove.
All time and it'll remove anything
associated with production and it'll just
keep the coding stuff.
So default with our production is it has
the loading on the load assuming reading
which they're building material out and
then coding to throw on top of that and
having both in there with it being coding.
So only we're trying to figure out should.
Should we take the load and unknown
aspect out or should it be included and
then just scrub the production aspects
out? Well, here's what I don't like,
at least at the beginning is I want to be
able to see them because I'm trying to
recording the production out there to see
those base coats,
I guess you can call them,
but I don't want to talk about.
I assigned to it to where it bumps my
price up until I track it up out there to
see what it actually how much I can take
off of my pay and put it.
So you want the you don't want any any
cost on it,
but it's only cost on the pay side of it,
yes.
Just give you that visibility.
You don't necessarily have to apply the
lease to it because you'll still get your
square footage and your your paint labor.
So these will be in separate buckets of
the load and unload and you can make
justifications that's gonna put you over
the cost.
Or that something like that would be,
yeah, we can.
But if we leave it as he is,
it's going to put it,
it's going to apply the same labor rate
to those hours as it would for the pain.
So I mean,
we could set it up to do it differently.
We we have to set up, do operations,
apply those times to it and apply it to a
labor rate of 0.
It'll take some setting up and some doing,
but we can do it.
So you see the hours, but no dollars.
Might muddy the water a little bit in
some areas of the system,
but it'll show you the total hours of
everything and then whatever the cost is,
it would only be reflective of the paint
time.
So it might muddy the water to look like
it's less than what you expected to be.
And we'd like, why not do this $13 a half,
right? Or something like that. Yeah.
Will that affect the production skills
and won't affect the production safety?
Now we're building it separate. So yeah,
it might just look weird on the estimate
in some areas too.
I had 100 hours and probably $45
associated with it,
so I'm picking it straight into the
battery, but you know it was weird.
Do you want to set it up that way?
So you you wanted to make sure I'm I'm
right in explaining this.
You wanted the hour,
you wanted to see the hours for late and
unloaded but not have a cost associated
with it, is that correct?
Yes,
but so that's just so I understand this
correctly. If you have loading unload,
you already have a production factor
based what what's the load on what?
So pay is based off of square feet per
hour. What's the load based off of?
It's not square feet.
Is it bounce per hour?
Is it it's probably unless you change it
out of the boxes,
the extrapolation I can find by the light.
And it's got just like the paint,
the it says somebody did it for that,
so it's probably based off of the length.
Then going forward,
we're going to put shipping and receiving
time towards jobs.
Is that how they're going to track it?
Then yeah, then again,
I'd like to see what it allocates for
hours, but I have a zero dollar value. OK,
reason I said I don't want to cost myself
out of general. So yeah,
we can do a labor code.
Paint with just paint and we can do a
labor for the paint.
Remember,
we just keep talking about walking down
the bench and then make bigger changes.
I will. Yeah, that would be easier.
From this, from today's standpoint, yeah,
I mean,
we could give it so that we can have a
separate rate board and we'll have that
as zero,
they will take building operations for
each one. A little bit of doors. I think,
right. I think maybe for now,
let's see what it does and then if we
want to go to that, we'll go to that.
Right.
Thank you.
So it's like you're speaking.
Elements.
Mhm.
So Curtis might have to say based off of
what he sees based off of that or
textbook.
He says somebody has and it looks like it
might be gabbing.
I'm not gabbing but Mark.
As there's a table locked up by Hughes
and so.
I think our reboots probably will fix
that, but I I can't. That's weird.
I just he's not even wanted to use to
plug in. Yeah, I don't know.
OK, I don't know.
Now he's guessing for that one thing
we're looking at, so yeah.
Yes.
It.
That's him as a matter of fact. Hey.
What you up to?
Yeah,
we're we've got where we we try to import
a kiss file into estimating.
We try to import a Excel file into
estimating. We try to create an estimate,
just create it from scratch and that.
It locks up every single time. Yeah, so.
I don't know. We'll go and look. And it's,
by the way, it's not just estimated.
Yeah,
we'll have to get out to you to do that,
Gary.
I'm not. They exactly.
They're not all of the convenience.
Actually, no. Nothing's yellow. No, no,
nothing's yellow.
So there was a bunch of stuff that rained
earlier.
What's published in the or either later,
but um.
Help them good.
Yeah, no,
they aren't moving at the moment, so, so.
OK,
so you you think just restart the remote
server or?
OK. OK. Yeah, OK.
Logan.
I don't know.
We were struggling with this. I mean,
we were struggling with some stuff
yesterday,
but we weren't struggling with this.
But yeah, we have a lot of snacks. Yeah.
Really. Who's fast? It's like, no.
I guess that would be.
Yeah.
Should run smooth.
I can give it to be remembered to be,
yeah, nothing, nothing.
That's the thought.
Is everybody else like kind of like?
Yeah. Well, they don't be pretty. Yeah.
Yeah, that's fine.
Yeah.
OK.
We'll give it a shot and I'll let you
know what happens.
That's it. See you.
Yeah, he thinks,
he thinks restarting the SQL service is
gonna, which is just, you know,
he thinks that's fine for Lisa and be
better, but.
Never miss Keith and give a shot.
That's the thing is the duplication
process should be like.
But it's actually taking since last
Thursday to then duplicate the status and
they're doing some. Yeah,
there are there's a deeper issue from
then.
With three days.
We duplicate three times over so we can
just have three quorums.
You know, all that goes.
We'll try to do the same thing myself,
but.
They don't want to disconnect.
They don't do.
Oh, I mean, right.
I'm trying to get to that, go back.
I need to put them in.
We will have you play for us too,
then we play round three.
It's not.
At home.
So but I mean.
We just have to.
It's like.
Even if it's all the walls and see if
they can see something for something,
it's obviously true.
Please, please.
Oh, especially if you're about to do this.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's try and break this thing again.
So we got a response from Keith.
It's the meeting, meeting.
Holy crap.
Maybe something, right?
So I'll take it different one.
Yeah,
I heard we're trying to work on this.
I'm doing something better.
Oh, and then they're all OK.
The task set probably is there here.
Well, that's sure what you're doing.
I'm sorry. Hey, were you sleeping?
So I guess.
There's not anybody in the.
That's about the.
I'm putting that thing in there.
We couldn't get any of the.
Yeah, thousand it is.
This.
It's not up. All right.
This time it was 'cause I'm moving too
fast.
What is this?
I think you're ******* sweating. You know,
I don't think managed you're not anything.
That's fine. You're not *******.
I'm feeling pretty red roll over here now.
Getting hold up. No, I'm not.
Yeah. Oh, look at that. Perfect up. Yeah,
I'm gonna.
OK, not a risky to do that. There we go.
Well, we can test every resource,
but none of our fee systems we just had
in here and because we copied it from
this and that was all what we did the
other day. So but we can test it.
Yes.
You can just recreate the things right
here to make a match.
Are the what about the quantities on the
paints and the cost of the paint?
Yes, it's a big one time.
Very good. Awful.
Yeah, and the square footage of watches.
Let's see.
It's a message.
So I understand you're beating the door,
but we want it to be something.
I think that thing this was.
I think it was 4 and four.
I don't think we had anything done with
that.
The thickness percade was different than
the dental thickness. Thanks.
Thanks a lot. There's not one.
I got a few.
I will start mixing that ****.
130 gallons.
Yeah, it was.
OK.
It one.
I don't know. I don't know. So it's an.
Right. Yeah, we get the settings.
Probably something in estimation rating.
No.
Oh, it's a very much.
It's really good.
The second loss in the instance.
OK, I didn't see.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. I think there's no.
We may,
but you know what I see is in the box.
That's correct. Oh, it shouldn't be. Yeah,
it's positive.
Yeah, but yeah.
Yes.
No, we're still preparing time.
This one I can explain at any point where
they have we got to get burned out out
there. So go to a piece of.
Just double click on one of them.
Just click anywhere on opposition based
over on the left and go to label codes.
And for plate here again,
the formula says get rid of the burning
here.
It's due to quality maintenance, yeah,
and then all you're going to and you're
probably supposing that for the other
paint like as well.
Is that from an estimate extra or
something? That's weird. Yeah,
I think you've not paid.
You can just the one blend it to the
estimate extra. So just clear it out.
This.
That's what we're looking for, right?
Yeah, this is work too. Well,
you know what I mean?
This one.
Yes, so for this one.
I don't.
Yeah,
135 COVID hours estimated for this
originally I would have about 70 hours
currently 1208 dollars.
What we have in calculations is doing is
231 points.
At 75%.
They were about 100% towards that focus.
So just so I get this straight,
you guys estimated 70% efficiency, 75,
75% of efficiency on again,
all your jobs are within 2% of your
audience. It was yesterday a conversation.
If, but we've been asking on networks,
we we set up the so we've never tweaked
that in the report.
So any of the things that we've made to
labor have been.
I feel that it's at least my job to make
it a bus or they make it public.
That sounds more realistic than what we
really have to do. That's about legacy.
It's not much reports yesterday, though,
and all freaking right on that task.
I can get an hour or two.
173.
Look for JF 6300 for a meeting.
They only gave me 70. Yeah.
So I submitted. So we'll have 173,
but that's just, this is just paying,
right? It's putting just, yeah,
our estimate is pro for it would be about
120 total.
I need to process that.
Let's get the owners. Yeah,
to leave all your the hours that you gave
for the paint,
the paint that we put in earlier.
Instead of using the 75%,
we'd have to use 100%,
but they're going to continue to use 75%.
So you have to adjust those hours down to
get them to the right hours.
You're found right. Yep, yes.
And we'll compute it on the fab.
You can't.
You're going to change the efficiency
rate on the whole. Yes, you are.
So if you have fab, if you do a fab of 75.
Throw off.
But we have to. Yeah,
our average was to the 7,
but I think it was still 70% of 100 we
got to do. It's still high.
Percentage. So yeah, honestly,
we need the we need population.
We're still still need to think.
I've got to change the balance and
increase. Yeah, so if you have 100%,
you're up to what we're right where
you're supposed to be and then.
Adjusting. We're on.
You're adjusting one number. Yeah,
and the 2025 is to be one,
but that's all the ******* impact.
They've been using it 75%, basically.
Or the Excel file is estimating and as on
the import we get to the city where.
It's let compare.
If we we definitely tried then we have
language and convenience.
Let's lock it up.
Just it's not necessarily in this the way
you get outside this person,
not possible a lot of the new one place.
I would get it.
It should actually be good for any sort
of supports of you where it was.
We're having those options.
Everyone's time it's.
They want to hear back. I don't know why.
We did there. We don't understand.
Feel like we need everything. Yeah,
that they're gonna,
we're going to have to fit their IT
involved.
We can't even solve it. Yeah, e-mail.
Well,
we'll just try install the patch and then
we'll see if it see what it was and then
if not, then I'll scream back at you.
OK.
Is is this?
Is there some sort of node issue with it?
I'm just thinking when I go to another
slide next week, you know,
there's something I need to be watching
for. Is there another issue?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's really good.
I knew that we have seen it. This is good.
So that's pretty. That was true.
I'll get into it,
but obviously I'll stay on page 51.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
How long? Like 810 days? 10 minutes.
I'm impressive. Well,
thanks for what makes me. What?
What's he agreed to? It shows. It shows.
I don't have to be mentioning where else.
So you have to build when you say yes.
But I needed it all like.
Oh, here's the thing. Here's the thing.
They said the first 7 truck loads.
They were part.
That's the part of the chat. It's like,
I'm not going to let them talk and he's
going to give me a price. It was, oh,
you were copying on there.
$7.00 like 33,000 foot feet.
My parents start off loading steel.
I don't get it.
We process that and we're just like, hey,
you can handle more if I do.
I got a job to get this **** done.
You want me to do it,
so I'll be able to make it and it's all
over my back.
I'll just send the price and send it to
30 grand.
Bigger as I already have to.
The truck was offloaded and was walking
steel on steel. Well,
there was more handling,
more trucking built down since six.
They went out in eight trucks. But yeah,
after that I think back from them.
It's very.
I was gonna say I had to go back to
building, building. I can't.
Yeah, that is not any difference,
but I think taking.
So that's 78 objects. Well,
it was 173 to 190.
Oh, sounds like it's working.
So you're drastically different with us
at all, especially when it's.
So, so how, how would we,
how would we hire them if we put in the
hundreds for the graph?
That's that's what I'm.
Because of what we've got,
what's the square footage?
Square footage on this one is 636694.
Don't worry about 100%,
we should figure that 20% wasn't coming
down. So that's at least 63, yeah, 63.6.
He's not even here right now.
Make sure we're after that.
That's true.
So we always should be getting all of
that. So we we did what you said.
We put two different paints on this thing.
So and so that should be getting us under
20 hours.
For the smart village, how many?
How much are all of this?
We need about two.
So there's a prime intermediate
essentially.
So that would be about 6000 square feet.
That would be 100. So that's much closer.
I thought it was just.
From that thing. OK, well, yeah, no,
there's too much. OK, cool.
I'm figuring that 10 hour dolphins maybe
for the offload and offload. Yeah,
that's certainly. Yeah, it looks right.
That's the end coming. She does. Yep.
That's your support.
I had that word.
I had that word about that.
I'll love that.
You'll be there in a few minutes.
You wouldn't know. OK, you wouldn't know.
So I'm going to do it.
I'll speak to that.
So there'll be no help. OK, fine.
Thank you.
So I estimate we're not having it.
Yes.
See what I got here. Uh,
how much big is it talking idea I guess?
How much? What was?
How much pain material?
52 gallons. Look at this shot.
25,467 lbs and 47 cents. All right,
so that's the thing we got. Yeah,
we got to do.
We got to put the minimum on the abrasive
that $4400.
I'm trying to.
So that's that's 25,000. Yeah,
you said it's over the 40. No, I don't,
but it's 25,467. That's still a partial.
So all you're saying it needs to be,
it needs to be a full.
So what is that 25 or 67? Yep.
So that's like 5.8 bags.
I need to get 6 bags.
But at points explorer.
Based on the calculations for that,
I'm thinking about,
but the minimum has to be about that,
yeah.
Dude,
once we figure out how we can do that,
tell us if it just shoots it out and then
we can wrap it up. Well,
if it's building an estimate then then
that.
So here's here's what I don't want to
have if it starts giving me all these.
Note this.
Then I have to go over and manually
figure out how to place this product.
You know this last isn't how long I have
to go back and redo it.
Make it work as another pain because it's
figuring certain certain amount per
square foot.
Shoot, it's going to figure it out. No,
we can do it.
We can kind of figure it has another pain
and stand and use that brand left finger.
What?
What do you need is rent update 4400?
4400 it's every minimum water. OK,
so let's see. So when I when I get sent,
it's either by the truck load,
which has 10 super sacks on it,
but he said is 2 tons.
I can get them on consignment and get
them charge jobs per day.
So it's either be 4400 or 88 tons.
Yeah.
We're not able to do that without
painting.
It won't show up right there.
It's going to show up as another one as a
paint, basically. But I think we might.
But that's really the price of your last
media in relationship to your price we
were paying per job.
Last media is even more.
It's hugely more not right now.
So we did the central right span paying
for the inside was about 12,500,
last media was about 17,000 I think.
Right there, it's for five times.
For the micro proxy.
OK.
But as what's the matter when you got
those two kind of lots going on in the
whole system?
I'm just not used to seeing those big
numbers for last week.
There's pain.
Maybe I just am not sensitive to it.
Well, well,
I don't understand because that's what
you're getting, but.
I'm just saying, well,
we might need some of that.
It's always been a point of discussion of
should we charge,
should we charge for the full amount of
media that we need when we've taken
effect that we're using recycle sand and
pot out here.
But at the same time, if I went out,
if I can only recycle like two or three
times,
if I don't have field jobs using garment,
I don't recycle ship.
So that's always going to be that's why
I'm not sensitive to it because we use
steel grid and get 200 turns out of.
Yeah, it's a big difference.
I'll think it will take the race and make
it 0.
Let's get a let's get a pin first so you
can set it up where it functions whether
it'll take it.
So what I'm thinking is we have to put in,
yeah, we don't need,
we don't need to worry about rounding up
size that kind of functions as we don't
need to round it up. Yeah,
we're not going to round up on because
we're just using this for the shop stuff,
whatever we get it,
we'll recycle them what we use.
So it's not.
It's back.
It's back's not gonna throw the pop.
So it's fun where it is. Yeah. Yeah. OK.
It's for the field,
but they only use the view. OK, OK, cool.
Do you know how much we used to steal
shop place? Yeah,
but they didn't get a plan.
That's what we need to do.
That's what we're doing. They both guys.
Did the bank look about right there as
far as the product you'd expect to see
going back up?
OK.
No, that's OK.
Hey, what's happening? Let's see what?
Is it October? That's like a freeze.
We'll see the actual quantity of paint.
52 gallons, 52 gallons,
45 door type of steel sped.
It's very well square feet.
It's 122 gallons, 122 square feet,
excuse me.
Per gallon. So we're saying 140.
Yeah.
Should be.
Good.
Well, yeah, it's grounding up too.
Let's not forget that.
What's what's this worth?
What about 63 hundred 6366?
Then pull up that screenshot again.
141.
That's 50.9. So yeah,
that's 52 gallons on that.
Oh.
So when you quote that coverage,
no matter here, carrying waste, 50% waste.
Is the is the dollar amount per hour the
same for structural and he does as well?
It's at 65 labour rate. Yeah, right.
It's different. It should be different.
Job working shop and it was shop.
What's you guys labor rate 65?
It should have it.
No,
we charge with the big boots charger and
the little boy shop. Yeah, exactly. OK.
But it isn't different. Yeah,
we go either 55 or 60.
It depends on the program.
Brichelle, it's not right on 60 thinking.
So we need to then separate that out so
we can do paint and and prep at a
different rate and that's the hard part.
We need adjusted.
So like this chef TSMC job.
Um, we went in at like.
40 sometimes so that our after mark up
towards 65 because they will not budge
from that number.
So technically I think our actual.
That's actionable cost plus markups,
overheads, consumables,
everything that rolls into it.
I think it's between 46 and $49,
but then markup. So it's cost up here.
It's just costly.
Yeah.
Right.
And and it is the changes and then we'd
like there's times where we get approved
to to buy down our our shop rate that
we're selling and increase our margins or
there's times where we decrease our
margins and keep our shop rate the same.
Really. I'm used to this. Cost is cost.
I've never heard of anybody changing
shoppers. Me neither.
That's up for the year.
Oh.
I don't want to ask that question. Yeah,
Jeff would do that on on some of our jobs.
That is,
that's definitely that's not his way of
operating. That's problem about him.
We're both from the issue.
This is where it just the cost is that
now usually has our overhead into it.
Yeah,
and they're so they're trying to separate
that out into separate line items and new
estimated software they're doing.
So we're allowed to go lower,
especially in procore to put a lower cost
if we account for that,
if we put an incentive of item for admin
for all the other stuff, lines for admin,
lines for management, lines for.
Why not? Probably. Probably.
I guess we're trying to take the cost of
part different consolid.
It lets you be you're not charging.
You're not charging.
I'm not saying the difference between
what let's say bid to when they got our
actual cost for a craft.
The difference between those two prices
doesn't essentially cover everything.
Or along with one scale, that makes sense,
but.
So you you got 135,000,
130 hours public labor.
Our actual cost to save support,
it's at 55, so that 15 by 135.
Whatever number it gives you,
it may be much more than it would be for
that. Some companies do.
They have their base rates and they have
a indirect rate, they have a direct rate,
no direct overhead rates,
and then they have a more go after that.
But it should be pretty much universal
across the company, right?
No matter how how they're going to do it,
those three rates, the rate, interaction,
the direct,
they should all be the same and not
change.
And then what should change is the market
idea, right? And that's way, yeah.
So we don't even look at the market.
It's the same thing.
And we work with the margin. Yeah,
it's just a little different,
but you're trying to get to your true
manufacturing cost.
The manufacturing cost is broken out into
those buckets that you just described.
They've got the cost in.
You freak it out.
Are you still covering all this?
Is this one wrong or is this one wrong?
Yes, but to put it simply,
so we have K we just submitted the
proport was 5.2.
They copied the exact wines in the man
Allison in Connecticut,
didn't learn by this and there was a
development because it was a substantial
will.
Because of the difference in labour,
that all got targeted at some of some
other stuff that you directed and
directed. Yes, and if we.
At the same time in that job,
we already had $200,000, 200,000 Atlanta.
Got it. I I understand. Yeah,
I get what's happening here.
It's because you're switching systems and
things are in different buckets. Yeah,
they didn't like double dip.
They have to look at it. You can't,
you know, right. Use this program,
all of these things.
They ought to be hard fast for like an
entire year.
And then you look back at the last year
and say, OK,
do we need to adjust the rates for the
next year?
And they put a little bit of flop in
there to cover any increase in inflate
costs over the following year.
You're usually smart people do it at the
end of the third quarter. Yeah.
So that by the time that your estimates
start hitting the ground in the first
quarter,
it's already picked up everything that's
estimated in the 4th.
Yeah.
So do we need to do a different, right?
Can we give,
can we give the operations in the 55 and
with the shop of 65,
you would have to go to 60?
What's your real cost?
Surely don't burden,
but you're real directed and real cost.
Thank you. Yeah,
that's not going to be by this,
by this group,
by use of the benefit accounting to know
as the leadership.
Personally, yeah,
that's part of my question.
If here's how that's that's two years in
the main is that that kind of job for me
to see how I want to see how we're doing
this. Yeah, you tell me. But yeah,
it has to be supplied basically every
product.
Huh. What's that?
A rate on 15 type of code.
It's a rate that shouts. So I'm not sure.
So there's a there's a rate that includes
and then there's a rate another you want
that like even when you both are being
right. OK, like that's great. That's a.
Well,
that committee doesn't know the
scientists time.
So they know who's considered to overhead.
It says non human rights.
So non productive labor is overhead.
So we got to calculate all that and the
environment that we have to take jobs in
all jobs a year and say OK,
this much percentage is to go overhead,
right?
And then you got the other directive and
direct cost,
insurance costs and cost of the building,
cost of the electric and all that,
you know, so all those and it's like, OK,
here's our rates for next year.
Let's start.
I resumed now so that we can just apply
to the right thing in October.
It would be any jobs we get now they'll
be covered for January.
So I think that's that's what I was. Yeah,
exactly the same. Sure, right.
That calculation assumes that you're
going to work.
All those man hours, the whole years,
it's a you're running, you're right,
you have to look at like the last three
years, for example, say on average,
how many hours did we work over the last
few years? OK,
do we think we're going to do that?
That over the next year and that's what
we base those things on. Yeah. So it's up.
That's a huge problem. Yeah, so, so,
but that's not us here for that.
That's at the beginning of this year.
I think Mark's team is shrunk in half,
so the total hour is not by half and
you're still not the same.
I understand with Mark's team, you know,
you've got to. So that's put up in public.
So yeah, you're right,
it would be a drastic.
Drastic,
drastic increase in overhead that that
the other guys they haven't done that.
I don't think Greg, you're right.
So you haven't done that.
I would say it's making, you know,
every company, everybody does.
That's how it's.
We'll get more money on the jobs if not a
truck that'll get or you it's more money
in your bottom line if we have big jobs.
We would cover the program.
We we don't start numbers in our own
county. That's something.
That's why I asked that question.
I just wanted to know.
Based on it,
whatever numbers that the county comes up
with, needs to be input into the system.
We're gonna estimate.
I used to do it, so yes, I catch it.
It's not a conversation for this program.
Yeah, so.
Yeah, I don't plan. So I did. I was like,
I'm going to know exactly what the same
thing I was doing. Yeah,
because that was be explained a little.
I didn't even sit there for 35 years.
That goes pretty well.
So that's that's, you know,
I don't think so. I don't know.
So probably we're going to kind of work
for start, finish.
Tomorrow we will have for just the
integration discussion.
We have a line up so we can take it with
the text.
I don't want to see what we can do with
that.
That's a pretty.
I think it's the other program.
They're heavy builder.
I have to have the right thing.
We're going to come up with electrical
components,
special topics provided that I can.
I think it's quite a while because I just
call that.
How do you get access?
You just ask the question and get an
answer.
All they have is the numbers to plug into
the program. That's all.
I think that's that's not our fault after
that.
They don't need enough work if they get
enough work. That's not not the issues.
It's like what number do you want to use?
That's what we're putting. If you want,
it's called pro forma,
which is kind of how you model, yeah.
Like we are.
And then let's see.
So we we readjust the rates, yeah,
to match 75% efficiency.
No. OK. So we we got to do that. Yeah,
you didn't do that. No, Taylor,
put that as an extra, so.
If you run it,
if you run a shop through both Fab and
Stoney's,
do you want to and you set it to 75,
but that's what works for Fab.
And his numbers are you're right,
you're absolutely. Yeah, you go,
the question is do you want to put the
efficiency on 100% and see where it then
you got to change all the shop stuff.
Shot up right now.
Let me ask you a question because this is
something I'm not.
If we want to schedule at a certain
efficiency rate,
what should we be estimated by?
Should it be the same or you always want
to cover a worst case scenario?
Estimating right?
It's like you're never according to you
guys yesterday.
All your **** comes out exactly where
you're I don't believe, frankly,
but normally you're going to want it
slightly higher than what you think your
cost is.
So yeah, maybe 75% not the right one.
Maybe 90% is I don't know.
I don't know if this could be the company
here.
I would actually see three years worth of
how many hours are estimated versus how
many hours you've actually hit.
Then I'd be almost at 90%. Shut up,
I don't believe that. I don't believe.
No, it will match up to his payroll. Yeah,
especially matching up the payroll,
because at that point, well, really, no,
we can look down with that.
That is actual, right?
So somebody's got to get actual for like
a three-year period and say yes, look.
Based on the estimate and the actuals,
here's what the difference is.
That's how you adjust your your 75% or
whatever percent you're going to use,
because like, look,
we're not that accurate. We you know,
we have guys that would go to internal
jobs.
They wanted to put their time in the tops
because they were trying to match the out.
No, it should be estimating. Hey,
we're out of hours.
Nobody's then they went, nobody's 100%.
That's enough. So it's not.
Same thing with painters.
So you generally say yourself,
I think here's what the slowest turn out
or just 10 out, right. So let's call that,
OK, keep me up. OK.
But then we can maybe have to get it on
the 20, then we're really 100%.
But that is, that number is more straight,
you know, on all of that.
And that's some reason without that,
as it is,
you're on the first job as the second job.
So that's not going to be any payable,
that's going to be on 80%.
It made it look really perfect.
That's the same.
So you made more and part of the problem
with this is estimating the value of G
and that part again. That's it.
All of our time in the shop in 10 of the
last year or two have been us calibrating
the numbers. OK, so is it any of our.
85%, I don't believe it.
It would be an existing.
I mean it would never been something that
we've ever adjusted as as as part of the
issue.
So he's only interested in what we've
never made in the past.
So it's never made an adjustment.
I've found that elector. I'll on Thursday,
oh, hey, we don't understand.
And then instead of decreasing their
efficiencies, percentage,
it's been fine-tuned to work 75%. OK,
and that's why we need to move away.
We're actually.
That's something by our system can
actually work. Plus they're going to be.
They should dial it in to.
I'll give them back one as my day at $2.
00 left over. OK, the thing,
the thing I like the road there when
we're working with this study.
I have a lot of.
Well, that's the hard part. 10 minutes.
So you have to determine that's
percentage. Yeah,
it's actually working on license.
What do you have that's important to
adjustments? I would be.
It has to be looking up and they don't
want to look at it and Michelle goes
responsible on that issue.
It does not go for jobs. They work,
they say guys,
I know you don't want to do that.
We have really good employees at that.
So you need to have a good.
Do you still run out of work on the shop
and clean it up and do whatever they're
not putting the morning tell us they
might steal your time and what they're
doing here is they're actually posting
that 900 jobs.
Are we going to raise the electrical guys
in or we're going to make sure that this
is actually.
Because they they're efficient of your.
You're cheating yourself if you don't
know what that's how it's done.
So your time studies are ******** is what
you're talking about because your time
studies,
the time studies you're doing now are
good, but if you look at a past job,
if you look at histories.
And you're going to get a time set.
Now let's say I have a job in two years
ago,
just like when I was starting tomorrow,
two years ago, look at that job and say,
wow, look, we the manage the hours,
it was, we had this, we beat those hours.
I can do that same thing here.
That's ********. We didn't do it.
We beat those hours over here, right?
That's why it's not right.
So it's like you should.
That's what the whole efficiency is about.
It should be put down as an efficiency
background. I understand.
I'm wondering how another house,
I know they don't do that, but I'd see.
Thanks a lot. What he's saying is.
As long as you're capturing the real
hours, yeah, that's the key.
Capturing the real hours,
ignore this real hours. So the problem is,
is that it's retention and if we don't
have enough hours to pay other people,
they won't stay in the league.
And that's as you slow down,
that becomes a real issue.
There's an issue everywhere.
The most efficient shops have to have
piles of work outside.
If you don't have piles of work,
everything gets less efficient. That's.
Human nature, yeah.
What he's saying,
so we got to get cheaper to get more work.
So the short answer is when we have the
discussion we have about why there's
hours you're meeting,
the reason they are is because if they're
meeting hours on the job and rather than
send guys home,
they're still posting hours to the job
even though they're not.
It would be good in my opinion.
All the other I've worked at is like, no,
those go down is overhead.
If you're going to keep them because you
got to keep them because you keep the
good guys,
you got to have some do something else if
they're not another.
Have an overhead button just for that and
just just to save the data.
You'll freak out over this,
but I'll have you if I do a shot that is
tracking down.
Really.
That was the last time I get stuck did
not track up like for 35 weeks until I
got here seven months ago.
When they walked in the door,
they wanted in and when they walked out,
it was like they wanted out.
So you know what they're getting, Yeah.
But if you look at the time they've long
time, like 40% of the hours we're missing.